COLLEAGUES FOR BEING HERE ON
TIME.
RIGHT NOW.
OKAY -- WITH MR BLOOM WE NEED
ONE MORE TWO FOUR WE NEED ONE
MORE FOR QUORUM.
SOON AS WE GET THAT.
YOU'VE GOT A COMMITTEE -- OR
WHENEVER YOU DECIDE.
ALL RIGHT.
MISTER BLOOM THANK YOU.
WELL.
UP WILL START AS A SUB COMMITTEE
ARE MISTER BLOOM YOUR MEMBER
TODAY.
YOU CAN SET UP HERE.
YEAH BUT GOSH -- MISTER GARCIA
OKAY IT WILL BE PRESENTING FIRST.
BE EASIER FOR YOU TO ASK
QUESTIONS OR WHATEVER IF YOU'RE
UP HERE [inaudible]
SO.
WILL START AS A SUB COMMITTEE
AND HOPEFULLY I GET ONE MORE
MEMBER HERE QUICKLY -- SO.
WE'RE HEARING OR A SPECIAL ORDER
A. B. TWO SEVENTEEN EDUARDO
GARCIA.
AND THEN WILL FOLLOW THAT WITH
AB.
ONE THIRTY FOUR BLOOM WHICH
ADDRESS IS MUCH MUCH OF THE SAME
ISSUES BUT BOB WE HAVE A QUORUM.
AGAIN THANK YOU MY REPUBLICAN
COLLEAGUES AND MY VICE CHAIR
[inaudible]
YES.
ALL RIGHT.
MADAM SECRETARY CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ADDED TO STAB WHICH
QUORUM [inaudible]
QUIRK.
I HERE WORK IS HEREMELENDEZ.
MULLIN THIS IS HERE BLOOM.
BLOOM IS HERE [inaudible]
BAUER-KAHAN.
DELHI DELHI IS HERE [inaudible]
CRISTINA GARCIA.
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN IS HERE MATHIS.
MATHIS IS HERE.
WHAT A TO G. MURATSUCHI SO WE
HAVE A QUORUM OF SIX MEMBERS?
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ARE NOW THAT WE'VE ESTABLISHED A
QUORUM -- PLEASE MR GARCIA OF A
PRESENT ON A. B..
TWO SEVENTEEN OF THE SAFE WATER
FOR ALL DRINKING ACT.
THANK YOU THE SAFE DRINKING
WATER FOR ALL ACT [inaudible]
THAT.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE LET ME
BEGIN BY ACKNOWLEDGING THE
LEADERSHIP OF RICHARD BLOOM WHO --
IS -- TECH TEAMING WITH US ON
THIS ISSUE AS YOU MENTIONING AS
OF ANOTHER BILL THAT WILL BEFORE
THIS COMMITTEE LOOKING AT MORE
OF THE MECHANICS THE
GOVERNMENT'S OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY.
OF OUR FUND OF THIS MATTER -- IS
USED -- BUT THIS PARTICULAR BILL
AB TWO SEVENTEEN IS FOCUSING ON
THE MECHANISM THE FUNDING
MECHANISM THAT IS NEEDED -- TO
BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE CLEAN
WATER NEEDS OF ALL CALIFORNIANS
AND I WANT TO EMPHASIZE.
ALL CALIFORNIANS BECAUSE THE
APPROACH HERE THAT WE'RE TAKING.
IS A COMPREHENSIVE -- ONE SINCE
LAST YEAR -- WE'VE BEEN IN A
SERIES OF MEETINGS WITH.
A NUMBER OF ORGANIZATIONS BOTH
PUBLIC PRIVATE -- AND ALL.
AND LIKE TO SAY STAKEHOLDERS
THAT HAVE.
US SOME SKIN IN THE GAME WHEN IT
COMES TO THIS ISSUE.
AND WE'VE BEEN HEARING A NUMBER
OF DIFFERENT APPROACHES -- THAT
THEY BELIEVE A COULD WORK. FOR
US TO MEET WHAT IS AN ULTIMATE
GOAL OF GENERATING A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS -- TO
PROVIDE THE NECESSARY RESOURCES
FOR BOTH OPERATION AND
MAINTENANCE.
COSTS AND IN SOME CASES THE ONE
TIME INFRASTRUCTURE.
INVESTMENTS I NEED TO GO IN OF
FOR THE DELIVERY OF SAFE CLEAN
DRINKING WATER.
AND SO I AM NOT GOING TO TELL
YOU YOU'RE GOING TO HEAR FROM
OUR WITNESSES THAT THERE ARE
OVER MILLION CALIFORNIANS UP AND
DOWN THE STATE.
IRRESPECTIVE OF COMING FROM
RURAL OR URBAN AREA -- THERE ARE
WATER QUALITY PROBLEMS
EVERYWHERE AFFECTING.
FAMILIES IN THE HOUSEHOLDS AND
SCHOOLS WERE OUR CHILDREN SPEND
THE MAJORITY OF THE TIME -- THE
WAY WE STRUCTURED THIS BILL.
AS I MENTIONED HAS TAKEN A
NUMBER OF IDEAS HAVE BEEN
DISCUSSED BY.
NUMEROUS STAKEHOLDERS.
AND ONE IN PARTICULAR TO HELP US
FUND -- THE NEED IS BY
ESTABLISHING THE AGRICULTURAL
FEES THAT MANY OF YOU MAY HAVE
BEEN FAMILIAR WITH.
IN THE EFFORTS THAT UP ASSEMBLY
MEMBER OR SENATOR MONEY PUT
FORWARD.
THAT WOULD ULTIMATELY RAISE
CLOSE TO THIRTY MILLION DOLLARS
AND THAT -- FEED THAT WOULD
BEGIN IN TWO THOUSAND TWENTY ONE
AT THIS AMOUNT WOULD BE PAID
ANNUALLY -- TO THE SECRETARY BY
A PRODUCER THAT OWNS MORE THAN.
ONE NON DAIRY CONFINED ANIMAL
FACILITY -- AND SO THE OTHER
APPROACH IS A FERTILIZER FEED.
THAT ALSO WOULD ESTABLISH ITS
COLLECTION AND TWENTY TWENTY TWO
AND AGAIN VERY SIMILAR TO WHAT
WAS SEEN AND SENATE BILL I
BELIEVE. SIX TWO SIX SIX TWO
THREE WE'VE ALSO TAKEN THE IDEA.
THAT MANY WATER AGENCIES HAVE
PUT FORWARD AND THAT IS THIS
IDEA OF A FUN.
A REFERRED TO AS A TRUST FUND
ASKING THE GOVERNOR.
GIVEN THAT HE HAS MADE THIS
ISSUE A TOP PRIORITY. FOR TWO
HUNDRED MILLION DOLLARS FOR THE
NEXT FIVE YEARS.
ARE ALLOWING US TO INTEREST TO
COLLECT CLOSE TO THIRTY FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS HELPING US GET
CLOSER TO THAT ONE HUNDRED AND
FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR -- TARGET
NUMBER -- THERE'S ALSO A CHARGE
TO WATER AGENCIES THAT WE'RE
REFERRING TO AS THE PUBLIC
BENEFIT WATER FUND.
THAT WOULD BE IN THE AMOUNT OF
FIFTY CENTS TWO QUARTERS. TWO
PER MONTH PER MONTH PLEASE YES
THANK YOU FOR FOR EMPHASIZING
THAT.
AND WE'VE ALSO INCORPORATED.
LANGUAGE IN THE BILL.
BECAUSE IN THE CONTEXT OF THIS
TRUST FUND DISCUSSION -- THAT
HAS BEEN PUSHED BY WATER
AGENCIES -- IT HAS BEEN SAID
THAT WE SHOULD JUST FUND THIS
ISSUE.
THAT IN THAT MANNER USING
GENERAL FUND DOLLARS AND I THINK
THE MAP SAYS THAT.
IN ORDER TO GENERATE THE ONE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS THAT'S NEEDED. FOR THIS
ISSUE YOU HAVE TO PUT A DOWN
PAYMENT INTO THE TRUST FUND IN
THE AMOUNT OF THREE BILLION
DOLLARS.
AND I DON'T KNOW ABOUT YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS IS
COMMITTEE BUT I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT THAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
HOWEVER.
IN THE BILL WE'VE ADDED SUNSET
LANGUAGE.
THAT IF IN SOME WAY.
THAT AMOUNT OF MONEY WAS PUT
FORWARD FOR THE PURPOSE OF CLEAN
WATER THAT WE WOULD SUNSET THESE
WATER FEES THE TWO QUARTERS.
THAT -- WERE ASKING YOU KNOW
CALIFORNIANS TO PUT INTO THIS
PUBLIC BENEFIT WATER FUND.
IN ORDER TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE
CLEAN WATER FOR OVER A MILLION
PEOPLE.
WE'VE ADDED A SECTION IN THE
BILL.
THAT LOOKS AT THE PROBLEM
REGIONALLY.
AND MAKING SURE THAT WE ARE NOT
JUST CONCENTRATING OUR EFFORTS
ARE INVESTMENTS IN ONE PART OF
CALIFORNIA BUT THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE STATE.
AS I MENTIONED THIS PROBLEM.
IS OCCURRING IN URBAN AS WELL AS
RURAL AREAS OF CALIFORNIA AND WE
NEED TO ENSURE.
THAT ALL THE WATER AGENCIES AND
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE
ACCESS TO THIS FUN TO BE ABLE TO
ADDRESS.
THEIR WATER NEEDS AND SO WE'VE
ESTABLISHED A REGIONAL APPROACH.
THAT ENSURES THAT 20%.
OF 1100% OF THE FUN ACTUALLY
GOES BACK TO SPECIFIC AREAS
PRIORITIZED BY NEED AS IT
RELATES TO WHAT THE WATER BOARD
HAS HIGHLIGHTED.
AS THE MOST PRESSING AREAS --
WITH THIS PROBLEM.
SO AB TWO SEVENTEEN UP PROVIDES
A NUMBER OF PAT. FOR US TO GET
TO THE END GOAL AND THAT IS TO
ENSURE THAT EVERY CALIFORNIAN.
AND EVERY CHILD HAS SAFE CLEAN
DRINKING WATER OUT TODAY YOU'LL
HEAR FROM TWO WITNESSES WE HAVE.
UP TO SIGN A DANDA CO FOUNDER
AND CO EXECUTIVE THE COMMUNITY
WATER CENTER AND METAL AND
GLITTER FEEL THE DIRECTOR
PARTNERSHIPS FOR UCLA INSTITUTE
WHO WILL TESTIFY ON BEHALF OF
THIS BILL -- DUE TO THE
CONTROVERSY OF THIS BILL AND ON
UNIVERSITY OF YES AND THE
IMPORTANCE OKAY THE COMPLETE.
AND I'VE ALREADY I'VE ALREADY
COMMITTED MYSELF TO AN AYE VOTE
GIVEN THE IMPORTANCE -- WE'RE
GOING TO ALLOW UP TO SIX MINUTES
FOR WITNESSES BUT THEN -- FOR
THOSE WHO ARE ADDING ON JUST TO
NAME ORGANIZATION AND POSITION.
SO WITNESSES PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GREAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
AND SUB COMMITTEE AND CHAIRMAN
FOR YOUR LEADERSHIP I AM SO SOME
OF THEM THAT CO DIRECTOR
ACTUALLY DIRECTOR AND FOUNDER OF
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER.
I'VE BEEN WORKING ON SAFE
DRINKING WATER FOR OVER A DECADE.
I AM HERE ALONG SIDE AND
REPRESENTING THE ONE MILLION
CALIFORNIANS WITHOUT ACCESS TO
SAFE DRINKING WATER.
FROM.
LED IMPACTING URBAN AREAS
TONIGHT TREATED OUR STAKE
CONTAMINATED INNER.
RULE COMMUNITY TAPS TO CHROMIUM
SIX IN OUR SCHOOLS.
I AM HERE TODAY ALONGSIDE WITH
MOTHERS AND FATHERS WHOSE
CHILDREN ARE SLOWLY BEING
POISONED BY THIS TAP WATER
EXPOSED EXPOSED AT SCHOOL AND AT
HOME. TO THE MOST SAFEST PLACES
THAT WE SHOULD NOT BE WORRIED
ABOUT HEARING CALIFORNIA.
IT IS TIME TO CALIFORNIA PASSES
THE SAFER FOR DRINKING WATER
FUND.
WE DON'T KNOW WHAT'S NEEDED WE
NEED A SUSTAINABLE AND PERMANENT
FUNDING SOURCE.
THAT ADDRESSES THE ROOT CAUSES
OF THIS CRISIS AND THAT IT
SHOULD AND WILL NOT BE CUT WHEN
WE HAVE AN ECONOMIC DOWNTURN.
WE DON'T NEED ANYMORE BANDAIDS
TO SOLVE THIS ISSUE.
THERE ARE SOME HERE THAT WILL
SAY THAT IF HE THE PRICE OF SOME
POCKET CHANGES TOO MUCH OR
THERE'S ANOTHER WAY TO SOLVE
THIS.
WE WOULD GLADLY PAY.
A LITTLE MORE EVERY MONTH TO
ENSURE THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS
HAVE ACCESS TO SAFE CLEAN AND
AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER.
BECAUSE WE'RE ALREADY PAYING
THIS WITH THEIR LIVES BEING
EXCEPT EXPOSED TO SOME TOXIC
WATER.
THAT CAN GET A SICK.
IT IS ABOUT IT IS THIS IS ABOUT
OUR HEALTH AND THE HEALTH OF OUR
KIDS.
I LIKE TO SAY THAT SHAME ON
THOSE THAT STAND IN BETWEEN
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE SAFE
DRINKING WATER FOR KIDS ARE
FAMILIES.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT THIS BILL IS
STILL IN PROCESS AND WE HAVE
WORK TO DO. FOR THE MOMENT IS IS
NOW I TRULY BELIEVE THAT THIS IS
THE MOST ONE OF THE MOST
DEFINING CIVIL RIGHTS STRUGGLES
THAT DEFINES OUR GENERATION.
MANY ARE FAMILIES ARE THIRSTY
FOR JUSTICE THE HAVE BEEN LIVING
LIKE THIS FOR FAR TOO LONG.
WE DON'T WANT TO LIVE IN
CALIFORNIA LIKE THIS ANY LONGER.
WE WANT TO LIVE IN A CALIFORNIA
WE CAN PHILIP GLASS A GLASS OF
WATER FROM A TAP WITHOUT THE
FEAR BECOMING SICK.
WE WANT TO LIVE IN A CALIFORNIA
WE DON'T CONDEMN FUTURE
GENERATIONS TO NOT BE ABLE TO
DRINK WATER FROM THE TAPS AT
SCHOOL AND THEN GO HOME AND I'LL
BE ABLE TO DRINK THAT.
WE DON'T WANT THAT ANYMORE AND
THE SOLUTION IS HERE.
WE NEED TO PASS THE SAVINGS FOR
DRINKING WATER FUND.
AND ALLOW THIS HUMAN RIGHTS
ACTUALLY HAPPEN. FOR THOSE OF
YOU THAT HAVE CHILDREN PLEASE
THINK OF OUR OWN THINK OF YOURS
AS YOU.
STICK YOUR VOTE TODAY OR CAN YOU
KNOW EVERY SINGLE ONE OF YOU. TO
ENSURE THAT WE CAN HAVE SAFE
DRINKING WATER.
GLASS YES THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GO AHEAD THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I MEDDLING CLICK FELD
UM THE DIRECTOR OF THE UCLA
WATER RESOURCES GROUP.
AND I'M HERE TO TELL YOU ABOUT
THE WORK I'VE DONE TO IDENTIFY
URBAN DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITY
WATER SYSTEMS IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY AND HOW HONORED I AM TO
BE STE TESTIFYING WITH SUSANNA
DE HONDA WHO IS.
A HERO IN THIS AREA -- I WANT TO
TALK TO YOU ABOUT.
HOW VOTE HOW AB ONE THIRTY FOUR
AND TWO SEVENTY ONE TO SEVENTEEN
SHOULD RECOGNIZE THE EXISTENCE
OF DISADVANTAGE WATER SYSTEMS
AND I SEE YOU FROWNING BECAUSE
IT I HEARD YOU AT THE LAST
HEARING SAYING WELL THIS ISN'T
AN URBAN PROBLEM BUT IT DON'T?
YOU KNOW I SAID IT ISN'T A
PROBLEM IN MY DISTRICT OKAY.
THANKS OKAY -- IS SO DO I AM
THERE THERE CAN WELL BE PROBLEMS
IN OAKLAND -- THAT WHERE THEY
HAVE FLED.
GROWING UP IN THE WATER RIGHT
RIGHT.
SO WHAT WHAT I'M HERE TO SAY IS
THAT IF FUNDING COMES FROM URBAN
WATER CONSUMERS THE BILL SHOULD
AS ASSEMBLYMAN GARCIA HAS SAID.
IT'S ONLY RIGHT THAT URBAN JACK
SYSTEMS IN THOSE AREAS BENEFIT
AND HAVE ACCESS TO THAT FUNDING
AND RIGHT NOW.
URBAN DECK SYSTEMS DON'T HAVE
EASY ACCESS TO THE FUNDING.
OF THE WORK I'VE DONE WITH
DOCTOR REVOLT WE FOUND THIS
THERE ARE TWO HUNDRED AND TEN
WATER SYSTEMS LOS ANGELES COUNTY
SOME OF THEM STARTED WHEN THE I
DEVELOPMENT WOULD COME FROM NO
WHERE AND THEY WOULD.
DEVELOP THE COUNTY WATER SYSTEM
JUST OF A COMMUNITY OR
HOMEOWNERS VERSION OF A MUTUAL
WATER COMPANY.
I NOW OF THE TWO HUNDRED AND TEN
SIXTY FOUR HAVE A CONCERT
CUSTOMER BASE WITH THE MEDIAN
HOUSEHOLD INCOME LESS THAN 80%.
OF THOSE. SIXTY FOUR TWENTY FOUR
ARE SEVERELY DISADVANTAGED OR AT
60% OF MEDIAN INCOME.
THEY CANNOT AFFORD WATER RATES
THAT WILL KEEP THEIR SYSTEM
RUNNING.
AND IF THEY END UP IN AN
INDEPENDENTLY OWNED UTILITY.
THEY OFTEN GET THEIR WATER SHUT
OFF BECAUSE THEY HAVE GOOD WATER
BUT IT'S TOO EXPENSIVE FOR THEM.
THIS THIS THIS THE SYSTEMS HAVE
A TOTAL OF ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND
EIGHTY THOUSAND CONNECTIONS
WHICH ROUGHLY AMOUNTS TO A
MILLION PEOPLE LIVING IN THE
SYSTEMS JUST IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY SO WHEN YOU SEE.
IT NO ONE'S EVER LOOKED AT THIS
BEFORE OR TRY TO GET A HANDLE ON
THIS SO THE NUMBERS ARE BIG THE
NUMBERS ARE BIGGER.
THEY'RE CLUSTERED IN TWO PARTS
OF THE COUNTY WERE POVERTY IS
CLUSTERED IN THE ANTELOPE VALLEY.
IN THE SOUTHEAST SOUTHWEST
REGION OF THE OF THE THE OLDER
PART OF TOWN.
CAPITAL TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE AND
OWN AND FUNDING ARE KEY TO ANY
SOLUTION SO I HAVE. THREE
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR YOU.
THE FIRST IS THAT SOMEWHERE IN
THIS LEGISLATION THAT YOU YOU
ASKED THE STATE BOARD TO
DETERMINE DAK WATER SYSTEMS.
ON A COUNTY WIDE BASIS RIGHT NOW
THEY LOOK AT CAP AT DETERMINING
ELIGIBILITY WHEN AN ENTITY COMES
INTO RISK.
APPLY FOR A GRANT.
AND THAT'S EASIER TO DO IN A
RURAL AREA THAN IT IS IN URBAN
FOR A WHOLE LOT OF REASONS.
BUT IT DOESN'T GIVE THE MOST
ACCURATE PICTURE OF URBAN
SYSTEMS AND IN FACT MOST URBAN
TAX SYSTEMS DON'T KNOW THAT
THEIR DECK ELIGIBLE YOU HAVE
ABOUT TEN SECONDS OKAY.
SO I THINK WE THAT SHOULD HAPPEN
THEY SHOULD INCLUDE THE FUNDING
SHOULD INCLUDE WORK MONEY FOR
LOCAL AGENCIES TO DO REGIONAL
DAK ASSESSMENTS AND GOVERNMENT
STRATEGIES.
AND THE TEN THOUSAND PERSON CAP
FOR ELIGIBLE DAX SYSTEMS NEEDS
TO BE RAISED BECAUSE SMALL IS
BIGGER IN URBAN AREAS.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT UP SO WE HAVE.
JUST TO BE CLEAR OUR WE'RE
TALKING THE AMENDMENT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT IS TO ADD -- FIFTY
CENTS A MONTH.
THAT WOULD BE DETERMINED BY THE
NUMBER OF CONNECTIONS.
IN OUR PARTICULAR -- WATER
UTILITY. ONE REASON FOR DOING
THAT AND FOR HAVING THE WATER
BOARD COLLECTING IT IS WELL.
IS TO SIMPLY MAKE THE COLLECTION
THAN VERY EASY THEY CAN LOOK UP.
THERE MAY BE A NEED FOR
ADJUSTMENT LATER ON THE NUMBER
CAN.
GO HIGHER LOWER.
BUT WE'RE JUST STARTING THERE AS
A STARTING PLACE -- I NOW WANT
LIKE TO HEAR FROM OTHERS IN
SUPPORT NAME ORGANIZATION
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME WITH THIS
INTERNET [inaudible]
MR.
GOOD AFTERNOON ARE GOOD GOOD
AFTERNOON MY NAME IS LESLIE
HERNANDEZ AND I COME FROM WEST
GOSHEN THAT'S AND TULARE COUNTY.
I'M ALSO A MEMBER OF THE I WHAT
POLLUTION I'M A MOTHER I'M A
GRANDMOTHER IN I'M IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL BECAUSE WE ALL HAVE
THE RIGHT TO SAFE DRINKING WATER.
IN AND OUT.
AND IS THE RIGHT THING TO DO
THANK ALL RIGHT.
PLEASE JUST NAME ORGANIZATION
YOU CAN MENTION YOUR GRANDMOTHER
TAYLOR MOTHER THAT'S FINE.
PLEASE TRY AND BE BRIEF WE'RE
GONNA HAVE A LONG DAY.
MY NAME IS ERICA HILL LARA
MENDOZA AND COMING FROM OUT OF
STATE CALIFORNIA.
AND THE REASON I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON AND THANK YOU MY
NAME IS JOSEPHINE YET THOUGH I
COME FROM A SMALL TOWN OF
CHILLER COUNTY I'M A MOTHER A
GRANDMOTHER AND I'M HERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL THANK YOU.
WHEN INSTEAD OF THESE MEN NUMBER
OF PARTICLES THAT IS BRING WITH
THEM IS TOTAL SAY?
THE BLOODY IF PLUCKY BUT AVOIDED
READING BUT AT THAT ARE WILLING
PAY SOME OF THE CRISIS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
ANY TRANSLATION.
NO WE WE UNDERSTAND THIS
POSITION. ONE OF THE WE NOTICE
AMONG THEM OF ANYA MINGLE THEY
LOOK ON THAT SYLVIA.
HE THE CONDUCTOR LADDIE.
HE SAW IN MOTHER.
EARTH DAY EVEN THE PLAN MEDIA E.
KETTLE OLYMPIA BUT A WITH A
MEDIA IT'LL OF CALIFORNIA.
BUT I'M LOOKING AT A PHILOSOPHY
UP WITH THE V. MUCH OF THAT
OFFICE.
THANK YOU.
WHEN I STARTED THIS?
NUMBER PHILIP BACK ON SALAS THE
WRANGLE THE START ALL CITY.
THEN ANOTHER THING THAT YOU
REVIEWED IT.
A A VAN GOGH PADA BUT I I POINT
OUT AND READ.
A PART OF THE NET OLYMPIA.
WHICH ADDRESSES THANK YOU.
WHEN I THOUGHT LET ME MY NUMBER
IS NOT REALLY BEEN WHAT FOR
THAT'D BE FORGETTING ONE YET
THOUGH GET ALL ONE YEAH BUT I?
GOT ACTIVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON.
MY NAME IS.
HI MY NAME IS MONTEREY ISLAND
CLEAN WATER.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS RAMPS IN THE LONG
CLEAN AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME MORE AND AND I WANT
TO CREATE A JINGLE ARE.
HELLO WHEN A CERTAIN NUMBER OF A
CONTENTIOUS IS A MOTIVE FROM
MEDIA EVEN UP WE HAD INTERVIEWED
BUT I WHEN WANT LIMPIA SO LOVELY
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS IS
ABOUT VALDEZ I'M A MOMMY MOMMY
TO BE AN AN ADVOCATES AND I PRAY
WE CAN ALL AND PASSES AND
SUPPORT THIS SPELL.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME'S MIGHT AT NINE
THIS AND I'M RELIGION ORIGINALLY
FARMER SAID BORN AND RAISED --
MY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
ALUMINUM RIDGES IN AT THE REST
YEP FOR YOU TO READ.
HELLO MY NAME IS DEBBIE YOURS
I'M FROM SACRAMENTO AND I'M IN
CHUNKS FOR THE SPELL.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS HEATHER THE GUESTS
THAT COME FROM THE COUNTY OF
SANTA CRUZ AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
SO THAT -- MY MY COLLEAGUES AND
COMPANY ERRORS CAN HAVE SAFE
WATER THANK YOU THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS RYAN JENSEN FROM
THE COMMUTE THE CITY OF AYE
SALIA CALIFORNIA AND I'M HERE TO
SUPPORT THIS BILL SO THAT THEY
ARE GENERATION AND FUTURE
GENERATIONS CAN HAVE ACCESS TO
SAFE DRINKING WATER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU HI GETTING A GUY YEAH
BOTH FROM BY SALLY CALIFORNIA
AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL AND I
WANT CLEAN WATER FOR A
COMMUNITIES.
THANKS.
WHEN TONY ME NUMBER IS MEDIUM
MEDINA BINGO THEY ARE ALL SEE
YES THREE YANKEE ECONOMY HOTEL
BASKING BUT APPLE YEAH THEY'LL
BE?
GETTING MOST I WANT TO BE A FOR
ME FOR MANY UP FOR MICHAEL MONEY
THAT IS THE REAL THING WE JUST
GOT US YES.
I'M TO THREE AND I STAND HERE.
FOR THIS BILL FOR MY
GRANDCHILDREN GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN MY CHILDREN.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU.
EIGHTY GOT FED MELENDEZ DOMESTIC
A PRIVATE WELL OWNER -- WITHIN
SAFE WATER AND I'M FROM TULARE
COUNTY AND I SUPPORT THIS BILL
FOR ALL COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T
HAVE ONE AND STATE WATER.
THANKS THANK YOU.
A MISTER MEMBERS PAT RAN WITH
THEIR AND READING ASSOCIATES
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
ASSOCIATION OF PROFESSIONAL
SCIENTISTS IN THE PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS IN CALIFORNIA
GOVERNMENT STRONG SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE JUST AN OLD FILLED
WITH THE CALIFORNIA CATTLEMEN'S
ASSOCIATION WE'RE SUPPORT
CONCEPT THANK YOU.
AFTERNOON JASON BRYANT WESTERN
UNITED DURING MEN WE ARE SUPPORT
CONCEPT THANK YOU.
KILL DEL HAND WESTERN GROWERS
ASSOCIATION AND WE ARE ALSO IN
SUPPORT IS CONCEPT.
HELLO KILLER ROBINSON HERE HERE
ON BEHALF OF BREAST CANCER
PREVENTION PARTNERS IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
IS SILENCE ALICE WITH THE NATURE
CONSERVANCY INSTRUCTS SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS IN SUPPORT.
JENNIFER CLARY CLEAN WATER
ACTION IN SUPPORT.
JUST ONE FOR CERES HANDLES THE
LOCAL ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH
DEPARTMENTS IN STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
STEPHANIE MOORE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF MUTUAL
WATER COMPANIES AND SUPPORT WE
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TRYST A GUARANTOR
WITH AGRICULTURAL COUNCIL
CALIFORNIA SUPPORTING CONCEPTS
AND LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
ASSEMBLYMAN GARCIA AS WE GO
FORWARD.
THANK YOU.
JIM LIMBURG ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
TO CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
YOU LITTLE ALONSO GARCIA MOTHER
AND CONSTITUENT OF THE FIFTY SIX
DISTRICT WITH MAC COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF OUR ASSEMBLY
MEN EDUARDO GARCIA AND ALL OF
YOU WHO WILL BE VOTING YES ON
THIS.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO EVENING WITH
THE CALIFORNIA VINYL JUST
ALLIANCE IN STRONG SUPPORT.
CHAIR MEMBER SALLY HANDED OUT
WITH THE WHITE MAN GROUP HERE
REPRESENTING NEXT IN CALIFORNIA
AND SCA CALIFORNIA BOTH IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON REBEKAH SENEGAL
SO WITH YOUR CHIP COUNCIL FOR
JUSTICE AND ACCOUNTABILITY AND
SUPPORT AND I'D ALSO LIKE TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA FOR
HIS.
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE THANK
YOU.
AFTERNOON JAMIE MARK AND WITH
THE AMERICAN HEART ASSOCIATION
AND WANTED TO ADJUST THE
MICROPHONE SO WE CAN HEAR YOU.
THANKS I HAVE TO BRING IT DOWN
REALLY LOW -- THANK YOU IN THE
NEXT GO BRING IT UP HIGHER OKAY.
JAMIE MORGAN WITH THE AMERICAN
HEART ASSOCIATION AND SUPPORT
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ALEXANDER HER
NAME WITH THE WESTERN CENTER ON
LAW AND POVERTY AND STRONG
SUPPORT [inaudible]
WE GET.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS THE
COMMITTEE LOUIS BROWN ON BEHALF
THE CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION WE ARE SUPPORTIVE
AMENDED IN CONVERSATIONS WITH --
THE AUTHOR ON THOSE AMENDMENTS
THANK YOU.
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS MY NAME IS
MERION WARMER I'M A THROW COUNTY
REPRESENTATIVES A CALIFORNIA WE
IN SUPPORT AND CONCEPT LOOK
FORWARD TO WORKING WITH THE
CHAIR AND THE COMMITTEE TO
RESOLVE A COUPLE OUTSTANDING
CONCERNS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON TO MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ALSO UNDER
NOT I AM PROGRAM OFFICER WITH
THE WATER FOUNDATION IN STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ALEX LEASE COMEY THIS VEHICLE I
WILL SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE WHO
CAME.
ARE FROM ACROSS THE STATE THAT
ORDINARY CITIZENS WE DON'T
USUALLY GET THAT HERE.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK OUR REGULAR --
LOBBYIST FOR ALLOWING THEM TO
SPEAK FIRST I THINK IT WAS VERY
ELEGANT.
AND I KNOW THEY'RE STILL
CONCERNED ABOUT THE BILL SO IT'S
TIME TO HEAR FROM THE OPPOSITION
.
THANK YOU CHAIR QUIRK IN MEMBERS
CINDY TECH WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES WE
HAVE AN OPPOSE UNLESS AMENDED
POSITION ON AB.
TWO SEVENTEEN AND WE SUBMITTED A
LETTER YESTERDAY SO I KNOW SOME
OF OUR CONCERNS ARE NEW.
WE AGREE WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA OF THAT THERE IS A
PROBLEM WE WANT THIS PROBLEM
SOLVE THIS YEAR -- THERE IS A
LOT OF AGREEMENT THIS YEAR ON ON
THE ISSUE THE SUBJECT MATTER.
PARDON ME MISTER CHAIRMAN -- CAN
YOU ASK THE WITNESS TO JUST MOVE
THE MICROPHONE CLOSER. TO THAT
YEAH THANK YOU YOU KNOW WE CAN
HEAR YOU BUT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
VIEWING THIS CANNOT SO THANK YOU
VERY MUCH ORIGIN THANK YOU MADAM
VICE CHAIR MISTER CHAIR ALONG
THOSE LINES COULD.
COULD YOU TODAY WITNESS RE --
IDENTIFY HERSELF SURE -- GOOD
CINDY TOOK WITH THE ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA WATER AGENCIES.
AND WHAT YOU CAN START FROM THE
BEGINNING IF YOU WANT THEN
YOU'LL GET THE WHOLE THING ON
THE RECORD.
I ONCE I'LL START TIME ME NOW
OKAY.
SO CINDY TOOK WITH THE
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA WATER
AGENCIES WE HAVE AN OPPOSED TO
LESS TO SIT ON OPPOSE A LIST
AMENDED POSITION ON THE BILL.
AND WE AGREE YOU WITH THE AUTHOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA THAT
THERE IS A REAL PROBLEM AND THAT
IT SHOULD BE SOLVE THIS YEAR AND
I KNOW A LOT IF YOU WANT TO DO
THAT AS WELL.
OUR POSITION IS REALLY FOCUSED
ON THE PART OF THE BILL THAT IS
A NEW PROPOSAL IT'S A DIFFERENT
VERSION OF A WATER TAX.
THAT'S OUR MAJOR CONCERN ALL
ELABORATE ON THAT IN A SECOND.
BUT I I FIRST WANTED TO THINK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA FOR
REALLY LISTENING TO STAKEHOLDERS
THE MEETINGS THAT YOU REFERENCED
EARLIER.
ON BECAUSE HE HAS BEEN WILLING
TO CONSIDER DIFFERENT IDEAS AND
WE GREATLY APPRECIATE THAT.
AND FOR EXAMPLE AWKWARD IN THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATION ARE SPONSORING A
BILL THIS YEAR SB SIX SIX NINE
BY SENATOR CAFIERO WHICH WOULD
CREATE THE SAFE DRINKING WATER
TRUST.
AND WIN THE AUTHOR LEARNED ABOUT
THIS PROPOSAL HE WAS INTERESTED
IN IT AND INCLUDED THE OF AN
IDEA FOR THE TRUST IN THIS BILL
SO WE GREATLY APPRECIATE THAT.
THE WE THINK THE TRUST PROPOSAL
COMPLIMENTS EXISTING FUNDS
FEDERAL FUNDING AND BOND FUNDING
IN CALIFORNIA THAT ARE AVAILABLE
FOR CAPITAL COSTS.
AND I THINK WITH THIS BILL IN IN
LARGE PART IS AIMING TO DO IS
FILL WHERE THERE'S REALLY A GAP
IN THE ABILITY TO FUND THINGS
AND THAT'S WE CALL IT THE TOUGH
NUT TO CRACK IT'S THE OPERATION
AND MAINTENANCE COSTS YOU CAN'T
USE THE FEDERAL MONEY FOR THAT.
YOU GENERALLY CAN'T USE BOND
MONEY FOR THAT SO WORLD YOU KNOW
TRYING TO SOLVE THAT PROBLEM.
IN OUR VIEW THE TRUST IS
INTENDED AS OF A MECHANISM TO
REPLACE THE WATER TAX IT'S AN
ALTERNATIVE TO THE WATER TAX WE
WERE INTENDING TO ADD THAT TO
THE WATER TAX.
SO I I JUST WANTED.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THAT WAS CLEAR
FROM OUR PERSPECTIVE.
CIVIC COREY OF OUR OPPOSITION
AGAIN GOES TO THE WATER TAX PART
OF THE BILL WE THINK IT'S NOT.
GOOD POLICY FOR THE STATE TO TAX
SOMETHING LIKE PEOPLE'S TAP
WATER THAT IS ESSENTIAL TO LIFE.
WE HAVE A HUMAN RIGHT TO WATER
POLICY IN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS
FOR SAFE WATER BUT IT'S ALSO FOR
AFFORDABLE WATER.
IN USING A TAX TO FUND A SAFE
DRINKING WATER PROGRAM WILL ADD
TO THE COST WATER ACROSS THE
STATE IT WILL WORK AGAINST WATER
AFFORDABILITY.
THIS WOULD ALSO BE THE PRESIDENT
FOR A STATE TAX ON WATER AND
THERE'S A LOT OF OTHER -- INTO
TEASE STATE AGENCIES THAT ARE
ALREADY TALKING ABOUT IDEAS THAT
THEY WOULD LIKE TO FIND WITH
ATTACKS ON WATER AND THIS WOULD
BE THE PRESIDENT FOR THAT.
NO THERE ARE SOME PROBLEMS WITH
THE LANGUAGE WE OUTLINED SOME OF
THOSE IN THE LETTER I'M NOT
GONNA CUT TO EVERYONE THAT WE
EXPLAINED IN THE LETTER BUT I'LL
MENTION ONE OF THEM FOR EXAMPLE.
THE BILL AS CURRENTLY AMENDED
WOULD ALLOW THE USE OF FUNDING
FOR SYSTEMS THAT HAVE SAFE
DRINKING WATER.
BUT THEIR RATES EXCEED A
THRESHOLD IN A YOU WATER BOARD
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE DOCUMENT
THAT THRESHOLD IS ONE POINT 5%.
OF THE MEDIAN HOUSEHOLD INCOME.
AND YOU HAVE THAT PROVISION IS
WELL INTENDED.
BUT AS WE SPEAK THE STATE WATER
BOARD IS WORKING ON A A PROGRAM
IT'S THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AB
FOUR ONE BY A VENN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DIED NOW SENATOR DODD.
WE HAD A MEETING AT THE WATER
BOARD THAT WENT FROM NINE TO
THREE ON FRIDAY ABOUT THIS.
THE PROGRAM AT THE WATER BOARD.
WOOD THE INTENT OF THAT IS TO
END UP WITH A SUBSIDY FOR WATER
CUSTOMERS AND IT WOULD SUBSIDIZE
ABOUT A THIRD OF THE HOUSEHOLDS
IN CALIFORNIA.
SO THAT'S A PROGRAM THAT'S UNDER
DEVELOPMENT RIGHT NOW WE SUGGEST
THAT THIS PROGRAM THIS BILL
FOCUS ON WHERE THERE ISN'T SAFE
DRINKING WATER.
SO THAT'S ONE SPECIFIC ISSUE --
JUST CUTTING TO THE CHASE AGAIN
WE HAVE AN OPPOSED TO LESS
AMENDED POSITION WE URGE A NO
VOTE ON THE CURRENT VERSION OF
THE BILL.
BUT WE COULD SEE YOU TO WITH
PARTS OF THIS IN THE TRUST AND
OTHER THINGS A SOLUTION COMING
TOGETHER.
SO WE APPRECIATE THE COMMITTEE'S
WORK ON THIS STORY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MISS TALK FOR YOUR ELOQUENT
STATEMENT THANK YOU.
AND AND THANK YOU FOR WORKING
WITH THE AUTHOR.
ALL RIGHT -- OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
MEMBERS CHASE AND I COULD WITH
ADULTS TING GILBERT ROPES AND
SPENT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MUNICIPAL UTILITIES
ASSOCIATIONS IN YOUR WAY -- I
WANNA BE CLEAR SEE MAYES
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE HAS YET TO
CONSIDER THIS BUT WE DO NOT
TECHNICALLY HAVE AND OPPOSE
POSITION ON THE BILL THAT
RESPECT FOR THIS COMMITTEE AND
THE AUTHOR WE WANTED.
TO EXPRESS OUR CONCERNS WITH
CERTAIN PROVISIONS IN THE BILL
IN PARTICULAR.
MISS TUCKER ALREADY TOUCHED ON
ON ON MANY OF THE ISSUES RELATED
TO THE THE NEW FEE AUTHORITY FOR
THE WATER BOARD IN THIS BILL. TO
ALL OF SENIOR WAYS MEMBERS ARE
PUBLICLY OWNED UTILITIES THEY'RE
ALL SUBJECT TO PROPOSITION TWO
EIGHTEEN WHICH MEANS THAT ANY
FEES THAT IS ASSOCIATED.
ON THE WATER AGENCIES THAT ARE
MEMBERS OF SENIOR WAY WILL
ULTIMATELY BE APPLIED TO ALL
RATEPAYERS OF THOSE AGENCIES SO
IT THIS ULTIMATELY IS A
REGRESSIVE COSTS TO THOSE
REPAIRS ARE MOST VULNERABLE THAT
WE START.
AND SO WE WE WE LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING A FOR FORMAL POSITION IN
MORE DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHOR
WANTED TO NOTE THIS OKAY AND I
PRETENDED YOU WERE SITTING UP
HERE BECAUSE IT WAS STILL TIME
FOR THE OPPOSITION TO SPEAK SO --
IT'S WELL UNDERSTOOD BUT NO ONE
ELSE PLEASE REPEAT THE SAME
POINTS BUT YEAH IF YOU WANT TO
ADD.
A POINT OR TWO WE HAVE ABOUT
FORTY SECONDS LEFT THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN.
AND JACK WALK ON BEHALF OF THE
CITY OF FRESNO -- CITY OF LONG
BEACH -- KERN COUNTY WATER
AGENCY SAN BERNADINO OF IT
VALLEY MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT --
DOES ONE POINT I DID WANNA MAKE
RELATIVE TO HOW MUCH MONEY'S ALL
TO MCKINNEY NEED IT IS I THINK
WE'VE GOT.
TO HAVE A CLEAR UNDERSTANDING OF
THE ESTIMATES VARY WIDELY
BETWEEN WHAT WE BELIEVE TO BE
THE CASE WHICH IS IN THE THIRTY
TO FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR RANGE
AND THEN OF COURSE WE'VE HEARD.
A HUNDRED FORTY MILLION DOLLARS
WHICH DOES INCLUDE CAPITAL COST
AND I THINK MISS TALK ELOQUENTLY
AS YOU.
POINTED OUT INDICATED THAT CAN
BE FINANCED WITH BOND MONEY SO
WE THINK THEIR ALTERNATIVES
THERE AND I THINK WE BEFORE WITH
THE LEGISLATURE LEAPS LET'S BE
SURE WHAT THE WHAT THE SET OF
NUMBERS REALLY -- SO YEAH AND
THAT'LL WERE IN AND OUT IN GREAT
DETAIL AND APPROPRIATIONS I
ASSURE YOU WITH THE GUIDANCE
FROM THIS COMMITTEE I TRUST --
TO THE EXTENT THAT WE HAVE
EXPERTISE YES BUT IT'S SAD THIS
IS DEFINITELY SOMETHING THAT
APPROPRIATIONS IS CASUALLY GOOD --
TO WAY WOULD BLOCK OUR STAFF IS
ALWAYS AVAILABLE TO THEM.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT FROM NOW ON JUST NAME
AND PUT OUR ORGANIZATION.
NICKEL CAN UNITS ON BEHALF OF
THE HOUSEHOLD AND COMMERCIAL
PRODUCTS ASSOCIATION WE
REPRESENT THE NON AGRICULTURAL
FERTILIZER INDUSTRY AND WE'RE
OPPOSE LAST AMENDED OCCUR DUE TO
ADOPT THE LANGUAGE AND SB EIGHT
FOUR FOUR LAST YEAR WHICH
ASSESSES A LOWER MELISSA SMITH
FOR THE NON COMMERCIAL
FERTILIZER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
SARS DIVERSE WITH A MISSILE
WATER DISTRICT OF ORANGE COUNTY
HAS NOT HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
AGENDA IS THE BILL BUT DID TAKE
A FORMAL POSITION OPPOSING THE
TAX AS A MECHANISM A FUNDING THE
SAFE AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER CUSTOMER.
LOOKING FOR TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR ON THE DETAILS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR IN THIRTY MILLION
ON BEHALF OF MESA WATER DISTRICT
WHICH YOU DO NOT HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION YET BUT AFTER
THE SAME COMMENTS AS AQUA IN
SENIOR THANK YOU THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE
MUNNINGS GREG MORRISON I'M HERE
ON BEHALF OF ELSEWHERE VALLEY
MUNICIPAL WATER DISTRICT IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
WERE PRACTICALLY 20% OF OUR
MEMBERSHIP OUR OUR OUR CUSTOMERS
ARE IN DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
AND SEVERELY DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND I WOULD SUBMIT
TO YOU THAT EVEN A SMALL AMOUNT
OF FIFTY CENTS IS A WATER TAX ON
THEIR BILLS.
WOULD SEVERELY IMPACT THEM AND
WE'RE ALREADY TO A CERTAIN
DEGREE SUBSIDIZING THOSE
PARTICULAR RATE PAYERS WITH NON
REPAIR MONEY THAT WE RECEIVE
FROM PASSIVE INCOME IN THE AREA
SO WE SUPPORT OCT WAS POSITION
ON THIS BILL.
AND LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK
YOU.
HOW ARE NOT TAKING TIME HERE FOR
EAST VALLEY WATER DISTRICT -- WE
ARE VIEWS ARE IN ALIGNMENT WITH --
THOSE EXPRESSED BY AQUA AND
UNFORTUNATELY FIFTY CENTS MAY
SEEM LIKE A SMALL AMOUNT BUT
IT'S STILL A STARTER TAX ON
WATER.
THANK YOU.
HI I'M A TWEENER BRIAN AND JACK
IN BRIDGEWATER THIRTY NINE
POSITION ON THE BILL LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE AUTHOR.
WE HAVE A CONCERN WITH THE FEES
ONE POINT THAT HASN'T BEEN
RAISED IS.
AMONG OUR LOW INCOME --
CUSTOMERS.
WE'RE ABOUT 30% IN SACRAMENTO
AREA. TWO MILLION PEOPLE THAT
SIX HUNDRED THOUSAND PEOPLE.
ABOUT FOUR HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND OF THOSE DOT ACTUALLY
DIRECTLY GET A BILL SO THERE'S
AND CHALLENGE WITH US HELPING
THEM OUT WITH THE OUTLOOK THE
POINT OF THIS WAS THAT THEY
WON'T HAVE TO BE.
GETTING A BAIL.
HE LOOKED IT'S DOUBLE THAT WE'VE
HAD AND NOT TAKE UP ANYMORE THE
TIMES OKAY TO GET IT RECOGNIZED
THAT THERE'S GONNA BE A
CHALLENGE REACHING THOSE
CUSTOMERS AND HELPING THEM OUT
WITHOUT WITH A P. A PROPOSED AT
SUCH.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS ADAM ROBIN
WITH THE NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
WATER ASSOCIATION PROJECT
CONVERSATION TODAY WE HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE FEW LANGUAGE
BUT WE VERY MUCH APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S WILLINGNESS TO ENGAGE
STAKEHOLDERS THROUGH INTER ON
INTO THIS YEAR LOOK FOR TO
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON NO AUTOMATIC WITH
THE CITY OF ROSE FILE.
ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH THOSE
OF CMU AND ARE A. AND JUST ADD
THAT WHATEVER FEE THAT WE DO
HAVE TO PAY AS A PUBLIC WATER
SYSTEM WILL UNFORTUNATELY HAVE
TO BE PASSED ON TO OUR CUSTOMERS.
AND DISPROPORTIONATELY A FAX
THOSE WHO CAN LEAST AFFORD IT.
THANK YOU.
THAT AFTERNOON CAROLYN JENSEN
WITH KP PUBLIC AFFAIRS ON BEHALF
OF WESTERN MUNICIPAL WATER
DISTRICT WESTLANDS WATER
DISTRICT IN THE MOJAVE WATER
AGENCY -- WE ALIGN OURSELVES
WITH THE COMMENTS OF AQUA AND OF
REMAIN OPPOSED TO LET THE TAX ON
WATER THANK YOU THANK YOU I
THINK WE HAVE ALL THE WITNESSES
YOU CAN STAY UP HERE MISS TALK
AND I SHOULD ALSO GET AN EXPERT
FROM THE PRO SIDE.
UP HERE IN CASE THERE ARE
TECHNICAL QUESTIONS TO BE
ANSWERED I WONDER TWO OF YOU CAN
COME UP THERE'S PLENTY OF SPACE.
ALL RIGHT MISS BARRET ON HAS
ASKED TO SPEAK FIRST -- BECAUSE
SHE IS LEAVING SHORTLY TO
PRESENT A BELL THANK YOU MISTER.
CHAIR -- THANK YOU MR GARCIA FOR
BRINGING.
THE START TENSION I MEAN I THINK
WE ALL WANT CALIFORNIANS TO HAVE
SAFE AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
WITH A SHARED GOAL -- ONE QUICK
ONE TECHNICAL QUESTION ON THE
TRUST IS MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE LA -- PUT OUT A REPORT
SAYING THAT THAT WOULD REQUIRE
US TO PUT THREE TO FOUR BILLION
DOLLARS OF GENERAL FUND MONEY
AWAY FOR THE TRUST TO WORK IS
THAT RIGHT.
THAT IS CORRECT OKAY -- SO.
I HAVE CONCERNS FIRST OF ALL THE
YOUR BILL AND MISTER BLOOM
SPELLER SEPARATE BECAUSE I THINK
THAT.
THE IDEA THAT THEY WOULD NOT
BOTH COME TO BE LAW WOULD BE.
SEVERELY PROBLEMATIC THE
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY IN
MISTER BLOOM SPELL IS.
I THINK NECESSARY TO THIS BILL
AND SO I'D LIKE TO SEE THEM
BECOME ONE BILL AND SO WE KNOW
THAT THAT OVERSIGHT
ACCOUNTABILITY WILL GO HAND IN
HAND WITH THIS BILL BECAUSE I
THINK IT'S IMPORTANT -- THIS
DIMENSION WEEK.
HE CAN CONSIDERED JOINING THE
BELLS IRAQ IT'S GOOD FOR THEM TO
BE SEPARATE BUT WE COULD JOIN
THEM WE'LL SEE IF THAT HAPPENED
OKAY [inaudible]
AND I'M.
SO ONE OF MY MAJOR CONCERNS WITH
THIS IS THAT.
THE UNCLEAN WATER IN MAJORITY OF
THE COMMUNITIES THAT WE'RE
FOCUSED ON IS THE RESULT OF
POLLUTION.
IS THE RESULT OF POLLUTION.
DIRECT POLLUTION INTO OUR WATER
SOURCES AND SECONDARILY
RESULTING FROM DRAWING DOWN OUR
GROUNDWATER TO SEVERELY.
AND THE EVIDENCE SHOWS THAT WE
DRAW DOWN THAT GROUND WATER THAN
I TRADE BALANCE GETS OFF AND
THAT'S PART OF THE PROBLEM IS
HAPPENING HERE.
SO IT IS ACTORS CAUSING THIS
PROBLEM.
AND SO ALTHOUGH.
I WOULD YOU KNOW I WANT TO SEE
CLEAN DRINKING WATER THROUGHOUT
CALIFORNIA I ALSO QUERY IS IT
RIGHT TO HAVE THE RATE PAYERS A
CALIFORNIA PAYING FOR THE
ACTIONS.
OF THE POLLUTERS AND SO I ALSO
WONDER IF 30% IS THE RIGHT
NUMBER -- IF WE REALLY LOOK AT
WHAT ACTIONS ARE CAUSING THIS IS
IT MORE THAN THAT AND I THINK WE
NEED TO MAKE SURE THE
RESPONSIBLE PARTIES ARE.
BEING HELD ACCOUNTABLE FOR THEIR
ACTIONS IN THAT THEY ARE -- THE
ONES RESPONSIBLE TO CLEAN IT UP
AND SECONDARILY I THINK WE NEED.
TO I DON'T WANT US TO JUST BE
CLEANING DRINKING WATER.
LETTING PEOPLE POLLUTE AND
CLEANING DRINKING WATER WE NEED
TO ALSO BE WORKING TO STOP THE
POLLUTION.
SO THAT MOVING FORWARD WE HAVE
LAST PROBLEMS WITH CLEAN
DRINKING WATER.
AND SO ALTHOUGH I UNDERSTAND
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE TO CLEAN OUR
WATER I ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT WE AS A COMMITTEE AND AS A
BODY ARE LOOKING VERY HARD AT
WHAT WE ARE DOING THAT IS
CAUSING THIS PROBLEM IN THE
FIRST PLACE AND GET TO THE ROOT.
CAUSES AND WE'RE PASSING BILLS
TO FIX THOSE PROBLEMS AS WELL.
I'M.
YOU KNOW I I HAVE TO COMMEND YOU
AND TO SEE THE ENVIRONMENTALISTS
AND THE GROWERS ON THE SAME SIDE
IS PRETTY AWESOME SO -- YOU KNOW
THAT'S GOOD TO SEE AND IT'S PART
OF WITH MAKING ME.
I'M MORE COMFORTABLE WITH US
MOVING FORWARD IN THIS
CONVERSATION BECAUSE I KNOW
YOU'RE WORKING WITH ALL
INTERESTED PARTIES TO MAKE SURE
WE GET TO A PLACE.
WHERE THIS BILL IS GOOD -- BUT I
ALSO WANT TO ECHO MAKING SURE
THAT AS WE HAD IF WE HAD TOWARDS
APPROPRIATIONS THAT WE GET THE
NUMBER RIGHT I MEAN WHEN I HEARD
FROM THE CITY'S A MAYBE A THIRTY
TO FIFTY MILLION BUT WE HAVE A
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION.
AGAIN BACK TO THE ACCOUNTABILITY
THAT WE ARE NOT OVER SUBSCRIBING
HERE WE'RE REALLY USING THE BOND
MONEY WHERE WE CAN.
AND ONLY AND USING THESE FUNDS
WHERE WE ACTUALLY NEED THEM FOR
ON GOING.
CLEANING -- SO THERE'S A LOT
LEFT TO BE WORKED OUT.
WHICH IS VERY CLEAR AND SO I
THINK THAT YOU KNOW.
I'M.
I WANT IT TO BE CLEAR THAT ANY
SUPPORT TODAY IS CONTINGENT ON
THIS STUFF BEING WORKED OUT AND
THEN WE GET TO A SOLUTION THAT
LOOKS TO THE FUTURE OF CLEAN
WATER IN A MUCH BROADER SENSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
STATEMENT AND BRINGING UP SOME
VERY IMPORTANT ISSUES -- WOULD
BE ALRIGHT IF THEY ANSWER THOSE
IN THE CLOTHES.
OKAY SO WILL TRY AND TO THE
EXTENT THAT WE CAN -- ANSWER OUR
QUESTIONS IN THE CLOTHES UNLESS
IT'S A VERY BRIEF YES SIR NOW --
MISTER PETER DAHLE YACHT MR
DARLING I THINK IS NEXT IN THE
NOW I I JUST HAD A SUGAR IN A
CLARIFICATION WHICH I HAD.
I MEAN.
I HAVE.
MANY OF THE SAME QUESTIONS THAT.
TO MS BAUER CAN HAS AND I WOULD
LIKE TO HEAR THEM ADDRESSED AS
PART THE CONVERSATION NOT JUST
IN A CLOSE.
ALL RIGHT THEN -- I'LL LOVE.
I'LL I'LL YIELD TO THEN THE
QUESTIONS BEING ANSWERED NOW.
AND MISS POWER BEHIND WILL HAVE
TO CATCH UP LATER -- CAN I ASK
MY OKAY GO AHEAD.
THEN.
ASK YOUR QUESTION AND THEN WE'LL
WE'LL LOT WILL GO ON TO ANSWER
QUESTIONS ALL RIGHT.
I HAVE GREAT RESPECT FOR MISTER
DALI WELL FIRST OFF I WANT.
TO LET THE AUTHOR KNOW IN THE IN
THE PEOPLE THAT COME HERE TO
SUPPORT THIS LEGISLATION IT'S
BEEN ONGOING WE KNOW THAT THIS
HAS BEEN THE ISSUE BUT I WANT TO
POINT OUT SOME.
SOME CLEAR FAX.
SO I HEARD IN THE TESTIMONY
THERE ARE MILLION -- RESIDENTS
OF CALIFORNIA HAVE.
AND SPIT DRINKING WATER AND
THAT'S A FACT WE KNOW THAT
THERE'S IS NITRATES AND AND
THAT'S UNACCEPTABLE I AGREE WITH
YOU ON THAT BUT THERE THIRTEEN
EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE HAVE SAFE
AFFORDABLE.
SOMEWHAT AFFORDABLE DRINKING
WATER AND I WANT TO SHARE WITH
YOU ALSO THAT.
WE HAVE PASSED A LOT OF
LEGISLATION IN BONDS TO ADDRESS.
THESE ISSUES I MEAN I CAN'T I
SHOULD HAVE GOT A LIST OF SAFE
DRINKING WATER BOND THE EIGHT
PROPERTY FOR I CAN GO BACK
TWENTY YEARS AND THE PUBLIC HAS
BEEN PAYING.
MAYBE NOT ON AN A ON A TAX ON
WATER.
BUT THEY'VE BEEN PAYING THROUGH
BONDS WHICH IS THE COMES OUT THE
GENERAL FUND WHICH IS PAID BY
TAX DOLLARS.
AND SO I'M SOMEWHAT FRUSTRATED
WITH THE FACT THAT WE CONTINUE
TO COME BACK AND AND FOR MAYBE
IT'S JUST MAYBE FOLKS ON OUR
SIDE OF THE AISLE THAT
CONTINUALLY YOU ARE ASKED THE
QUESTION IS.
YES WE HAVE ISSUE BUT HOW DO WE
SOLVE THAT ISSUE AND HOW DO WE
ACTUALLY ADDRESS IT WITH.
THE BEST AVAILABLE TECHNOLOGY
AND DROPPING THE RATE THIS IS
THIS IS TALKING ABOUT TAXING
EVERY SINGLE. TO ME DRINKS AND
AND THE STATE THROUGH WATER
SYSTEM THAT IS AN ALSO PRODUCERS
LIKE MYSELF WHO USE FERTILIZERS
I'M GONNA BE IT'S ALREADY TAX
AND WE'RE GONNA ADD TO THAT TAX
IN THIS LEGISLATION SO.
IT'S GONNA BE VERY HARD FOR ME
TO SWALLOW THIS KNOWING ALL THE
WHILE THAT I'VE ACTUALLY RAN
PIECES OF LEGISLATION.
THE LOUD POINT OF USE.
FILTRATION OF WATER AND THE
BILLS GET KILLED.%
BUT SOME OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
GROUPS WHO ARE STANDING HERE
SUPPORTING THIS TAX.
WHEN I KNOW THAT THAT WOULD HELP
ALLEVIATE SOME OF THE PROBLEMS
AT THE SOURCE AT THEIR HOUSE TO
GIVE SAFE DRINKING WATER? TO
CONSTITUENTS IN CALIFORNIA THERE
ARE HUNDRED AND FORTY IMPAIRED
WATER SYSTEMS IN CALIFORNIA THAT
I'M AWARE OF THAT THERE MAY BE
MORE THAT ARE REALLY NEED.
SOME FOLKS ON THAT'S WHAT WE
SHOULD FOCUS.
AND SO.
AS SOMEBODY WHO HAS.
BEEN TAXED A LOT IN THE STATE
AND YOU CAN'T AFFORD TO LIVE IN
THE STATE.
QUITE FRANKLY WHEN EVERYTHING IS
THE COST OF LIVING IS GOING UP.
AND I JUST DON'T HAVE A A HIGH
LEVEL OF TRUST FOR THE WATER
BOARD.
NUMBER ONE IN IMPLEMENTING
WHATEVER PIECE OF LEGISLATION
GETS PUSHED OUT.
IN A FASHION THAT WILL ACTUALLY
AFFECT THE THOSE THOSE
CONSTITUENTS WHO NEED THEIR
WATER SUPPORTED AND WE'VE SEEN
THIS TIME AND TIME AGAIN WHERE
WE'VE HAD.
LEGISLATION THAT SUPPOSED TO FIX
SOMETHING AND THE MONIES GET
DIVERTED OFF INTO.
ALL KINDS OF OTHER THINGS THAT
NO FIX THE PROBLEM AND I'LL GIVE
YOU TWO EXAMPLES THAT ARE JUST
BLARING IN OUR FACE RIGHT NOW WE
DID A THERE WAS A TAX FROM
BATTERIES LAST YEAR FOR EXCITED
MY GOOD FRIEND.
CRISTINA GARCIA.
WHO WORKED ON THAT LEGISLATION
TO HELP OUR COMMUNITY WITH THE
WITH THE THE?
LEAD ISSUES LOOK AT WHAT
HAPPENED DTS TOOK THE MONEY AND
EXPANDED THEIR OFFICES AND IS
NOT GOING TO THE GROUND WHERE WE
NEED TO FIX THE PROBLEM.
SO I HAVE.
VERY JUST A LOT OF DISTRUST FOR
THE GOVERNMENT TO BE ABLE TO DO
WHAT WE ASK THEM TO DO NUMBER
TWO WE PASSED HEAVILY USED
TRACKS ON TRUCKS.
MANY MANY YEARS AGO TO FIX OUR
ROADS. TO THE TUNE OF A BILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR.
AND THAT MONEY GOT DIVERTED TO
THE GENERAL FUND AND TO THIS DAY
IS STILL CONCERT CONVERTED TO
THE GENERAL FUND.
IT IS NOT FIXING OUR ROADS AT
THE SAME TIME CAME BACK TO US
AND SAID WE NEED TO PASS A TAX
FOR FUEL WE CAN FIX THE ROADS.
SO I'M JUST I AND I KNOW THAT
YOU'RE TRYING TO FIX A PROBLEM
THAT IS IN YOUR DISTRICT BUT I
JUST WANT TO SHARE WITH THE
FRUSTRATION THAT.
MANY FOLKS HAVE IN THIS BUILDING
THAT JUST CAN'T JUST TRUST US
THIS TIME.
WELL I DON'T TRUST YOU THIS TIME
BECAUSE I I HAVE A LIST OF TIMES
THAT WE'VE BEEN TAX AND DRIVING
UP THE COST TO CALIFORNIANS AND
IT DOESN'T FIX THE PROBLEM.
SO I COMMEND YOU FOR BRINGING UP
FOR I KNOW IT'S A TOUGH ISSUE
AND THERE ARE LOTS OF SPECIAL
INTEREST EVERYWHERE OUT THERE
BUT AT THE END OF THE DAY.
WE WANT TO BUILD THE TRUST WITH
THE PUBLIC OF CALIFORNIA WHEN
WE'RE ASKING THEM TO PAY AGAIN.
AND AGAIN AND AGAIN THE MONEY
ACTUALLY FIXES THE PROBLEM AND
IT AND WE FIX IT.
SO THAT IT DOESN'T COST.
MORE THAN IT SHOULD AND IT
THERE'S BEEN SOME OBVIOUSLY
MISSED TALKING SOME OF THE OTHER
ONES HAD SUGGESTED THAT -- MAYBE
WERE WERE GET WE'RE TAXING TOO
MUCH FOR THE ACTUAL PROBLEM THAT
NEEDS TO BE FIXED SO I SHARE
THAT WITH YOU I'M GONNA HAVE A
DIFFICULT TIME SUPPORTING ANY
LEGISLATION UNLESS.
THERE'S SOME SAFEGUARDS IN IT
THAT SAYS.
THIS IS WHERE IT'S GOING TO GO
AND THIS IS HOW IT'S GONNA FACT
BECAUSE THE TRACK RECORD OF THIS.
LEGISLATURE AND THE PEOPLE WHO
IMPLEMENT THE LAWS WE PASS IS
HORRIBLE.
SO IT'S NOTHING PERSONAL I AGREE
WE NEED TO HAVE CLEAN SAFE
DRINKING WATER BUT THERE THIRTY
EIGHT MILLION PEOPLE OUT THERE
WHO HAVE GOOD SAFE DRINKING
WATER CALIFORNIA.
THERE'S A MILLION IT DON'T LET'S
FOCUS ON THOSE MILLION FIGURE
OUT HOW WE CAN GET THEM SAFE
DRINKING WATER FOR THEIR
FAMILIES THANK YOU THANK YOU
SENATOR ALLEN -- SO.
LOTS OF STATEMENTS.
WHAT I'D LIKE?
ARM.
AT YOUR REQUEST IS TO RATHER
THAN ADDRESSES IN THE CLOSE
ADDRESS IT NOW ALSO SINCE YOU
HAVE MANY OF THE SAME QUESTIONS.
ARE WE CAN MAKE SURE THERE'S A
ANSWERED -- AND WE CAN ALSO MAKE
SURE THAT MR DOLLIES OUR
QUESTIONS -- ARE ANSWERED SO.
WE'LL START WITH YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME TO CALL ON YOUR
EXPERTS AT THE END OF THAT I'M
GONNA CALL ON MISS TALK IN SEE
IF SHE HAS ANY QUESTIONS.
I THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT
THAT WE DISCUSS THIS FULLY NOW.
WE'RE GONNA END UP TAKING MORE
THAN AN HOUR ON THIS ITEM AND
EVERY MINUTE IS IMPORTANT AND
WORTH IT.
AND THEN WE'LL GET TO THE OTHER
QUESTIONS.
BUT THIS IS IT.
YOU KNOW IF WE STAY HERE LATE
TONIGHT IT'S FINE BECAUSE THIS
IS REALLY SO IMPORTANT TO US ALL.
THANK YOU AS CHAIR LET ME UP ALL
START WITH THE THE COMMENTS AND
STATEMENTS MADE BY MY COLLEAGUE.
A MISTER DALI IN I DON'T THE I
DON'T DISAGREE.
WITH THE THE COMMENTS THAT YOU
MADE AS IT RELATES TO THE
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
OF FUNDING STREAMS THAT ARE SAID
TO DO ONE THING IN ULTIMATELY
END UP.
SOMEWHERE ELSE.
I THINK THAT -- WITH THIS PIECE
OF LEGISLATION THERE HAS TO BE
SOME DIRECT THE OVERSIGHT OF
IDENTIFYING WHERE THESE
COMMUNITIES ARE -- THE TYPES OF
PROJECTS THAT ARE BEING PUT
FORWARD THE COST -- THE TIME
LINES AND OF COURSE THE
BUDGETARY -- ALLOCATION.
WITH THE FOLLOW UP AND FOLLOW
THROUGH A NIGHT I'M GOING TO BE
WORKING CLOSELY WITH MISTER
BOWMAN.
CAN WE PUT THESE BILLS TOGETHER
ABSOLUTELY WE THINK THOUGH -- IT
AT THE CURRENT TIME IT'S IT'S AN
EASIER.
TASK TO WORK ON THESE IN
PARALLEL -- SO THAT WE CAN DEAL
WITH THE RESPECT STAKEHOLDERS AS
IT RELATES TO THE MECHANISM AND
THEN OF COURSE THE ACTUAL
IMPLEMENTATION -- BUT I DON'T
DISAGREE -- YOU GIVE A PERFECT
EXAMPLE OF THE ISSUE RELATED TO
ROAD INFRASTRUCTURE -- MONEY
THAT WAS DEDICATED FOR ONE THING
AND EVENTUALLY ENDED UP IN THE
GENERAL FUND -- YOU OR I WERE
HERE.
MY AND SO WE CAN'T BE HELD
RESPONSIBLE BUT WE ARE
RESPONSIBLE FOR HOW.
THIS NEW FREE ON GAS.
IS UTILIZED FOR INFRASTRUCTURE
INVESTMENT AND THE VOTERS ALSO.
HAVE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO
WEIGH IN ON THAT.
AND THEY'RE SAYING WE TRUST YOU
FOR NOW.
AND STAY THE COURSE AS IT
RELATES TO IMPROVING OUR ROADS
AND INFRASTRUCTURE WITH THAT
FEAT.
THE VOTERS SPOKE -- AS IT
RELATES TO THE EXCITED I THINK.
THAT IS A GOOD EXTREMELY
CONCERNING.
AND I HAVE -- FULL CONFIDENCE IN --
MY COLLEAGUE -- CRISTINA GARCIA
AND I WILL SUPPORTER -- TO TAKE
THE OPIATE COURSE OF ACTION TO
ENSURE THAT THAT MONEY ENDS UP
WHERE IT NEEDS TO BE RIGHT.
LET'S GET BACK TO THE SUBJECT AT
HAND.
YOU MENTIONED BONDS.
WE KNOW THAT BONDS.
ARE NOT ALLOWABLE FOR THE
PURPOSE OF OPERATION AND
MAINTENANCE.
OF THIS PROBLEM.
WHICH IS WHY IN ALL THE WE
HAVEN'T TALKED A LOT ABOUT THIS
CONSOLIDATION CONTINUES TO BE.
A NUMBER ONE OPTION.
AS IT RELATES TO THE SMALLER
SYSTEMS THAT CAN NO LONGER BE
SUSTAINED ON THEIR OWN.
BUT THOSE LARGER SYSTEMS THAT
WILL BE RESPONSIBLE FOR TAKING
THE MON [inaudible]
WE'LL NEED. TO HAVE SOME
INCENTIVE.
RIGHT SOME RESOURCES TO BE ABLE
TO TAKE ON THAT OPERATION AND
MAINTENANCE COSTS.
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS FUND
FOCUSES ON SO I AM WITH YOU BY
WE WERE THE AUTHOR OF THE LAST
WATER PARK BOND.
THAT.
DIRECTED SOME MONEY FOR WATER
INFRASTRUCTURE CLEAN WATER BEING
ONE SECTION OF THE BILL BUT IT'S
NOT ENOUGH.
THE PRIOR WATER BOND WASN'T
EITHER.
IN TWO THOUSAND FOURTEEN THAT
WAS SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS.
THAT GOES TOWARDS INFRASTRUCTURE.
IMPROVEMENTS AND NOT SO MUCH THE
OPERATION AND MAINTENANCE THAT'S
WHY WE ARE PROPOSING THE TWO
QUARTER.
PUBLIC FUND BENEFIT.
FEE TO BE ABLE TO ADDRESS THE
ISSUE -- THAT'S BEFORE US ALL
TURNED TO TO OUR CALL THE GAL
WHO.
SAYS MANY OF HIS CONCERNS ARE
ARE.
DIRECTLY TIED TO HIS POWER CON
AND THE COMMENTS THAT WERE MADE
WERE THAT -- POLLUTERS SHOULD BE
HELD ACCOUNTABLE I THINK THE
WATER BOARD IS DOING THAT.
YOU CAN TELL ME IF I'M WRONG --
IT THE WATER BOARD IS ON TOP OF
THIS ISSUE COULD THEY DO MORE
MOST DEFINITELY.
AND THE REASON WHY I THINK.
THE AG COMMUNITY IS AT THE TABLE
WITH US IS BECAUSE THE WATER
BOARD IS THREATENING TO DO MORE.
AS IT RELATES TO HOLDING THEM
ACCOUNTABLE.
SO -- I'M APPRECIATIVE OF THE
FACT THAT WE ARE APPROACHING
THIS IN A COLLABORATIVE WAY.
AND WHETHER OR NOT.
YOU KNOW AG OR ANY OTHER
INDUSTRY IS RESPONSIBLE FOR A
PORTION -- THE NUMBER WAS 30% IF
IT'S MORE THAN IT SHOULD BE
REFLECTED IN THE AMOUNT THAT'S
BEING PUT ON THEM TO BE ABLE TO
CLEAN THIS UP BUT BUT ULTIMATELY.
YOU KNOW I WANT TO SAY THAT I
DON'T DISAGREE WITH THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE MADE.
AND THIS IS THE BEGINNING OF
THAT CONVERSATION TODAY WE HAVE
HANDFUL OF AMENDMENTS THAT WE
HAVE ACCEPTED -- TO THEN MOVE ON
TO IDENTIFYING THE ACTUAL.
AMOUNT.
OF THE PROBLEM AND ULTIMATELY
HAVE APPROPRIATIONS.
HELP US BEGIN NARROWING DOWN THE
SCULPTOR -- BUT THE COMMENTS ARE
WELL TAKEN WELL NOTED AND AS WAS
MENTIONED EARLIER.
ON WE ARE COMMITTED TO WORKING
WITH EVERYONE WHO HAS STOOD UP
IN OPPOSITION. TO THIS BILL AND
I KNOW THAT.
YOU KNOW WE'VE HAD SOME WATER
AGENCIES.
WHO WILL GO ON NAME WHO HAVE
COME TO MEET WITH US AND HAVE
PUT FORWARD SOME IDEAS SOME
SOLUTIONS AS IT RELATES TO
MECHANISMS ON HOW TO ADMINISTER?
COLLECTED AND SEND THE FEEDBACK.
TO THE STATE IN ORDER FOR IT TO
END UP IN THE FUN -- TO CLEAN UP
THESE WATER SYSTEMS IN SPECIFIC
PARTS OF THE STATE SO WE ARE.
HEARING YOU LOUD AND CLEAR.
AND YOU KNOW IT'S BEEN MENTIONED
THIS IS A CONTROVERSIAL OR OR A
TOUGH ISSUE.
IT SHOULDN'T BE.
THE IDEA THAT THERE ARE CHILDREN
IN SCHOOLS -- THAT DON'T HAVE
CLEAN DRINKING WATER THAT SHOULD
NOT BE CONTROVERSIAL OR A TOUGH
ISSUE.
WHEN WE USE THE WORD TAX OF
COURSE IT SCARES US IN?
FOLKS -- ON WHETHER OR NOT THE
WE CAN SUPPORT THIS OR NOT THIS
IS A OF FEET. TO BENEFIT THE
PUBLIC.
RIGHT AND THAT'S THE DIFFERENCE
BETWEEN THE TAX AND AND THE FEE
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT.
TAXES FOR GENERAL SERVICES A
FEES WERE SPECIFICALLY.
ADDRESSING A SPECIFIC NEED IN
AREAS WHERE PEOPLE ARE PAYING
THE FEE AND IT'S VERY DIFFICULT.
FOR SOMEONE TO SAY I DON'T HAVE
THIS PROBLEM IN MY DISTRICT I
KNOW -- THERE ARE.
STANDARDS.
THAT TO CONTINUE TO BE ELEVATED
AT THE WATER BOARD.
THAT ARE PUTTING SYSTEMS OUT OF
COMPLIANCE EVERY SINGLE DAY.
AND THAT REQUIRES.
RESOURCES TO BUILD THE ADEQUATE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND TECHNOLOGY.
AND MAYBE IT'S THE TEMPORARY
APPROACH OF USING POINT OF USE
FILTRATION SYSTEMS AS WE DO IN.
THE COACHELLA VALLEY TO ADDRESS
THE ISSUE OF ARSENIC.
BUT THE LONG TERM SOLUTION IS TO
CONNECT THEM TO CENTRALIZE
INFRASTRUCTURE.
SO THAT EVERYONE.
IS DRINKING THE SAME QUALITY OF
WATER THAT STUFF BEING
SUPERVISED AND MAINTAIN.
OUR BY THE PROFESSIONAL SO --
MANY STATEMENTS WERE MADE THEY
WERE IN A LOT OF QUESTIONS OR
STATEMENTS THAT WERE MADE IN I
WANTED TO ADDRESS THOSE
STATEMENTS.
IN SUCH WAY AND AGAIN INVITE.
YOU.
TO GET INVOLVED IN THIS
CONVERSATION -- BECAUSE I THINK
THIS IS A YEAR THAT WE MUST
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
OKAY -- MISSED MURATSUCHI THERE
IS THERE ANYTHING YOU WOULD
REQUIRE ADDITIONAL --
CLARIFICATION ON YES I HAVE A
SERIES OF QUESTIONS ALL RIGHT I
I FORGOT I WAS GONNA LET MISS
TALK.
A RESPONDED CASE YOU HAD -- UGH
JUST BRIEFLY -- IS THERE
ANYTHING YOU WOULD LIKE TO
RESPOND -- TO YES ON JUST A FEW
THINGS.
ON BONDS OF COURSE PROP ONE
TWENTY FOURTEEN HAD OVER HALF A
BILLION FOR SAFE AND CLEAN WATER.
THE MOST RECENT BOND -- TWENTY
FROM JUNE OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
WITH PROP SIXTY EIGHT THAT
INCLUDED AN ADDITIONAL TWO
HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION FOR
SAFE AND CLEAN WATER AGAIN
AVAILABLE FOR CAPITAL NOT -- FOR
IN THEM.
ON THE POLLUTION ISSUE THAT WAS
RAISED EARLIER WE A 100% AGREE
THAT RESPONSIBLE PARTY SHOULD BE
RESPONSIBLE YOU KNOW FOR
POLLUTION.
ON THE TRUST ISSUE OF THE NUMBER
OF A HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILLION
CAME UP EARLIER I AM THAT WAS A
NEW NUMBER TO ME.
LAST YEAR THE NUMBER WAS A
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION I
THINK THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
WAS TRYING TO RAISE BUT
REGARDLESS.
AS OUR MISTER KWOK WHO TESTIFIED
THERE'S A LOT OF DIFFERENCES ON
THE MONEY THAT WILL BE DISCUSSED
AT APPROPRIATIONS.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOKED AT THE MOST
RECENT NEEDS ASSESSMENT THAT THE
STATE WATER BOARD IS ISSUED --
FOR IN M. FOR NITRATE AND OTHER
CHEMICALS IT WAS FORTY THREE
POINT THREE MILLION DOLLARS YOU
ADD MONEY FOR CONSOLIDATION
MAYBE YOU GET TO FIFTY MILLION --
THAT TRANSLATES TO A TRUST OF
ABOUT ONE POINT THREE BILLION
THAT COULD BE FUNDED OVER ONE
TWO OR THREE YEARS FOR EXAMPLE
SUGGESTIVE GET THAT INFORMATION
OUT THERE.
AND FINALLY.
THE WAY THE NEW ON THE BE
MECHANISM THAT'S BEEN REFERRED
TO IS WRITTEN IT IS A TAX UNDER
PROP WENTY SIX YES -- VERY GOOD
AND THANK YOU FOR BRINGING UP
YOUR NUMBERS AGAIN -- THAT WILL
BE DETERMINED IN APPROPRIATIONS
ARE WE JUST LOOKING AT POLICY
HERE -- SO MISTER MURATSUCHI I
BELIEVE YOU HAVE SOME QUESTIONS
YES THANK YOU VERY MUCH IDEA.
BUT TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS
COMMITTEE DOES ITS JOB OF FULLY
VETTING THE POLICY BE RATHER
THAN JUST RUBBER STAMPING A
WORKS FOR ME YES THANK YOU.
SO FIRST OF ALL I WANT TO MAKE
IT ABSOLUTELY CLEAR THAT AS FAR
AS I'M CONCERNED IT'S NOT
CONTROVERSIAL.
THAT WE SHOULD HAVE SAFE
DRINKING WATER FOR ALL SO THE
QUESTION IS HOW DO WE GET THERE --
AND ON ON THE ISSUE OF THE WATER
FEE OR THE WATER TAX OUR WE MAY
CALL IT -- I'M NOT AFRAID OF
VOTING FOR A TAX OF VOTED FOR
TAXES BEFORE.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE HOWEVER THAT
THE THAT THE COSTS ARE A
RELIABLE -- THERE I AM HEARING
TESTIMONY THAT THE NUMBERS.
THERE THERE SEEM TO BE SOME
DIFFERENCES IN TERMS OF THE
AMOUNT.
NEEDED INTO THAT THE DOLLARS ARE
WELL SPENT.
YOU KNOW ALONG THE LINES OF
WHETHER THE DOLLARS ARE WELL
SPENT I I COMPLETELY AGREE WITH
THE AS BARRACK QUE AND THAT --
THAT THAT WE SHOULD BE ASKING
RATE PAYERS AND TAXPAYERS TO PAY
FOR POLLUTERS.
POLLUTERS IF THERE IF THERE THE
PROBLEM THEN THEY NEED TO PAY.
IF THEY IF THEY SHOULD BE PAYING
MORE THAN THAN THAN THIS BILL
SHOULD BE MAKING THEM PAY MORE.
I JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
RATE PAYERS AND TAXPAYERS ARE
NOT SUBSIDIZING BAD BEHAVIOR
[inaudible]
SO.
WAIT WAIT WITH THOSE.
BASIC -- CONCERNS IN MIND AND ON
OUR SIDE SKEWS ME I HAVE TO
PRESENT A BILL -- THE VICE CHAIR
IS VERY EXPERIENCED IN --
SITTING IN FOR ME.
ALL RIGHT BUT I KNOW THAT WE'RE
GOING TO HEAR EVERYONE'S
QUESTIONS AND I'LL BE BACK AS
QUICK AS I CAN.
SO MR GARCIA.
BY ON THE BASIC PRINCIPLE OF
MAKING SURE THAT THE POLLUTERS
PAY.
YEAH YOU YOU RESPONDED THAT TO
THAT THE WATER BOWL BOARD IS
HOLDING THE POLLUTERS
ACCOUNTABLE BUT HOW.
YOU KNOW WHY GIVE ME A COULD YOU
OF THE ELABORATE ON THAT YEAH WE
WE HAVE -- THEY ARE THE
REGULATORS.
AND WE PASSED POLICY THAT THEN
THEY IMPLEMENT.
RIGHT AND SO THEY ARE --
RESPONSIBLE DIRECTLY FOR
REGULATING -- SYSTEMS AND OR
INDUSTRIES.
THAT ARE OUT OF STATE COMPLIANCE
REGULATIONS -- THAT'S THE THE
BASES OF MY MY STATEMENT.
BUT TO CAN THE QUESTION.
IF IT IS FOUND -- THAT --
POLLUTERS.
ARE CONTRIBUTING TO THE PROBLEM
FAR GREATER THAN WHAT WE ARE
ESTIMATED IN THIS BILL THEN THIS
BILL OUGHT TO REFLECT THAT.
THERE'S NO QUESTION ABOUT THAT
OKAY -- SO ALONG THOSE LINES I
MEAN I I I I I AM ALL FOR WHAT
I'M HEARING IS THAT THE WATER
BOARD.
IS IS REGULATING AN AND IMPOSING
FINES OR PENALTIES WHEN THERE
ARE NOT.
IN COMPLIANCE WITH THE
REGULATIONS BUT WE WE HERE ARE
ARE FACED WITH THE THE ISSUE OF
WHO'S GOING TO PAY -- PRIMARILY
FOR THE OPERATION AND
MAINTENANCE A TO ENSURE A SAFE
DRINKING WATER FOR ALL AND SO
YOU KNOW THAT'S WERE.
I I AM NOT HEARING -- AND AND
AND AND IF I'M MISSING SOMETHING
I ASKING TO HELP ME OUT HERE BUT
I'M NOT.
HEARING HOW THE WATER BOARD
ENFORCEMENT ACTIVITIES ARE GOING
TO HELP PAY.
FOR THE OPERATION AND
MAINTENANCE COSTS OF INSURING
SAFE DRINKING WATER FOR ALL.
SO THE WAY THIS BILL IS BROKEN
DOWN IS THAT.
THERE WILL BE AGRICULTURE FEES
FERTILIZER FEES DAIRY FEES.
THERE'S A REQUEST OF TWO HUNDRED
MILLION FOR THE NEXT FIVE YEARS
TO BE PUT IN THE FUND SIMILAR TO
THE AQUA -- CONCEPT OF PROPOSAL
AND WE'RE ASKING THAT THERE BE A
FEE -- THAT IS A SERVICE
CONNECTION FOR YOU ON A MONTHLY
BASIS ON ON WATER AGENCIES A TO
BE ABLE TO THEN GENERATE.
THE ULTIMATE GOAL WHICH I STAND
CORRECTED CONTINUES TO BE ONE
HUNDRED AND FORTY MILLION
DOLLARS.
TOM.
COULD THE NUMBER CHANGE IT COULD
FROM NOW.
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS BASED ON
ADDITIONAL INFORMATION FROM THE
WATER BOARD.
THAT THERE MAY BE OTHER SYSTEMS
AND OTHER PLACES OF THE STATE --
THAT NEED TO BE INCORPORATED
INTO THIS EQUATION THIS IS BASED
ON THE MOST RECENT AND AVAILABLE
INFORMATION THAT WE HAVE -- AKA
REPRESENTATIVE HAS MENTIONED
THAT THE ESTIMATE AT ONE POINT
WAS IN THE FORTY FIFTY MILLION
DOLLARS CONSIDERING THE CLEAN UP
OF NITRATES -- AND THE
CONSOLIDATION -- WHAT WE WANT TO
MAKE SURE IS THAT -- NOT
EVERYONE HERE NOT EVERYONE IN
CALIFORNIA IS FACING THE SAME
PROBLEM WITH NITRATES -- THERE
ARE SCHOOLS IN DIFFERENT PARTS
OF CALIFORNIA THAT FACE THE
PROBLEM OF LET.
THERE ARE OTHER RURAL
COMMUNITIES THAT DON'T FACE THE
ISSUE OF NITRATES BUT HAVE HIGH
LEVELS OF ARSENIC AND CHROMIUM.
SIX AND SO WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT IF WE'RE ASKING.
ALL CALIFORNIANS TO PITCH IN TO
THIS PROBLEM.
THAT ALL CALIFORNIANS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO TAP INTO THIS FUN.
AND ADDRESS THEIR CLEAN WATER
PROBLEMS IN THEIR OWN BACKYARD.
OKAY SO ALONG THAT POINT THE DO
YOU HAVE.
DATA INDICATING WHAT PERCENTAGE
OF THESE -- NOW.
OPERATIONAL MAINTENANCE COSTS
ARE AND ACT AND IN AN
AGRICULTURAL AREAS VERSUS URBAN
AREAS.
I DON'T HAVE THAT INFORMATION ON
ME I I DON'T HAVE THAT OKAY THAT
WE WILL FOLLOW UP ON ALL RIGHT
SO -- BAG I I I APPRECIATE.
TO YOU KNOW -- YOU YOU TOLD ME
THAT THIS IS A AN ONGOING GO A
PROJECT IN AND AND I WILL
RESPECT THAT -- BUT THAT'S GOING
TO BE ONE OF THE THE THE THE
QUESTIONS THAT I'M GOING TO BE
LOOKING.
FOR IS -- YOU KNOW I MEAN I I I
SHARE SOME OF THE CONCERNS THAT
MR DOLLY HAS I WANT TO I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT THE THOSE DOLLARS
ARE BEING WELL SPENT THAT IT'S
NOT JUST.
TO A POLITICAL PITCH TO THROW IN
LA COUNTY AND AND TALK ABOUT HOW
THIS IS URBAN PROBLEM RATHER
THAN JUST ROLL PROBLEM.
OF BECAUSE YOU KNOW.
AGAIN I I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM
IN IN VOTING FOR ATTACKS IF IF
IF FIND.
IN A SURE THAT THOSE DOLLARS
COULD BE WELL SPENT -- THE SO SO
YOU KNOW IN IN IN IN IN TERMS OF
MAKING SURE THAT POLLUTERS PAY A
MEANING.
I DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM WITH WITH
JACKING UP WHAT YOU'RE PROPOSING
FOR FOR THE YOU KNOW FOR THE FOR
THE FOR THE DAIRY FOR THE
FERTILIZER FOR FOR AGRICULTURE.
IF THAT'S GOING TO YOU KNOW MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE PAYING THEIR
FAIR SHARE I I THINK THAT'S THE
THE THE THE THE DRIVING
PRINCIPLE THERE ARE ARE THEY
BEING ASKED TO TO PAY THEIR FAIR
SHARE -- SO THAT AGAIN RATE
PAYERS AND TAXPAYERS ARE.
ARE ARE ARE NOT YOU KNOW.
PAYING FOR THE POLLUTERS AND
THAT THAT'S ANOTHER QUESTION
THAT I'M GOING TO BE LOOKING --
FOR AS AS AS I'M GOING TO AS
THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD -- I
TALKED ABOUT -- HOW I GOT A --
BE LOOKING -- FOR YOU KNOW
MAKING SURE THAT WE HAVE A
RELIABLE SET OF COSTS THAT.
TO THAT AND THAT THIS BILL IS IS
IS BEING BASED ON AND I'M YOU
KNOW I I I WANT TO SHARE -- THE
CONCERNS OF IT MISS TALK IN IN
TERMS OF THIS BEING A PRECEDENT
I MEAN IT IT IT BOTHERS ME THAT
WE'RE AT YOUR SETTING A
PRECEDENT THAT WE'RE GONNA BE
TAXING WATER -- AND AND THAT'S
WHY AGAIN I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT YOU KNOW THEY THE
IMPLICATIONS OF THIS BILL.
I WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THOSE
DOLLARS ARE BASED ON SOLID
NUMBERS -- AND THAT AGAIN --
WHERE WE'RE NOT WE'RE NOT TO
PAYING FOR THE POLLUTERS -- SO
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE PRINCIPLES
THAT I'VE BEEN LOOKING FOR THANK
YOU THANK YOU.
OKAY A SETTLEMENT -- HOLD HOLDEN
HAS SOME QUESTIONS I BELIEVE DID
YOU HAVE SOMETHING TO ADD MISTER
GARCIA BEFORE ONE OF OUR ONE OF
OUR WITNESSES WANTED TO KINDA
OKAY I I'M SORRY MR HOME WOULD
YOU MIND HOLDING ON AND LETTING
HER DRESS SOME OF THOSE THANK
YOU.
THE MANAGER.
I LIKE TO JUST ADD I THINK IT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT THAT WE
UNDERSTAND THAT DRINKING WATER
CONTAMINATION HAS A VARIETY OF
DIFFERENT CONTAMINANTS.
AND I WILL SAY THE FACT THAT
WE'RE ALREADY THINKING ABOUT --
TAXING AGRICULTURE AND THERE AT
THE TABLE THEY RECOGNIZE THEY'VE
CONTRIBUTED TO CONTAMINATION.
AND THEY WANT TO BE PART OF THE
SOLUTION WHICH IS REALLY
HISTORIC.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT AND THE
CONTAMINANT THAT'S PART
PRIMARILY A BIGGEST SOURCE OF
CONTAMINATION FROM THE INDUSTRY
IS NITRATES.
NOW THAT SAID NEDRY DOES NOT THE
ONLY CONTAMINANT THAT WERE FACED
WITH SO SOME OF THOSE FEES A
WILL COME FROM THE INDUSTRY WILL
HELP.
SOLVE THE STE THE PROBLEM WHERE
WE DO HAVE NITRATES.
THE REALITY IS THAT AS WAS
MENTIONED BY OUR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA IS WE HAVE OTHER
CONTAMINANTS THAT WE ALSO HAVE
TO ADDRESS.
SUCH AS ARSENIC ONE TWO THREE T.
C. P. URANIUM BACTERIA PER
GLORIA IT GOES ON AND ON AND ON
AND FOR THOSE CONTAMINANTS WE TO
FIGURE OUT A SUSTAINABLE SOURCE
OF FUNDING. FOR THE OPERATION
AND MAINTENANCE MAINTENANCE OF
THIS CONTENT ARE THESE
CONTAMINANTS.
AND I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
RECOGNIZE THAT YES WE PASSED A
LOT OF FUN A BOND FUNDING BUT
NONE OF IT GOES TOWARDS THE
BIGGEST GAP WHICH IS OPERATION
AND MAINTENANCE AND THIS IS WHAT
THIS BILL WILL HELP ACHIEVE.
I ALSO JUST WANT TO RECOGNIZE
THAT AS WE TALK ABOUT SHORT TERM
SOLUTIONS LIKE THESE POINT OF
USE DEVICES.
I'M VERY CAUTIOUS WITH THAT
BECAUSE WHEN YOU INSTALL A
FILTER IN SOMEONE'S HOME.
YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
PERSONS MAINTAINING THE FILTER
BECAUSE IF YOU DON'T MAINTAIN
THOSE FILTERS THE FILTRATION
DEVICES IT ACTUALLY INCREASES
THE CONCENTRATION.
NOW I WILL SAY THAT WERE
ACTUALLY TESTING SOME PRIVATE
WELLS AND THE CENTRAL COAST AND
I'M SEEN SIX TIMES THE LEVEL OF
NIGHT TREATS THAT ARE THAT ARE
LIMITED IN OUR DRINKING WATER.
THERE'S CLEARLY NO CERTIFIED
DEVICE TO REDUCE THAT LEVEL OF
CONTAMINATION.
THERE'S OTHER LOCATIONS WHERE WE
HAVE MULTIPLE CONTAMINANTS LIKE
PER GLORIA AND NITRATES THERE'S
NO SOARED BY POINT OF USE THAT I
KNOW OF THAT CAN ACTUALLY REDUCE
THAT LEVEL OF CONCENTRATION NOW
I JUST WANT TO SAY.
THAT IN ADDITION TO THAT WE ALSO
HAVE THE NEED GAS -- CLINICS
WERE MEMBERS GOAL IN THE CLINICS
IN THEIR WATER FOUNTAINS.
WE HAD TO INSTALL A POINT OF
USED DEVICE BECAUSE WE HAD
ARSENIC SO YOU GO TO THE DOCTOR
TO GET BETTER BUT THE FOUNTAIN
AT THE DOCTOR'S OFFICE HAS
ARSENIC.
THESE ARE THE CONDITIONS THAT I
GOT TO SAY WERE ALSO VERY
FRUSTRATED WITH AND SOME OF OUR
MEMBERS ARE PAYING SOME OF THE
HIGHEST WATER RATES FOR TOXIC
WATER OVER EIGHTY DOLLARS A
MONTH.
AND ON TOP OF THE HAVE TO BUY
BOTTLED WATER SO I JUST WANT TO
REMIND US THAT THE REALITY RIGHT
NOW WE HAVE PLENTY OF STUDIES
THAT SHOW WHERE WE HAVE THE
PROBLEM.
AND THIS FUND WILL ALSO INCLUDE
PRIVATE WELLS WHEREAS I BELIEVE
THE TRUST DOESN'T INCLUDE THAT
AND WE HAVE MANY WELL THROUGHOUT
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT ALSO NEED THIS ASSISTANCE
IT'S NOT JUST ONLY PUBLIC WATER
SYSTEMS BUT ALSO INDIVIDUAL
PRIVATE WELL OWNERS ARE IN THE
SAME RISK OF MAKING SURE THAT
THEY HAVE SAFE DRINKING WATER.
OKAY I'M BACK -- WHERE ARE WE
NOW WHO IS?
MR HOLDING THIS UP.
WELCOME BACK THANK YOU.
IT WAS AN EASY BILL THANK GOD.
NOT LIKE THIS.
ONE A FIRST FOR MY MY QUESTION
IS MORE OF A CLARIFYING QUESTION
BUT LET ME BEFORE I ASKED THAT
QUESTION -- LET ME JUST STATE
FOR THE RECORD THAT -- I KNOW
THAT THE AUTHOR TO BE A VERY A
CONSUMMATE Là -- LAWMAKER AND A
VERY DILIGENT IN TERMS OF
PUTTING THE PIECES TOGETHER WHEN
I HEARD.
OF THE THE OPPONENTS OR THOSE
WHO HAD.
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE BILL OF
THEIR STILL POSITION THEMSELVES
IN A POSITION OF WORKING WITH
YOU SO THEY HAVE NOT AS SER GONE --
YOU KNOW TO THE HARDCORE NO AND
AND I THINK THAT IS A TESTAMENT
OF UNDERSTANDING HOW YOU'RE
WILLING TO TAKE WHAT IS A VERY --
A BIG BILL AND AND TRYING TO
MAKE SURE THAT ALL THE PIECES
COME TOGETHER AND AND THEY MAKE
SENSE -- AND SO -- HI I WOULD
LIE MYSELF A LOT OF THE
QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN ASKED WHICH
YOU'VE ALREADY INDICATED -- OR
IN YOUR WILL HOUSE TO TRY TO GET.
OF THE ANSWERS.
TO MY MY QUESTION IS A AS A CO
AUTHOR.
OF CERTAINLY -- ALIGN MYSELF
WITH THE INCREDIBLE BENEFITS
THAT THIS BILL IS DESIGNED TO
ACCOMPLISH.
WHAT I WANTED TO DO WAS -- IN
THE MANY ANALYSIS.
WHERE IT IS ON PAGE TWELVE
REFERRING TO POTENTIAL
AMENDMENTS I THINK THAT SHE EVER?
REFERRED TO IT EARLIER -- WE'RE
DESCRIBES -- THE BILL COULD BE
AMENDED TO IMPOSE A FIFTY CENT.
OF PER CONNECTION FEE ON ALL
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS AND REQUIRE
ALL PUBLIC.
WATER SYSTEMS TO REMIT THE FEE
TO THE STATE WATER BOARD.
OF IT'S MY UNDERSTANDING THAT
THE PUBLIC WATER.
SYSTEM INCLUDES WHOLESALERS AND
I'M I'M WONDERING IF THIS
CREATES A POTENTIAL FOR A RATE
PAYERS. TO BE -- HAVE A FEE
OPPOSE TWICE AS TO IF IF THE
WHOLESALERS AND RETAILERS FALL
UNDER.
OF THIS -- STATE WATER BOARD OUR
SYSTEM OF WHAT IS IT THE
INTENTION.
OF THE BILL -- TO HAVE THE FEE
APPLY TO RETAILERS AND
WHOLESALERS.
BUT ONE TIME.
RIGHT NOW OKAY TWICE.
IT'S A WILL MAKE SURE THAT THAT
IS MADE VERY CLEAR.
IN THE LANGUAGE OF THE BILL OKAY.
THAT'S THAT'S WHY I WANT TO
CLEAR THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
THAT UP THANK.
VERY GOOD THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUESTION -- WOULD ANYONE ELSE
LIKE TO YES MADAM VICE CHAIR
THANK YOU AND THE LAST ONE I
THINK THAT HAS A SPOKESMAN
EXCEPT FOR MISTER BLOOM EVER
THERE -- SO THINK WE'LL GET
HISTORY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN -- SO
A COUPLE OF POINTS THAT I WANT
TO MAKE -- I YOU KNOW I HAVE TO
AGREE WITH MY COLLEAGUE.
THAT MENTIONED THAT WE HAVE
ALREADY TAKEN A NUMBER OF STEPS --
TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S ADEQUATE
CLEAN DRINKING WATER FOR
CALIFORNIANS IN.
SOME OF THE BALLOT MEASURES THAT
HAVE BEEN PASSED -- WE JUST.
WITH THAT LAST YEAR WE JUST
PASSED THE BILL THAT WOULD ALLOW
SOME OF THESE WATER -- DISTRICTS
TO BE CONSOLIDATED IF THEY
WEREN'T ABLE TO PROVIDE CLEAN
DRINKING WATER SINCE THAT TIME
SINCE THE BILL WAS PASSED. ONE
HAS BEEN CONSOLIDATED.
THAT'S IT SO WHEN ASSEMBLYMAN
DOLLY SUGGEST THAT HE HAS A
MISTRUST OF HOW THIS PROCESS IS
GOING TO PLAY OUT I HAVE TO
AGREE AND I THINK EVERYONE IN
THIS ROOM SHOULD BE A LITTLE
SUSPECT.
OF YOU KNOW I MIGHT START OFF
WITH GREAT INTENTIONS BUT IN THE
END DOES IT TURN OUT THE WAY WE
EXPECTED -- THERE'S DISCUSSION
ABOUT IS THAT IT IS A TAX IS A
FEE -- IT'S A TAX.
IT'S A TAX IN AND I AND I DON'T
KNOW HOW.
THIS MAY PLAY OUT ON THE COURT I
DON'T KNOW WATER IS IN THIS IS
IT IS A HUMAN RIGHT.
RIGHT DON'T WE WE AGREE ON THAT
WATER IS A RIGHT SO I DON'T.
I'M HAVING A HARD TIME
RATIONALIZING THIS IN MY HEAD
HOW WE'RE GOING TO TAX SOMETHING
THAT IS A RIGHT -- HOW THAT
THAT'S NOT UNCONSTITUTIONAL --
WHICH IS SOMETHING I'M SURE
YOU'VE CONTEMPLATED AND I'M SURE
YOU'VE HEARD THROUGHOUT THIS
PROCESS BUT I WILL TELL YOU FROM
MY OWN PERSPECTIVE.
EVEN NOW I'M SURE YOU MAY ASSUME
THAT JUST BECAUSE I'M A
REPUBLICAN EVERY TIME I HEAR THE
WORD TAX THAT.
YOU KNOW MY BLOOD STARTS TO CURL
THAT'S NOT TRUE BUT I WILL TELL
YOU THAT AS A AS A AS A SOMEONE
WHO FEELS IT'S HER OBLIGATION IN
YOURS. TO DEFEND THE TAXPAYERS
MONEY I THINK WE NEED TO TAKE
THIS SERIOUSLY AS TO WHETHER OR
NOT IT'S TAX -- FEE AND NOT GET
BATTLE AND LET THE COURTS DECIDE
WHAT THE INTENT WAS AND WHAT
THIS ACTUALLY IS [inaudible]
I'M.
I MEAN ASK YOU STRAIGHT OUT.
BECAUSE I HAVE HEARD RUMORS IN
THEY MAY JUST BE THAT RUMORS BUT
I HAVE HEARD RUMORS THAT.
AT SOME POINT.
THIS BILL IS GOING TO CHANGE AND
SOMETHING WILL BE INSERTED THAT
WILL EXEMPT -- LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS FROM PAYING THIS
TAX OR FEE WHICH EVERYONE A
COLLEGE IS THAT YOUR INTENTION.
SO WE HAVE EVERY INTENTION TO
MAKE SURE THAT IF THERE ARE
MECHANISMS.
THE WEEK IN INTEGRATE INTO THE
BILL TO PROTECT DOLE'S.
WHO COULD LEAST AFFORD TO PAY?
WHAT DO SO AND WILL USE POVERTY
LINE?
UP PERCENTAGES RIGHT UP BUT I
WANT TO HIGHLIGHT.
THE PEOPLE THAT YOU HEARD FROM
TODAY IN THAT CATEGORY -- AS IT
RELATES -- TO INCOME LEVELS.
AND THEY'RE HERE SAYING THAT
WE'RE PAYING A LOT OF MONEY
ALREADY. FOR DIRTY WATER.
AND WE DON'T MIND PAYING TWO
QUARTERS -- IF THE GOVERNOR DOES
HIS PART AND PUTS DOWN THE BIG
DOWN PAYMENT.
AND THEN INDUSTRY.
DOES THEIR PART AND PAY THOSE
FEES.
OF THAT THEY DON'T HAVE A
PROBLEM WITH THAT BUT I GUESS.
TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTION IT'S NOT
A RUMOR WE ARE EXPLORING --
LANGUAGE MECHANISMS THAT WOULD
CREATE AN OPPORTUNITY TO PROTECT
US CERTAIN POPULATIONS ARE FROM
DOING SO NOT ONE I ALSO WANT TO
MAKE JUST THE DRAW.
CORRELATION BETWEEN -- FEES THAT
WE PAY IN OUR ELECTRICAL BILLS.
THAT GO TO A PUBLIC BENEFIT FUND.
AT THE P. YOU SEE.
THAT OLD TIMIDLY GO BACK TO
COMMUNITIES TO ESTABLISH LOW
INCOME RATE PROGRAMS AND OTHER
TYPES OF PUBLIC BENEFIT.
SERVICES AND PROGRAMS AND SO THE
IDEA THAT THERE'S PRESIDENT
BEING SAID IS NOT EXACTLY
ACCURATE.
WHEN IT COMES TO A FUNDAMENTAL
AND BASIC -- UTILITY -- THAT WE
ALL NEED AS WELL PERHAPS WATER.
FALLS HIGHER THAN THE POWER
CONVERSATION BUT THIRD IN MANY
WAYS ONE IN THE SAME WHEN IT
COMES TO ESSENTIAL.
OF AMENITIES -- THAT WE NEED --
SO -- THE ANSWER'S YES WE ARE
LOOKING AT IT AND WE'RE HOPEFUL
THAT WE COULD GET SOME LANGUAGE
THAT WILL BE.
INTEGRATED THERE BUT I DO WANT
TO REMIND YOU THAT THE MAJORITY
OF PEOPLE.
WHO COME IN SUPPORT THIS BILL
ARE THE PEOPLE THAT -- ARE
SAYING WE DON'T HAVE A PROBLEM
PAYING FOR THIS -- AND WE'RE THE
ONES THAT ARE GOING TO BE
DIRECTLY IMPACTED IN MR GARCIA
JUST TO BE CLEAR -- MANY OF THE
PEOPLE ON FOR INSTANCE IN TULARE
AND AND THE CENTRAL VALLEY WHO
ARE IN SUPPORT OF PAYING THIS
EXTRA TAX -- WE ARE RECOGNIZING
OF COURSE THAT THERE ARE SO MANY
OTHERS THAT ARE IN A WELL SYSTEM
THE WOULD NOT BE PAYING THAT TAX
CORRECT.
SO THE WAY I BELIEVE -- AND IT
WAS JUST MENTIONED THAT THE FUND
THE TRUST FUND DOES ACTUALLY
INCORPORATE -- WELLS -- BUT YEAH
NEEDS THAT I GRADED IN THE
AMENDMENT YOU'VE TAKEN.
DOES NOT INCLUDE PAYMENTS FOR
WELL WE'RE TALKING ABOUT I'M
ACTIONS ONLY.
YOU'RE TALKING THAT CONNECTS
RIGHT ONLY WELLS ARE NOT
CONNECTED BUT THEY WILL BENEFIT
BUT THEY BUT THEY WON'T BE
PAYING BUT THEY WON'T BE PAYING
BUT TELL.
OKAY I JUST WANT TO BE CLEARER
ABOUT.
OKAY THANK YOU MISTER.
BUT I DID WANT TO MENTION
BECAUSE IT'S BEEN BROUGHT TO MY
ATTENTION THAT THE CONSOLIDATION
REQUIRES RESOURCES.
RIGHT.
YOU NEED THE RESOURCES TO
CONSOLIDATE THE SYSTEMS AND SO
THE FACT THAT THERE'VE BEEN.
JUST.
ONE TELLS US THAT THE NOW WE
HAVE THE PROBLEM.
AND THIS IS TRYING TO ADDRESS
THAT DIRECTLY.
OKAY CAN I TAKE THAT IS YOUR
CLOSE I THINK WE'VE WE'VE DONE
ALL WE CAN.
YES SIR RESPECT YES FREE I'VE
OPENED OUR EYES WERE MATTER --
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL -- WE MEDIA MOTION -- OF
HOLDEN.
SECOND BLOOM OKAY.
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR PATIENCE.
THIS IS ITEM ONE AB TWO
SEVENTEEN EDUARDO GARCIA THE
MOTION IS DO PASSES AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS.
QUIRK.
HI QUIRK I MELENDEZ.
MELENDEZ NOT VOTING.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I OUR CAN [inaudible]
DALLY [inaudible]
CRISTINA GARCIA [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN I AM [inaudible]
MATHIS.
WHAT A TO G.?
THE JAPANESE. TWO THREE FOUR WE
NEED TO HOLD IT.
YEAH WE HAVE -- WE NEED ONE I'M
PRETTY SURE WE'LL GET IT -- SO
WEIRD NOW PREPARED FOR MR
BLOOM'S BELL WHICH IS IMMEDIATE
FOLLOW UP
.
WELL I'M GLAD THAT -- MISTER
GARCIA ONE THAT CORN TOSS.
WHO IS GOING TO GO FIRST?
OKAY PLEASE YEAH PLEASE PROCEED.
AS YOUR GUIDE WHEN YOU GET
COMFORTABLE THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
I I WANT -- TO AS MANY OF YOU
DID ACKNOWLEDGE -- THE FOLKS WHO
WERE HERE ADVOCATING ON THIS
BILL I THINK IT'S A GOOD WAY TO
BEGIN WE HAVE THIS ISSUE LAST
WEEK.
IN BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE THREE AND
I CAN TELL YOU THERE WERE
PROBABLY FIVE TIMES AS MANY
PEOPLE HERE.
MOST OF THEM FROM THE SAME
COMMUNITIES THAT WERE THAT WERE
REPRESENTED HERE THIS MORNING
THE AND I I TELL YOU THAT
BECAUSE SOME.
I WANT YOU TO KNOW HOW INTENSE
THE INTEREST IS IN RESOLVING
THIS ISSUE.
I'VE ONLY BEEN INVOLVED FOR
ABOUT THREE YEARS -- WHEN
SENATOR MINING -- CAME TO ME A
COUPLE YEARS AGO AND SOUGHT TO A
TO TO WORK TOGETHER -- IN IN THE
FIRST YEAR WE WEREN'T ABLE TO
MAKE PROGRESS LAST YEAR IT WAS
IT WAS IN THE BUDGET WE SPENT A
CONSIDERABLE AMOUNT OF TIME --
TRYING TO ADDRESS THIS ISSUE AND
OF COURSE HERE WE ARE AGAIN
HAVING.
BEEN UNSUCCESSFUL LAST YEAR --
WE'RE DEALING WITH THE SAME.
OR SIMILAR STRUCTURE -- EIGHT
AND AND WE ARE STUCK IN MORE OR
LESS THE SAME PLACES SOMETHING
HAS TO GIVE.
THE PROPOSAL THAT YOU HEARD FROM
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA IS A
THOUGHTFUL AND ROBUST.
ONE ON THAT DOES ADDRESS THE
NEEDS OF THE FAILING WATER
SYSTEMS THAT WE HAVE AROUND THE
STATE THIS HAS TRULY HOW BAD YOU
ADDRESS YOUR BILL YEAH I'M
GETTING THERE SENATE RIGHT IT'S
THE NEXT PARAGRAPH SIR.
SAME WE DID WE GET HERE NINETY
MINUTES ON THAT [inaudible]
ONE HI.
A WHAT MISS OPEN THE ROLE REAL
QUICK SO I COULD VOTE ON THAT
LAST BILL AND I HAVE A SURE
THING.
THEY HANDED HER MY FOR INDULGING
ME -- MADAM SECRETARY -- PLEASE
CALL OKAY I'M CALLING THE ROLE
ON ITEM ONE AB TWO SEVENTEEN
EDUARDO GARCIA.
OF THE VOTE IS NOW AT FOUR ZERO
DALLI.
DALLIS AND NOW.
AND MATHIS.
MATHIS NOW [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
OKAY SCENARIO -- MISSED MISTER
CHAIR A AB TWENTY TWO SEVENTEEN
CREATES THE FUNDING STREAM AND
A. B..
ONE THIRTY FOUR ACCOMPLISHES THE
GOAL OF FOR A OF MAKING SURE
THAT WE ENSURE THAT THE FUNDS
ARE SPENT TRANSPARENTLY AND
EFFECTIVELY.
THE BILL IS PRETTY SIMPLE -- AND
STATES THAT IF AND WHEN A SAFE
AND AFFORDABLE DRINKING WATER
FUND IS ESTABLISHED.
THE MONEY IN THE FUND SHOULD BE
SUBJECT TO TO REQUIREMENTS ONE
THAT THE FUNDING BE DISPLAYED IN
THE ANNUAL GOVERNOR'S BUDGET.
INCLUDING REVENUES EXPENDITURES
AND FUND BALANCES AND TO THAT
EVERY FIVE YEARS THE LA -- WILL
PROVIDE AN ASSESSMENT OF THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF EXPENDITURES
MANY EXISTING WATER SYSTEMS DID
NOT HAVE THE TECHNICAL -- DO NOT
HAVE THE TECHNICAL OR FINANCIAL
CAPACITY TO ADDRESS THEIR
ONGOING COSTS -- AND THAT WAS A
SUBSTANTIAL FACTOR IN THEIR
ULTIMATE FAILURE HAVING A
FUNDING SOURCE THAT PROVIDES
CONTINUITY IS IMPORTANT BUT WE
ALSO WANT TO MAKE SURE.
THAT AS WE DISTRIBUTE FUNDING WE
VALUE GOVERNANCE AND LONG TERM
SUSTAINABILITY.
OF US SOME OF THAT IS ADDRESSED
IN AB TWO SEVENTEEN AND HAS BEEN
A FOCUS OF MANY OTHER
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS. TO
CONSOLIDATE SMALL SYSTEMS AND IN
SOME INSTANCES -- WITH ME TOO
MANAGERIAL THE INTERVENED AND
FAILING SYSTEMS.
SO -- WE WANT TO ADDRESS THOSE
ISSUES IN AB ONE THIRTY FOUR AND
GIVE THE LEGISLATURE SOME
CERTAINTY THAT THE MONEY WILL BE
SPENT.
JUDICIOUSLY AND EFFECTIVELY AS
HAS ALREADY BEEN PREVIOUSLY
DISCUSSED WITH ME HERE TODAY ARE
JENNIFER CLEARING FROM CLEAN
WATER ACTION.
I THINK I SAW JONATHAN NELSON OF
COMMUNITY WATER CENTER AND
PHOEBE SETON OF THE LEADERSHIP
COUNCIL.
JENNIFER CLARY CLEAN WATER
ACTION AND I JUST WANT TO SAY
THAT THIS IS A VERY IMPORTANT
BILL I'VE BEEN DOING THIS FOR
SIXTEEN YEARS NOW.
AND THE ONE THING THAT WE'VE
BEEN ABLE TO COUNT ON IN TRYING
TO GET ACCESS TO SAFE DRINKING
WATER FOR COMMUNITIES IS THE
SUPPORT OF THE LEGISLATURE.
I KNOW PERFECTLY WELL WHAT A
DYSFUNCTIONAL AGENCY LOOKS LIKE
THAT'S WHY THE DRINKING WATERPROGRAMS THAT THE STATE WATER
BOARD AND IN THE FOUR AND A HALF
YEARS IT'S BEEN THERE WE'VE MADE
GREAT STRIDES.
AND SO HAVING ACCOUNTABILITY
HERE HAVING THE LEGISLATURE
REMAIN PART OF THE SOLUTION IF
YOU AS YOU HAVE BEEN FOR SO LONG
IS USUALLY IMPORTANT AND THAT'S
WHY WE SUPPORT THE BILL.
THANK YOU.
YEAH I AM.
I I CAN'T JONATHAN OUT SO I
COULD TAKE OVER HIS FIVE MINUTES
IS JUST GETTING CHAIR OF PVC IN
LEADERSHIP COUNCIL FOR JUSTICE
AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
I AGREE WITH -- WITH EVERYTHING
THAT JENNIFER SAID WE'VE HEARD
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR
THREE YEARS HEARD A LOT OF
INTEREST IN -- ENSURING THAT
LEGISLATIVE OVERSIGHT AND
ACCOUNTABILITY OF THE PROGRAM.
AND SUPPORT THIS PROPOSAL GREAT
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
ARE THOSE ALSO IN SUPPORT.
GAIL DEL HAND WITH WESTERN
GROWERS ASSOCIATION WHERE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
MORE NO INTELLIGENT ON BEHALF OF
CALIFORNIA CITRUS MUTUAL IN
CALIFORNIA FRESH FRUIT
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
CHEN MEMBERS JONATHAN NELSON
BEHALF OF THE COMMUNITY WATER
CENTER IN SUPPORT WE THANK
MASTER PLAN FOR ITS LEADERSHIP
AND LOOK FOR TO WORKING WITH YOU
ON THIS.
GOOD AFTERNOON TURN MEMBERS
TRICIA GERINGER AGRICULTURAL
COUNCIL OF CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MERION
WARMER DOWN FOR A COUNTY
REPRESENT IS A CALIFORNIA ALSO
IN SUPPORT.
MELISSA ROMERO ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEAGUE OF
CONSERVATION VOTERS AND SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE MOORE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF MUTUAL
WATER COMPANIES WE SUPPORT THE
BILL LOOK FOR TO CONTINUE
CONVERSATIONS.
JIM LINDBERGH ON BEHALF OF THE
FRIENDS COMMITTEE ON LEGISLATION
TO CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT ANY OPPOSITION.
CAN I HAVE A MOTION.
ALL RIGHT -- WE HAVE A MOTION AT
THE ANY OTHER QUESTIONS I DON'T
SEE ANY.
YOU MAY CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR OF A THANK YOU.
OUR CHAIRS RECOMMENDATION IS I
FOR CAN ABILITY -- MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER.
TWO A. B. ONE THIRTY FOUR BLOOM.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK.
AYE.
QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ.
WHEN DOES NOT VOTING BLOOM?
AYE BLOOM AYE [inaudible]
BAUER-KAHAN [inaudible]
DALY [inaudible]
CRISTINA GARCIA [inaudible]
HOLDEN [inaudible]
THE NINE MATHIS.
MATH IS NOT VOTING.
WHAT I TO CHANGE MURATSUCHI I?
FOR ME TO HOLD IT OPEN.
OKAY SO WE NEED ONE MORE AND I'M
SURE WE'LL GET IT -- ALL RIGHT
NOW WE'LL GET BACK TO THE
REGULAR ON THEIR BUSINESS AND
WE'LL START WITH THE CONSENT --
NO I WANT TO DO CONSENT FIRST.
SHOULD I STAY HERE YOU CAN STAY
ABSOLUTELY.
SELL ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
WE HAVE THREE ITEMS I KNOW I
HAVE IT HERE SOMEWHERE -- OKAY
AND THERE IT IS -- I'VE.
OKAY ITEM NUMBER FOUR A. B.
THIRTY THREE ITEM NUMBER TEN A.
B. THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN ITEM
NUMBER TWELVE AB.
FIFTY NINETY SEVEN IF THERE NO
QUESTIONS MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS THE CONSENT CALENDAR
ITEM NUMBER FOUR AB SEVEN THIRTY
THIRTY THREE QUIRK IT'S TO PASS
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS RECOMMENDING
CONSENT ITEM NUMBER.
TEN AB THIRTEEN FIFTY SEVEN
QUIRK IT'S TO PASS RE REFER TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
RECOMMEND CONSENT ITEM NUMBER.
TWELVE AB -- FIFTY NINETY SEVEN
AB FIFTY NINETY SEVEN COMMITTEE
ON ENVIRONMENTAL SAFETY AND
TOXIC MATERIALS.
THAT'S TO PASS RE REFER TO
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS WITH
THE RECOMMENDATION OF CONSENT
QUIRK.
AYE QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ MELINDA'S
AYE BLOOM AYE BLOOM I
BAUER-KAHAN.
DALY.
CRISTINA GARCIA HOLDEN HOLDEN I
AM.
MATHIS.
MOOD AT SUIT MY MATHIS I THINK
YOU MORE THAT'S WHAT SHE WOULD
HAVE TO GI SO WE HAVE SIX VOTES
HI THAT PASSES OUT WE FINALLY
PASSED SOMETHING [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
NOW NOW AREN'T YOU GLAD YOU
DIDN'T SIT IN THE FRONT ROW ALL
THAT TIME.
VERY HAPPY TO UPSET WHERE I DID
OKAY.
VERY HAPPY ALL RIGHT.
NOW I HAVE SOMETHING A LITTLE
DIFFERENT.
HE SAID GO AHEAD AB SEVENTEEN
EIGHTY EIGHT TO A MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS REGULATIONS THAT
WERE ENACTED IN TWENTY FOURTEEN
TO MINIMIZE HARM FROM ONE SUBSET
OF RODENTICIDE ITS.
SECOND GENERATION ANTI COAGULANT
WROTE DOWN THE SIDES.
HAVE PROVEN INEFFECTIVE AS
NECROPSY DATA PERFORMED BY THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF FISH
AND WILDLIFE AND OTHER
SCIENTISTS HAVE DEMONSTRATED
THAT UNNECESSARY POISONINGS
CONTINUE TO POSE A SIGNIFICANT
THREAT. TO WILDLIFE AND PATHS.
THE USER BROKE DOWN THE SIDES BY
LICENSE PEST CONTROL APPLICATORS
TO STILL ALLOW RODENTS TO
CONSUMER DATA SITES.
AND THEN -- THEY IN TURN POISON
UPPER LEVEL PREDATORS WHICH
RESULTS IN CONTINUED DEATHS OF
WILDLIFE AND PATS.
POISONINGS AND DEATHS IN
CALIFORNIA HAVE BEEN DOCUMENTED
IN NUMEROUS SPECIES SUCH AS
EAGLES HAWKS FALCONS OWLS
BOBCATS.
MOUNTAIN LIONS AND EVEN THE
IMPERILED SAN JOAQUIN KIT FOX
AND NORTHERN SPOTTED OWL THE
PROBLEM IS SO SEVERE THAT OVER
70% OF WILDLIFE TESTED IN
CALIFORNIA -- WAS SHOWN TO HAVE
BEEN EXPOSED TO RODENTICIDE.
AND RODENTICIDE ALSO POSE A RISK
TO CHILDREN PETS AND DOMESTIC
ANIMALS.
IN FACT MORE THAN ONE HUNDRED
PETS NEEDLESSLY DIE EACH YEAR
DUE TO RODENTICIDE EXPOSURE.
AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT SIX TO
TAKE STRONGER MEASURES TO
PROTECT CHILDREN PETS AND
WILDLIFE FROM UNINTENTIONAL
RODENTICIDE POISONING BY BANNING
THE USE AND SALE OF SECOND
GENERATION.
ANTI COAGULANT RODENTICIDE STATE
WIDE AND THE USE OF FIRST
GENERATION ANTI COAGULANT
RODENTICIDE ON STATE OWNED
PROPERTY.
NEW ENVIRONMENTALLY RESPONSIBLE
AND MORE HUMANE.
MEANS OF CONTROLLING RODENT
POULATIONS ARE INCREASINGLY
BEING DEVELOPED AND SUCCESSFULLY
USED BY THE PEST MANAGEMENT
INDUSTRY WHICH OFFERS US HOPE
FOR THE FUTURE.
YET ACCORDING TO RESEARCHERS AT
UCLA VIRTUALLY EVERY MOUNTAIN
LION -- THAT UCLA AND AND PS
HAVE TESTED AND 90% OF THE
BOBCATS TESTED FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA HAVE TESTED POSITIVE
FOR ANTI COAGULANT RODENTICIDE.
POST FOR BOTH FIRST AND SECOND
GENERATION.
RODENTICIDE THAT KILLED SEVERAL
OF AN ALREADY STRUGGLING
POPULATION OF SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA MOUNTAIN LIONS.
GIVEN THE OVERWHELMING HARM
POSED BY RODENTICIDE AND THE
AVAILABILITY OF COST EFFECTIVE
ALTERNATIVES.
THESE POISONS SHOULD BE BETTER
REGULATED.
WILL CONTINUE TO WORK WITH YOUR
STAFF AS THE BILL MOVES FORWARD
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE. TO INFLUENCE HER TO TESTIFY.
NOW WITH THIS IS A TWO MINUTES
EACH.
THANK YOU.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR STEPHANIE
LEWIS I AM A FULL TIME WILDLIFE
AND A MERION AT THE CALIFORNIA
WILDLIFE CENTER IN CALABASAS.
I RECEIVED MY VETERINARY DEGREE
AND COMPLETED A SPECIALTY
INTERNSHIP AND WILDLIFE MEDICINE
AT TUFTS UNIVERSITY.
THE CALIFORNIA WILDLIFE CENTER
RECEIVES OVER FOUR THOUSAND
PATIENTS EACH YEAR ALL OF THEM
SICK INJURED OR ORPHANED
WILDLIFE NATIVE TO SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
OVER JUST THE PAST TWELVE MONTHS
WE'VE TREATED AT LEAST ELEVEN
PATIENTS SUFFER SUFFERING FROM
SECONDARY ANTI COAGULANT
RODENTICIDE TALK TO CLOSE THIS.
AND OVER THE COURSE OF MY CAREER
AS A VETERINARIAN AS A WILDLIFE
REHABILITATION -- I'VE TREATED
MANY MORE ANIMALS BOTH WILD AND
DOMESTIC IMPACTED BY THESE
POISONS.
THE EFFECTS OF ANTI COAGULANT
ARE INSIDIOUS.
ANIMALS AFFECTED SLOWLY LOSE BUT
THEY'RE A SMALL WOUND OR INTO AN
ORGAN OR BODY CAVITY.
SICK WILDLIFE TEND TO HIDE IN
ORDER TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
WHICH MEANS THAT THE NUMBER OF
PATIENTS ACTUALLY MAKE IT TO MY
EXAM TABLE LIKELY FAR
UNDERESTIMATES HOW MANY.
ARE SUFFERING FROM THESE POISONS
IN THE WILD.
I ALMOST ALL I ALSO ALMOST
EXCLUSIVELY SEE ANIMALS A VERY
LATE IN THE COURSE OF THEIR
ILLNESS.
THE LAST PIECE I RELEASE WAS AN
ADULT RED SHOULDERED HAWKS WHO
HAD LOST OVER 80% OF HER RED
BLOOD CELLS THROUGH A LACERATION
ON A TOE THAT WAS LESS THAN FIVE
MILLIMETERS LONG.
ONCE YOU PRESENTED TO ME SHE WAS
TOO WEAK TO STAND OR EVEN OVER
OPEN OUR EYES.
SADLY IN MY EXPERIENCE AT LEAST
HALF -- TO OVER 80% OF BIRDS OF
PREY WITH SECONDARY A. R. TALK
THE CLOSEST DIE WITHIN THE FIRST
TWENTY FOUR HOURS A PRESENTATION.
BEFORE MY VITAMIN K. THERAPY HAS
HAD TIME TO COUNTERACT THE
POISON AND RESTORE CAN THE
STATE'S US.
I'VE SEEN ANIMALS BLEED INTO
THEIR LUNGS CAUSING VERY SEVERE
DISTRESS AS WELL INTO THEIR
BRAINS HER EYES JOINTS AND
MUSCLES CAUSING SEVERE PAIN AND
PERMANENT DISABILITIES.
HOWEVER THE FULL EXTENT TO WHICH
THIS POISON HAS IMPACTED
WILDLIFE IS LIKELY
UNDERESTIMATED.
WHAT KIND OF WAR SUCH AS BOBCATS
MOUNTAIN LIONS ARE SUBJECT TO
CHRONIC LONG TERM SUB LEGAL
EXPOSURE TO A VARIETY OF
ANTICOAGULANTS?
AND THIS IS BELIEVED TO ALTERED
GENE EXPRESSION AND THE MUSE
SYSTEM HEALTH.
RESEARCHER IN WILD FIELDS IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA BY DOCTOR
SOUTH RILEY AND OTHERS OVER THE
PAST DECADE HAVE DETERMINED A
LINK BETWEEN ANTI COAGULANT
RODENTICIDE EXPOSURE AND NO TO
EITHER MEANS A PARASITIC DISEASE
THAT PREVIOUSLY HAD RARELY CAUSE
MORTALITY ANY SPECIES.
IN.
TWO THOUSAND FOUR YOUR NUMBER
WITH.
DO YOU HAVE ANOTHER WITNESS SIR
YES -- WE PROBABLY SHOULD GIVE
TIME TO THE OTHER WITNESS --
YOU'VE USED UP TWO MINUTES AND
SIXTEEN SECONDS PERHAPS YOU CAN
JUST SUMMARIZE YOUR CONCLUSIONS.
I'M SURE -- SO AT NEW AGAIN AS A
DOCTOR.
AS THAT MR BLUEBERRY SAID --
100% OF THE NINETEEN BOBCATS
THAT DIED OF SEVERE MAIN HAD A
OUR EXPOSURE -- AND THE LOSS OF
THESE APEX PREDATORS IS
RECOGNIZED BY BIOLOGIST HAVE A
CASCADE EFFECT THAT CAUSES
WIDESPREAD DESTRUCTION OF
ECOSYSTEMS AND THIS CAN LEAD TO
CHANGES IN EDUCATION WILD FIRE
FREQUENCY INFECTIOUS DISEASES
INVASIVE SPECIES AND WATER
QUALITY -- AGAIN THE THE THE
EXPOSURE FREQUENT WILDLIFE IS IF
WE WE WE HAVE TO LEAVE SOME TIME
FOR THE OTHER WITNESS.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF COMMITTEE MY NAME IS JONATHAN
EVANS I AM THE ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH LEGAL DIRECTOR WITH THE
CENTER FOR BIOLOGICAL DIVERSITY.
ALSO A MEMBER OF THE DEPARTMENT
OF PESTICIDE REGULATION
SPECIFIED MANAGEMENT VISOR
COMMITTEE.
MUCH OF MY CAREER HAS BEEN
FOCUSED ON REDUCING THE HARM TO
WILDLIFE -- FROM -- FROM
PESTICIDES AND IN PARTICULAR
SECOND GENERATION ANTICOAGULANT
WERE DONE A SIDES ARE THE MOST
DEVASTATING PESTICIDE FOR
CALIFORNIA'S MOST ICONIC.
WILDLIFE SUCH AS MOUNTAIN LIONS
BOBCATS SANDWICH CAM K<c.cyan> BOXES</c>
PACIFIC FISHER'S.
THERE BEEN A NUMBER OF
INCREMENTAL STEPS TO REDUCE THE
HARM OF THE BIRD AND ITS SIDES
IN PARTICULAR THE SECOND
GENERATION ANTI GOING OVER IN A
SIZE THAT ARE THE TARGET.
OF THIS BILL BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION AND EPA BECAUSE THEY
RECOGNIZE THE SEVERE HARM OF
THESE PRODUCTS.
UNFORTUNATELY WE'RE STILL SEEING
INCREDIBLY WIDESPREAD EXPOSURE
AND INDEED DIRECT MORTALITY AND
LEAVE THE MORTALITY OF A LOT OF
DIFFERENT WILDLIFE SPECIES.
THE BILL BEFORE US TODAY AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT AS A MUCH
CLEANER MORE EFFICIENT AND
EFFECTIVE STRATEGY THAN ANY OF
THE REGULATORY STEP THAT COULD
BE TAKEN.
DPR RECENTLY OPENED UP THE
REEVALUATION PROCESS BECAUSE OF
THE HARM A SECOND GENERATION AND
I QUITE OVER IN THE SIDES.
UNFORTUNATELY THE PAST TRACK
RECORD IN IMPLEMENTING
RESTRICTIONS.
ON A TENANT TO FOURTEEN YOUR
SCALE FOR THESE TYPES OF RED AND
SIDES REALLY WILL NOT MINIMIZE
THE HARM OF THESE PRODUCTS IN
THE SHORT TERM.
THERE ARE RANGE OF SAFE COUGHED
COST EFFECTIVE.
TOOL IN THE TOOLBOX.
THERE ARE OVER A HUNDRED AND
FIFTY DIFFERENT TYPES OF RENDON
ASIDES THAT AREN'T COVERED UNDER
THE SPELL OF SECOND GENERATION
AND ITS.
SECOND GENERATION AND ACQUIRED
OR ASIDES THAT ARE AVAILABLE FOR
USE IN CALIFORNIA TODAY WON'T BE
AFFECTED BY THIS BILL THIS BILL
IS NARROWLY TARGETED ON THE MOST
TOXIC READINESS SIDES.
AND HAS CLEAN EXEMPTIONS FOR
PUBLIC HEALTH -- PROTECTING THE
ENVIRONMENT AND CALIFORNIA'S
AGRICULTURAL ECONOMY.
SECOND GENERATION AND I IF YOU
COULD JUST SUMMARIZE CERTAINLY I
WILL JUST AGAIN PUT FORWARD THE
NUMBERS FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT ASIDE REGULATION
WHILE THE SECOND GENERATION
ANTICOAGULANTS.
ARE ONLY THE SMALLEST PERCENTAGE
OF YOU SUPPORT ON THE SIDES THEY
HAVE THE GREATEST HARM NON ANTI
COAGULANT ACUTE TALKS AGAINST.
REPRESENTS.
DRAMATICALLY MORE USAGE BUT ARE
GETTING INTO THE SYSTEM THEIR
OTHER TOLD UNTIL BOX THAT WON'T
BE AFFECTED BY THIS BILL I
GRITTED POSSIBLE TODAY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT OUR OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M LISA OWNS
VIANI WITH RAPTORS ARE THE
SOLUTION WE HAVE A STRONG.
FIFTEEN COALITIONS IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL THANK YOU.
HELLO KILLER ROBINSON HERE ON
BEHALF OF THE MEN PENINSULA
REGIONAL OPEN SPACE DISTRICT AND
FRIENDS OF THE LA RIVER HERE IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
I'M JANET COVERS AND I'M HERE
REPRESENTING RATS AND ALSO THE
PROJECT KATIE AND STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HELLO I'M SUSAN LITTLE WITH THE
ENVIRONMENTAL WORKING GROUP IN
STRONG SUPPORT [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
NICHOLAS SACKETT SOCIAL
COMPASSION LEGISLATION IN
SUPPORT.
MORE COMMON BATHS EREKLE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON ERIN HOW THE ON
BEHALF OF PROJECT PRIORITY IN
SUPPORT WILDLIFE SHOULD BE
RODENTICIDE FREE THANK YOU THANK
YOU.
DR PETRA MARCIA NORTH A
CALIFORNIA VETERINARIAN IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
FANA TOMLINSON PROJECT KOTV IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT UP OPPOSITION -- LET'S
SEE WE'VE GOT.
HOW MANY DO WE HAVE THAT WE HAVE
TO ALL RIGHT YOU -- YOU MAY ALL.
OF THREE WILL STILL HAVE PLENTY
OF CHAIRS IF YOU WANT TO COME UP
AND IF YOU WANT TO SPEAK.
MORE THAN JUST -- YOUR NAME AND
IF YOU WANNA.
MAKE A COMMENT YOU HAVE FOUR
MINUTES TOTAL BETWEEN THE THREE
OF YOU.
SO.
WHO WOULD LIKE TO START?
IF I MAKE GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SPEAK WITH YOU TODAY MY NAME IS
JAMES STATE.
AND I OWN A LOCAL PEST CONTROL
COMPANY HERE IN THE SACRAMENTO
AREA.
AND WE EMPLOY ABOUT THIRTY
PEOPLE AND HAVE ABOUT FIVE
THOUSAND CUSTOMERS.
I ALSO COME TO YOU TODAY AS THE
PRESIDENT OF THE PEST CONTROL
OPERATORS OF CALIFORNIA.
WE REPRESENT A THOUSAND
COMPANIES WHO EMPLOY OVER TEN
THOUSAND TECHNICIANS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE.
AND IN SHORT WHEN YOU HAVE RATS
WHERE THE PEOPLE THAT YOU CALL.
WHETHER IT'S HERE IN YOUR HOMES
BUSINESSES EVEN IN THE STATE
CAPITAL.
WE COME HERE TODAY ACTUALLY IN
SUPPORT OF THE INTENT OF THE
BILL WE BELIEVE THAT THE PROBLEM
WITH WILDLIFE.
IS. FOR REAL AND SERIOUS WE ONLY
HAVE ISSUE WITH THE PROPOSED --
STRATEGY FOR ADDRESSING THAT.
THE BACKBONE OF OUR STRATEGY IS
TO CONTROL RODENTS WITH AYE PM
WE START WITH EXCLUSION.
WITH HABITAT MODIFICATION.
AND MAKING SURE THAT SANITATION
IS PROPERLY MANAGED SO THAT WE
DON'T ATTRACT RODENTS TO OUR
HOMES AND SCHOOLS AND HOSPITALS.
WE USE OUR EMPLOY RODENTICIDE
ONLY WHERE NECESSARY IN FACT.
IT'S AXIOMATIC THE LESS
RODENTICIDE SO THAT WE USE THE
MORE MONEY WE MAKE SO WE DON'T
LIKE.
TO EMPLOY THEM UNLESS WE
ABSOLUTELY NEED.
TO THE STEWARDSHIP OVER IT AND
SIDES IS VERY IMPORTANT TO OUR
INDUSTRY.
IN FACT IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN P.
C. O. C. LAUNCHED THE WEST COAST
ROAD AND ACADEMY IN DIRECT
RESPONSE TO THE PROBLEM OF
RODENTICIDE IN WILDLIFE.
THIS IS A THREE DAY ACADEMY
WHERE WE BRING IN TECHNICIANS.
AND TRAINERS.
AND WE TRAIN THEM.
TO APPROACH.
RODENT PROBLEMS WITH IBM.
AND IT'S A ACADEMY THAT
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT I'M
SORRY YES THAT'S A GREAT IDEA.
SO THIS IS YOU HAVE TEN SECONDS.
SORRY WELL I I WOULD JUST LIKE
IT'S SO IT JUST FLIES RIGHT I
HAD IT DOES.
SO.
WE ARE VERY ENCOURAGED THAT THE
P. R. HAS OPENED THE
REEVALUATION HOWEVER THIS ISSUE
IS DIRECTLY CONNECTED TO PUBLIC
HEALTH.
AND WE'RE VERY CONCERNED THAT
WHATEVER SOLUTIONS WE EMPLOY
PUBLIC HEALTH MUST BE CONSIDERED
IN FACT.
EVEN NOW WE HAVE ISSUES A PUBLIC
HEALTH THAT HAVE EMERGED LAST
YEAR YEAH I GOT TO GIVE SOME
TIME TO THE OTHER WITNESSES
HELLO YOU CAN THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS JOSH
BENSINGER ON THE PLASTER COUNTY
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONER ON
BEHALF OF HERE ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONERS AND SEALERS
ASSOCIATION.
WE'VE ALSO RECOGNIZE THE
IMPORTANCE OF PROTECTING
WILDLIFE AND NOW WE WE AS
AGRICULTURAL COMMISSIONERS IN --
ENACT DEEP YARDS PESTICIDE
REGULATIONS ON THE GROUND IN
EACH OF OUR FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
RESPECTIVELY WE ALSO GET THE
REPORTS FROM THE APARTMENT FISH
AND WILDLIFE WHEN PESTICIDE
POISONINGS OCCURRED WHERE WERE
AWARE OF WHAT A SERIOUS ISSUE
THAT IS.
WE CURRENTLY HAVE AN OPPOSE
POSITION ON THIS BILL DUE TO THE
WAY IN WHICH THE AGRICULTURAL
COMMISSIONER IS TASKED WITH THE
ROLE THAT IS NOT CONSISTENT.
WITH OUR CURRENT -- REGULATORY
REQUIREMENTS AND THE WAY THAT WE
IMPLEMENT A PESTICIDE USE
ENFORCEMENT PUTS US IN MORE OF A
DECISION MAKING ROLL OVER THE
USE OF PESTICIDES RATHER THAN IN
A ROLE IN WHICH WE ARE
EVALUATING AND REGULATING THE
SAFE AND LEGAL USE OF THOSE
PESTICIDES.
THANK YOU OUR NEXT WITNESS MY
NAME'S DARREN VAN STEENWIJK I AM
ALSO A LOCAL OPERATOR.
IN THIS ACKERMAN AREA -- ONE OF
THE ENCOURAGING THINGS THAT THE
DVR HAS DONE IS THAT THEY'VE
ALREADY REACHED OUT TO US WITH A
TO START THE CONVERSATION ON
WHAT THEY CALL AN ARM PERMIT
CONDITIONS WHICH ARE.
A CENTURY ESSENTIALLY A
TEMPORARY MEDICATION -- THAT
WOULD BE ENACTED WHILE THE A RE
EVALUATION IS CURRENTLY
HAPPENING -- THE DPR HAS A HAS A
WIDE VARIETY OF QUESTIONS --
THAT THEY'RE LOOKING TO ANSWER
ME P. ARTISTS ARE DEPARTMENT
PASSED AT REGULATION AT ALL I
APOLOGIZE -- THAT DAY I THAT
THEY'RE LOOKING TO ANSWER AS
PART OF THEIR REVALUATION -- ONE
OF THE BIG QUESTIONS THAT'S OUT
THERE IS THE IDEA OF THE
SPECIFIC PATHWAY OF OF THESE --
ACTIVES FROM A A FROM POINT A
INTO THE INTO THE WILDLIFE
BECAUSE TO THE DEPARTMENT PASSED
AT REGULATION -- IT DOESN'T HAVE
ENOUGH DATA TO DETERMINE EXACTLY
WHERE THAT POINT A IS AND WHERE
IT STARTING -- AND SO THERE --
THEY OF LOOKED AT THE WHITE A
WIDE VARIETY OF DATA GAPS --
THAT THEY WANT -- TO FILL IN AS
AS PART OF THEIR RE EVALUATION --
AND WILL BE -- WILL BE WORKING
VERY DILIGENTLY TO TO FILL IN
THE DATA GAPS TO CREATE THE MOST
APPROPRIATE -- AND COMPREHENSIVE
OF MEDICATION -- THAT THEY FEEL
IS NECESSARY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH -- OTHERS IN
OPPOSITION.
LOCAL COMMUNITY ON BEHALF OF THE
HOUSEHOLD AND COMMERCIAL
pAGREE RELY LIKE TO ALLOW THE
REEVALUATION PROCESS TO PLAY OUT
THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE LARA KNOWING HE CHECK
ON BEHALF OF RISE IN WESTERN
PLAN HEALTH ASSOCIATION IN
OPPOSITION SIMILAR TO THE DPR
SHE'LL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
DON KEPT YOUR BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION SEEMS
HERE AGREES WITH COMMENTS BEING
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ELEONORA CALIFORNIA CHAMBER OF
COMMERCE WE STILLER POSE BUT
APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS THAT
MR MISTAKEN.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
CAPULETS REPRESENTING ANIMAL
PEST MANAGEMENT SERVICES IN
OPPOSITION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS.
AS THE MEMBER SHRINK AWAY WE CAN.
RIGHT GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR -- MISTER
A BLOOM BY -- APPRECIATE WE TRY
TO DO BECAUSE YEAH I'VE BEEN
TRYING.
TO BASSAM PESTICIDES IN OTHER --
CONTEXTS ALSO BUT COME.
COULD YOU JUST ADDRESS THE THE
THE ISSUE.
THIS IS A COMMON ARGUMENT THAT I
GET FACED WITH ONE IN MY EFFORTS
YOU KNOW.
WHY WE SHOULD PROCEED WHEN THEY
DEPARTMENT A PASS FOR PESTICIDE
REGULATION IS?
IS A JUST ANNOUNCED THAT THEY'RE
GOING TO ENTER INTO A
REEVALUATION.
THAT PROCESS IS LIKELY TO TAKE A
NUMBER OF YEARS WE HAVE A
PROBLEM -- THAT IS GROWING FROM
THE THE USE OF OF THESE ANTI
COAGULANT AND WE NEED TO ACT NOW
AND WE CAN CERTAINLY -- LOOK AT
THE A INFORMATION AND
DETERMINATION OF DPR WHEN THAT
IS AVAILABLE BUT IT'S REALLY A
AT AN UNCERTAIN AND UNCERTAIN
TIME RIGHT NOW.
SO SO IN OTHER WORDS WHILE WE
OFTEN HEAR THAT WE SHOULD.
TO LET THE SCIENCE -- PREVAIL --
SOMETIMES WE CAN'T WAIT FOR THE
SCIENCE.
OR AT LEAST WHAT I WERE.
WE'RE ACTING ON SCIENCE NOW --
THIS IS A VERY MUCH A SCIENCE
BASED BILL -- IN FACT WE HAVE
BEEN WORKING ON THIS I'VE BEEN
WORKING ON THIS ISSUE. FOR THREE
YEARS FOUR YEARS NOW WE HAVE
FOUR FINGERS -- FROM MY CHIEF OF
STAFF -- I'VE BEEN WORKING ON
THIS ISSUE FOR FOUR YEARS.
AND ALL OF OUR EFFORTS HAVE BEEN
BASED ON A SCIENTIFIC REPORTS
FROM THE CROPS THESE -- AND FROM
A VERY CAREFUL EVALUATION OF
WHAT TO THE CAUSE OF BEEN AND
DURING THAT PERIOD OF TIME --
WE'VE DEALT WITH A FIRST
GENERATION AND AND AND NOW
SEEKING.
TO WORK ON SECOND GENERATION
ANTICOAGULANTS -- BUT THE ISSUE
AND THE PROBLEM WAS CONTINUED TO
FESTER AND GROW.
ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
VERY MUCH.
OF MADAM VICE CHAIR.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OKAY
SO I'VE GOT A COUPLE OF
QUESTIONS FOR YOU YOU GUYS --
YOU SAID THAT YOU YOUR ISSUES
WITH THE STRATEGY.
WHAT DID I HEAR THAT CORRECTLY?
THE YEAH JUST THAT'S CORRECT SO
THE BILL AS IT'S WRITTEN
REQUIRES TO AGENCIES TO SIGN OFF
BEFORE -- THESE RED INSIDES ARE
EMPLOYED IN CERTAIN CONDITIONS.
AND THAT'S THE THE COUNTY
COMMISSIONERS AND ALSO THE
PUBLIC HEALTH AGENCY.
AND SO OUR CONCERN IS THAT
NEITHER OF THESE AGENCIES.
ARE -- THEY DON'T HAVE THE
LANGUAGE THAT THEY NEED TO MAKE
THE DETERMINATION.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE STAFF THEY
NEED TO MEET THE VOLUME BECAUSE
THEY'RE COULD LITERALLY BE
HUNDREDS OF CALLS PER DAY AT
LEAST PER WEEK.
AND THEY DON'T HAVE THE FUNDING
FOR THE STAFF THAT WOULD THEY
WOULD NEED FOR THE INCREASE OF
THIS AND THAT'S WHY I SUSPECT
THAT THE THAT THE AG
COMMISSIONERS ARE HERE WITH US
AT THE TABLE SO -- THE THE OTHER
ISSUE WE HAVE WITH THIS
PARTICULAR STRATEGY IS IT'S FULL
OF EXEMPTIONS FOR AGRICULTURE
AND AREAS.
AND WE FEEL LIKE THE
REEVALUATION COULD -- ENACT
SOLUTIONS IN THE FIRST SIX TO
TWELVE MONTHS WITH THE
INTERMEDIATION.
THAT WOULD NOT HAVE THESE
RESTRICTIONS I THINK WE'LL HAVE
BETTER SOLUTIONS COMING OUT OF
THE P. R..
THANK YOU I'M.
THESE ANTI COAGULANT ARE THESE --
CAN THIS ONLY BE -- BOUGHT
COMMERCIALLY.
CAN THE AVERAGE CALIFORNIAN GO
BUY IT.
AT THIS POINT AND THE ANSWER IS
NO.
NO THE NOW I KNOW ONE OF THE
THINGS WE HAVE WORKED WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF PESTICIDE
REGULATION ON IS -- IS ONLINE
INTERNET SALES -- BECAUSE THEY
RECOGNIZE THAT THAT IS SOMETHING
THAT IS -- THAT'S AN UNREGULATED
SECTION OF COMMERCE THAT THEY
THAT THEY ARE TRYING TO GET
THEIR HANDS ON OKAY SO.
SO OVER THE COUNTER NO BUT YOU
CAN STILL RELATIVELY EASILY GET
A GENERALLY OPERATORS ARE THE
ONLY ONES WHO HAVE ACCESS. TO
THIS TYPE OF CORRECT SOLUTION
CORRECT AND IF I CAN ADD TO THAT
PLEASE FOR ME I HAVE -- ONE OF
THE AGAIN TO SERVE TO SUPPORT
WHAT JIM WAS SAYING THAT WE THAT
WE DON'T DISAGREE AGAIN WITH THE
PREMISE OF THE BILL WE JUST FEEL
THAT.
THAT -- THAT THE DEPARTMENT
PESTERED REGULATION NO HAS A
PROCESS SPECIFICALLY TO YOU KNOW
TO ADDRESS AND COME FORTH WITH
WITH AN APPROPRIATE SET OF
MITIGATION THAT -- THAT WE THAT
WE CAN -- ARE THAT WE CAN ALL.
AGREE UPON.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM.
A VICE CHAIR AND ANYONE ELSE.
OKAY DO WE HAVE A MOTION.
OKAY COULD I GET A MOTION
[inaudible]
GREAT.
ALL RIGHT.
THERE'S NOTHING MORE YOU MAY
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
WAITING IS REALLY NOT -- THE
BEST OPTION HERE WE KNOW THAT
THIS PROBLEM EXISTS IT IS
EXISTED FOR SEVERAL YEARS IT'S
GOTTEN WORSE -- HOW WE CAN
ALWAYS ADJUST LATER ON AND AND
MISTER CHAIR YOU KNOW YOU THAT --
ABOVE -- YOU AND THE ADVOCATES --
ON THIS BILL I HAVE THE OF MY
THE AGREEMENT TO CONTINUE TO
WORK GOING FORWARD ON THE ON THE
LANGUAGE.
AND PERHAPS WE CAN GET TO A
PLACE WERE -- ALL AGREEABLE.
IT WOULD BE GREAT
.
ALL RIGHT.
HIGHER TO THE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND EIGHT FOUR YEARS IS TOO
LONG TO WAIT -- THIS IS CLEARLY.
AN ISSUE RIGHT NOW WE NEED TO DO
SOMETHING RIGHT NOW I REGION I
VOTE
-- A MEMBER HERE IS MISSED
IF YOU VOTES -- WHY DON'T WE
CALL THE PREVIOUS TWO ITEMS
AGAIN AND GET THE ABSENT MEMBER
ITEM ONE WHICH IS AB TWO
SEVENTEEN AND ONE OF THE WORKERS
SEE ON THE VOTE IS AT? FOUR TWO
BAUER-KAHAN.
DALY CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA
GARCIA HI SELECT A COLOR.
TWO FIVE TWO SHE PASSES OUT YEAH
THAT BILL IS NOW OUT.
WE DIDN'T SPEND THAT SEVENTY
FIVE MINUTES IN VAIN.
WE HAVE ITEM NUMBER TWO AS WELL
HERE -- IT'S AB. ONE THIRTY FOUR
BLOOM.
ON THE VOTE IS AT FOUR ZERO
BAUER-KAHAN.
DALLY CRISTINA GARCIA.
CRISTINA GARCIA AYE THAT TAKES A
VOTE.
TO FIVE ZERO THAT ALSO PASSED
ALRIGHT SO THE ONLY ONE I SEE
HERE TO PRESENT RIGHT NOW
[inaudible]
IS [inaudible]
I ASSEMBLY MEMBER ELOISE RAMOS
PLEASE COME UP [inaudible]
A GOOD.
IT'S BEEN A LONG DAY ALREADY.
IS SHE ALRIGHT BELL IS MOVED IS
THERE A SECOND [inaudible]
DID WE SO YOU MOVED IT RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT I'LL SECOND.
WE HAVE PEOPLE ASSEMBLY DIGAS.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
AND MEMBERS OF THIS FIND
COMMITTEE TODAY I PRESENT TO YOU
AB ELEVEN TWENTY THREE WHICH
ENSURES THAT THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL AND HIS OFFICE RECEIVED
NOTICE.
OF PROP SIXTY FIVE APPEALS.
PROP SIXTY FIVE THE SAFE
DRINKING WATER TOXIC ENFORCEMENT
ACT OF NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX
REQUIRES THAT THE BUSINESS THAT
EXPOSES CONSUMERS TO CHEMICALS
LISTED AS CARCINOGENS OR
REPRODUCTIVE TOXICANTS MUST
FIRST PROVIDE CLEAR AND
REASONABLE WARNING.
LEAVE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
FORCES PROP SIXTY FIVE TO REDUCE
THE PUBLIC'S EXPOSURE TO TOXIC
CHEMICALS IN FOOD NUTRITIONAL
SUPPLEMENTS INFANT FORMULA
FURNITURE AND A HOST OF OTHER
CONSUMER GOODS AND PRODUCTS.
IN ACCORDANCE WITH PROP SIXTY
FIVE PRIVATE CITIZENS CAN
ENFORCE THE STATUTE IN THE PRIDE
IN THE PUBLIC INTEREST.
CITIZENS MUST SEND A NOTICE TO
AN ALLEGED VIOLATOR AND TO THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL ADVISING OF THE
ALLEGED VIOLATION.
PRIVATE.
ENFORCERS MUST ALSO REPORT TO
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S OFFICE
WHEN THEY FILE A COMPLAINT OR
SETTLEMENT.
THESE REQUIREMENTS ALLOW THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL TO EVALUATE
CLAIMS AND ENSURE THAT PRIVATE
ENFORCERS CLAIMS HAVE MERIT.
AND THAT PRIVATE LAWSUITS AND
SETTLEMENTS ARE IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE PUBLIC.
HOWEVER THERE ARE NO
REQUIREMENTS THE PRIVATE
ENFORCES YOUR DEFENSE SUPPORT
ANY OTHER PROP SIXTY FIVE
ACTIVITIES TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL INCLUDING ONE AN APPEAL
IS FILED.
AS A RESULT THE DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE MAY BE UNAWARE OF
PENDING APPEALS AND THE COURT OF
APPEALS.
OUR FREQUENTLY ASKED TO OPINE ON
THE LAW WITHOUT THE BENEFIT OF
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S INPUT
RISKING A DECISION THAT WILL SET
PRECEDENTS.
AND DAMAGING TO THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL'S AUTHORITY TO ENFORCE
THE LAW.
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL IS MARIO THE BUT NOT
ONLY WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MARIO
DIBERNARDO HERE ON BEHALF OF
ATTORNEY GENERAL.
SERRA WHO'S PROUD TO SPONSOR
THIS PIECE OF LEGISLATION -- THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MENTIONED.
BASICALLY MOST OF THE POINTS I
WAS GOING TO REYES. ONE THING I
WOULD LIKE TO ADD IS THAT NGUYEN
IS SO IT'S A VERY SIMPLE BILL
RIGHT IT'S IF A IF A LITIGANT IS
APPEALING A PROP SIXTY FIVE CASE
ALL THEY HAVE TO DO IS SEND
NOTICE TO THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S
OFFICE THAT THEY'RE DOING SO.
NOTHING MORE NOTHING LESS
PROPOSITION SIXTY FIVE ALREADY
HAS LOTS OF PROVISIONS REGARDING
NOTICE OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
DURING THE TRIAL PHASES OF THE
THE CASES.
THIS IS RELATED TO THE PALETTE
CASE -- IF A CASE GOES SIDEWAYS
EITHER WAY IN THE APPELLATE
COURT AND THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
WAS NOT AWARE OF THE CASE WE
HAVE TO THAN PETITION -- FOR
DEEP PUBLICATION TO AVOID A A
HARMFUL PRESIDENTIAL DECISION
AND THIS IS HAPPENED RECENTLY
TWICE.
AND WE WANT TO AVOID HAVING TO
GO THROUGH THAT BY REQUIRING
THIS NOTICE DURING THE APPELLATE
STAGE.
SO THAT WE HAVE THESE CASES ON
OUR RADAR AND WE CAN INFORM THE
CORE WHEN IT'S APPROPRIATE.
THERE ARE SEVERAL OTHER AREAS OF
THE LAW THAT PROVIDE SIMILAR
REQUIREMENTS ON LITIGANTS
INCLUDING IN THE CALIFORNIA
DISABILITY LAWS THE UNFAIR
COMPETITION LAWS SEEK WAS AND
THE FALSE CLAIMS ACT.
SO -- WITH THAT I'D LIKE TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR ABOUT THANK
YOU.
ALL RIGHT.
OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
ANY IN OPPOSITION [inaudible]
MEMBERS QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT ARM NO QUESTIONS DâN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER YOU MAY CLOSE.
AB ELEVEN TWENTY THREE OFFERS A
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
ATTORNEY GENERAL AN OPPORTUNITY
TO PARTICIPATE IN LITIGATION
ESPECIALLY THE PILLS PROCESS
THIS IS EXTREMELY IMPORTANT TO
AVOID ANY OF THE HOUSE ARTS THAT
WE HAVE DISCUSSED.
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT -- HE SAID IT'S A
SIMPLE BELL.
GOOD TO LET THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
NOW WHAT'S GOING ON OUR REGION I
VOTE -- MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB
ELEVEN TWENTY THREE A. S..
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AND RE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY.
QUIRK.
AYE QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ
[inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
BLOOM I BAUER-KAHAN.
BAUER-KAHAN HI DALY.
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I HOLDEN [inaudible]
MATHIS.
THE SNOW WHAT A TO G..
WITH A TO G. ICE. FIVE TO ONE
YOU'RE OUT.
BEST OF LUCK THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRIEDMAN.
THE BILL.
SECOND.
THANK YOU THAT'S A VERY GOOD
SIGN.
WE ARE ACCEPTING THE A WE ARE
ACCEPTING ALL THE SUGGEST A
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS -- TO
ENSURE THAT THE DEADLINE IMPOSED
BY THIS BILL IS MANDATORY ONLY
THE LEGISLATURE HAS APPROPRIATED
SUFFICIENT FUNDS.
I AB ELEVEN EIGHTY REQUIRES A
CALIFORNIA STATE WATER RESOURCES
CONTROL BOARD TO UPDATE
REGULATIONS FOR NON POTABLE
RECYCLED WATER FOUND IN TITLE
TWENTY TWO BY.
TWENTY TWENTY THREE THESE
REGULATIONS HAVE NOT BEEN
UPDATED IN NINETEEN YEARS WE
HAVE A VAST NETWORK OF RECYCLED
WATER INFRASTRUCTURE BUT WE'RE
NOT ABLE.
TO REALLY UTILIZE ITS EFFICACY
BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF UPDATING
OF THE REGULATIONS AND WE'VE
HEARD THIS FROM MANY EVER
AGENCIES WITH THAT -- I URGENT I
VOTE TO END I HAVE THAT THE LAW
ALSO HERE REPRESENTING WATER
REDUCE.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS BETH --
ALSO WITH WATER REDUCE
CALIFORNIA APPRECIATE THE WORK
YOU'RE STAFF PUT IN ON THIS --
AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS [inaudible]
WONDERFUL -- OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
VERY BRIEFLY MISTER CHAIR CASE
THAT I HAPPEN TO CALIFORNIA'S
FOR THE POLICE CHASE AND ALSO IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
VERY GOOD [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
FASTEST BILL YET ANY QUESTIONS.
ALL RIGHT YOU MAY CLOSE.
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE
VERY GOOD.
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL -- IN WHAT IS THE MOTION IT
IS TO PASS.
TO AS AMENDED. TO APPROPRIATIONS
THANK YOU.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER NINE AB
ELEVEN EIGHTY FRIEDMAN.
THE MOTION IS DO PASSES AMENDED
AND RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK AYE QUIRK
AYE MELENDEZ.
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BAUER-KAHAN
BAUER-KAHAN HI DALLY.
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I HOLDEN.
MATHIS.
MATHIS SIDE WHAT A TO G..
RED TO GI. SIX CONGRATULATIONS
YOUR OUT [inaudible]
MEMBERS -- NOW I HOPE WE CAN GET
ANOTHER ONE PAIR.
YES -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER TANK
PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR.
AB EIGHT FOUR ONE WOULD REQUIRE
THE OFFICE OF ENVIRONMENTAL
HEALTH HAZARD ASSESSMENT WILL TO
ADOPT A WORK PLAN VERY GOOD SIGN
THIS IS WITHIN THE CLASS OF P.
FAST CHEMICALS.
SHOULD BE ASSESSED AT THE RISK
TO HUMAN HEALTH AND WHETHER OR
NOT NOTIFICATION OF US TO BE A
DOCTOR.
SOME CONCERNS HAVE BEEN RAISED
BY ENVIRONMENTAL ORGANIZATIONS
WILL CONTINUE OUR DISCUSSIONS
WITH STAKEHOLDERS.
AND WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT TO
LEAVE GET THEIR CONCERNS WITHOUT
OUR RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
THOUGHT.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHERS IN SUPPORT. FOR
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THEIR CODE
CALIFORNIANS SUPPORT.
SUPPORT OR IN BETWEEN
[inaudible]
OR OPPOSITION [inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OF ANY QUESTIONS.
LOOKS LIKE ANOTHER SUCCESSFUL
HERE.
WE DESERVE THIS AFTER SEVENTY
FIVE MINUTES ON THE FIRST WHEN
WATCHING ONTO HER SIDE AND WE
HAVE EVER BUT IT WAS WORTH IT.
ALL RIGHT -- WHAT IS THE MOTION?
IT'S TO PASS TO APPROPRIATIONS
DO I HAVE A LET'S SEE IT'S BEEN
MOVED AND SECONDED.
SO MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM NUMBER SIX AB EIGHT
FORTY ONE TANK.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AND
REFERRED TO THE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS QUIRK.
AYE QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ
[inaudible]
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BAUER-KAHAN.
OUR CAN I DALY.
CRISTINA GARCIA MS IN ASCII
HOLDEN.
MATHIS MATHIS I WANTED TO CHANGE
WHEN I TO GI. SIX ZERO THE TOP
GRADUATION DROUGHT [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT -- YES ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CARILLO IS NOT HERE [inaudible]
YES -- I KNOW BUT CAN WE GET.
SHE'S ON HER WAY LET ME JUST OUR
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ON THE
UNRESOLVED BILL THAT WE STILL
HAVE.
WE HAVE ONE BELT THAT'S ITEM FOR
I THINK -- WELL IT WAS THE
SECOND BLOOM DOWN WE STILL
HAVEN'T RESOLVED THAT ONE YET
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
OKAY.
THIS IS ITEM THIRTEEN AB
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT BLOOM THE
VOTE STANDS AT FOUR TWO WITH THE
CHAIR RECOMMENDING AND I
BAUER-KAHAN.
BAUER-KAHAN HI.
DALY [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
SO THAT BRINGS THE VOTE TO FIVE
OKAY THAT BILL IS OUT.
ALL RIGHT [inaudible]
MR MATHIS.
I BET THIS ONE HAS SUPPORT
SUPPORT [inaudible]
THE BILL.
DO I HAVE A SECOND.
YEAH WHAT BILL IS THIS.
THIS IS A GREAT THIS IS A MAP
THIS BILL MISTER CHAIRMAN WHY
DON'T YOU SECOND IT SO WE CAN
WILL HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND
WILL YOU SECOND YOUR BILL ON IT
WAS CHAIR MEMBERS NOW YOU OUT.
ASSEMBLY BILL -- TWO SEVENTY
FOUR WHICH WERE GOING TO BRING
CLEAN WATER TO THE CITY OF
PORTABLE KNOWN AS THE CITY
WITHOUT WATER WITH ME TODAY IS.
CHAIRMAN NAIL PERONE FROM THE TO
THE RIVER TRIED TO EXPLAIN MORE
MR.
THANK YOU THE HONORABLE CHAIRMAN
AND COMMITTEE MEMBER SENT FOR
GIVE ME THE OPPORTUNITY COME
BEFORE YOU AND ON BEHALF OF MY
ONE THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY SIX MEMBERS.
I REALLY DO APPRECIATE THIS TIME.
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND HE'S
PORTABLE MORE RECENTLY MADE
NATIONAL NEWS BY RUNNING OUT OF
WATER.
OUR TRIBE AS A WATER EVERY YEAR.
YET WE CAN'T MAKE THE LOCAL
PAPER.
AND AS PART OF OUR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT WE DO RUN A CANNING
FACILITY WE ARE IN THE PROCESS
OF MOVING THAT GAMING FACILITY
THE TRIBE CURRENTLY EMPLOYS A
LITTLE OVER.
A THOUSAND EMPLOYEES.
AND INTO SOME PROPERTY THAT WE
ON A PORTABLE PART OF THAT
PROJECT IS A TERTIARY TREATMENT
PLAN. FOR WITH FOR WATER SO THAT
OUR PROJECT HAS NO IMPACT ON
PORTABLES POSSIBLE WATER.
BUT WITHOUT OPPORTUNITY IN PLACE
THE FUNDING THAT WE MAY BE ABLE
TO ACQUIRE.
WITH THIS BILL CAN.
EXPAND THAT.
TO REALLY HELP THE CITY OF
PORTABLE.
WE TRY TO BE THE GOOD NEIGHBOR
AS THE TRIBE YOU KNOW THE TRIBE
HAS OVER THIRTY DEPARTMENTS OF
ITS OWN ITS OWN POLICE ITS OWN
FIRE ITS OWN SCHOOL -- BUT A LOT
OF OUR CHILDREN GO TO SCHOOL IN
PORTABLE -- ALL OF OUR HIGH
SCHOOL KIDS GO TO THERE.
AND WE HAVE A BIG ISSUE WITH
WATER OUR CURRENT PLAN ON THE
RESERVATION PRODUCES ABOUT FOUR
HUNDRED THOUSAND GALLONS A DAY
AND WE PROBABLY IS ABOUT THAT.
AND SOMETIMES IN OUR LOW WATER
PERIODS THE WATERS THE COLOR OF
THIS.
TABLE HERE IN FRONT OF ME --
THAT WE ARE FORCED TO DRINK TO
TRY PROVIDES.
OTHER SOURCES OF WATER FOR YOU
KNOW THOSE THAT THAT NEEDED OF
THAT RUN OUT.
AND I THINK THAT MOVING FORWARD
AND IF THIS IS SUCCESSFUL THAT
WE CAN REALLY [inaudible]
STOP.
WHAT WE'VE BEEN LIVING WITH
SINCE WE'RE PLACE THERE BACK IN --
EIGHTEEN SEVENTY THREE WE'VE
ALWAYS TRIED TO BE A GOOD
NEIGHBOR.
WE ALWAYS APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT
THE CITY'S ALWAYS BEEN GREAT
WITH US THE COUNTY.
AND WE WOULD REALLY LIKE YOUR
SUPPORT.
ON THIS BILL SO THAT WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD AND PROVIDE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO PROVIDE A YOU HEARD A
BILL EARLIER REGARDING QUALITY
WATER FOR EVERYONE.
AND THAT'S KIND OF WHAT WE WE
WOULD LIKE ABSOLUTELY TO BE
INCLUDED.
I'M NOW I DO WANT TO POINT OUT --
BEFORE WE GET ANY MORE QUESTIONS
THAT.
WE'RE GONNA.
LOOK AT THIS BELL AS SOMETHING
THAT THAT HELPS PEOPLE DRINK
WATER.
APPROPRIATIONS WILL OF COURSE BE
LOOKING AT THIS IN DECIDING --
ON THE APPROPRIATENESS OF
PUTTING THIS IN THE BUDGET
ABSOLUTELY AND WE WILL END BUT I
DON'T YOU KNOW SO IT'S PRETTY
CLEAR WHAT ARE JURISDICTION IS
AND WHAT THE ISSUE IS HERE.
DO I HAVE OTHERS WHO WERE IN
SUPPORT.
ANY IN OPPOSITION [inaudible]
ANY QUESTIONS [inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
ANOTHER QUICK BELL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH EVERYONE --
SO THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS -- TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT THAT APPROPRIATIONS.
AS AMENDED.
DO PASS AS AMENDED TO LOCAL
GOVERNMENT IT'S GREAT.
AND I STILL DON'T HAVE A SECOND.
WHO'S THE SECOND WHO WANTS TO
SECOND THIS ALL RIGHT BY OUR
COMMON -- SO MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
I THIS IS ITEM NUMBER THREE AB
TWO SEVENTY FOUR MATHIS THE
MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED AND
RE REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I BAUER-KAHAN BAUER-KAHAN
I DALY.
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
HOLDEN.
MATHIS AYE MATHIS AYE YOUR WHAT
CITY.
WHAT CITY?
SAID SIX VOTES AT THAT -- SIX
ALL RIGHT EXCELLENT.
ALL RIGHT.
MORE PROGRESS IS MADE.
OUR NEXT IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CORREA'S VAL AND CONGRATULATIONS --
TO THE CHIEF AS WELL AS MR
MATHIS
.
YOU MAKE PROCEED WHEN READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M HERE 2% ASSEMBLY
BILL.
FIFTEEN HUNDRED WHICH WOULD AND
BOLD AND LOCAL AUTHORITIES TO
TAKE IMMEDIATE ACTION AGAINST
LOCAL THREATS TO OUR PUBLIC
HEALTH AND SAFETY.
IN CAIFORNIA MULTIPLE
REGULATORY AUTHORITIES HAVE
JURISDICTION OVER BUSINESSES
THAT HANDLE OR GENERATE
HAZARDOUS HAZARDOUS WASTE A
MATERIAL THAT POSE A RISK TO
PUBLIC SAFETY.
AND HEALTH THIS INCLUDES FOR
EXAMPLE THE SOUTH COAST AIR
QUALITY MANAGEMENT DISTRICT AND
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
TOOK A TOXIC SUBSTANCE CONTROL.
LOCALLY A CERTIFIED PROGRAM
AGENCY IS RESPONSIBLE FOR
IMPLEMENTING AND ENFORCING
HAZARDOUS MATERIALS AND WASTE
LAWS AND THE LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICER HAS GENERAL THIRTY TO
PROTECT THE PUBLIC'S HEALTH AND
EXPAND ORTIZ BIG THIRTY IN CASES
OF DECLARED.
EMERGENCY.
CURRENTLY SOME FACILITIES THAT
EMIT HAZARDOUS SUBSTANCE
CONTINUE TO OPERATE BECAUSE THEY
DO NOT MEET.
THE REGULATORY MINIMUM STANDARDS
TO CEASE OPERATIONS IMMEDIATELY.
A PRIME EXAMPLE OF THIS TYPE OF
ATROCITY IMPACTING OUR
COMMUNITIES.
BEING THE EXIDE BATTERY
RECYCLING FACILITY IN VERNON
CALIFORNIA THE EXITE PLANT
CONTINUOUSLY EXPOSED FAMILIES
AND RESIDENTS OF MY DISTRICT.
AS WELL AS THE DISTRICTS OF
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO GARCIA
CRISTINA GARCIA AND SPEAKER
RENDON -- COMBINED WE REPRESENT
APPROXIMATELY TWO MILLION PEOPLE.
THE COMMUNITIES WERE EXPOSED TO
DANGEROUS LEVELS OF TOXIC LEAD.
UNTIL THE FACILITY WAS FINALLY
SHUT DOWN IN.
TWENTY FIFTEEN IT PAINS ME TO
SHARE THAT PRIOR TO EXCITE.
PRIOR TO THE X. I. PLAN BEING
SHUT DOWN THE BATTERY RECYCLING
FACILITY DEPOSITED HIGHLY
DAMAGING LEVELS OF LEAD INTO OUR
FAMILY'S HOMES.
WALKWAYS AND YARDS FROM NINETEEN
TWENTY TWO UNTIL TWENTY FOURTEEN
THAT'S OVER NINETY YEARS.
NEARLY THREE HUNDRED CHILDREN
YOUNGER THAN SIX WHO WERE LIVING.
NEAR EXCITED WERE FOUND TO HAVE
HIGH BLOOD LEVELS IN.
TWO THOUSAND TWELVE THE LAST
YEAR THE X. I. PLANT WAS IN FULL
OPERATION.
THE DELAY TO SHUT THIS FACILITY
DOWN LED TO EMISSIONS FROM THE
PLANT CONTAMINATING MORE THAN.
TEN THOUSAND RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTIES ACROSS THE NUMBER OF
COMMUNITIES IN LA COUNTY.
LAST YEAR.
MYSELF AND THE MEMBERS MENTIONED --
PARTICIPATED AND CREATED AN
OVERSIGHT HEARING THAT THE STATE
LEGISLATURE HOSTED IN LOS
ANGELES I SHED LIGHT.
ON THIS CATASTROPHIC EVENT.
WITH THE INPUT OF OUR COMMUNITY.
WE DISCUSS EXCITES WRONGDOINGS
THAT HAD IMPACTED THE LIVES OF
THOUSANDS OF RESIDENTS IN OUR
COMMUNITIES.
SO MANY STILL LIVE WITH THE
CONSEQUENCES OF THE TOXIC LEAD
SEEPING INTO THEIR HOMES TILL
THIS DAY.
ASSEMBLY BILL FIFTEEN HUNDRED
IT'S A DIRECT RESPONSE TO THE
CONCERNS AND FRUSTRATIONS
EXPRESSED IN OUR COMMUNITIES. TO
THE MEMBERS OF THE STATE
LEGISLATURE.
THIS BILL IS IMPERATIVE TO
ENSURE THAT LOCAL AUTHORITIES
CLOSEST TO OUR COMMUNITIES
IMPACTED BY TOXIC.
POLLUTION.
CAN EXPEDITIOUSLY PROTECT PUBLIC
HEALTH.
AND PUBLIC SAFETY.
AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED WILL ENABLE
LOCAL JURISDICTIONS TO DIRECT
THE FACILITY OR PORTION OF A
FACILITY TO TEMPORARILY
DISCONTINUE THE OPERATIONS THAT
HAVE EXPOSED.
OUR COMMUNITIES TO HARMFUL TOXIC
MATERIALS UNTIL THAT ISSUE IS
CORRECTED.
WITH THE SUPPORT OF OUR SPONSORS
WE HAVE CRAFTED A BILL THAT
SPECIFIES THE BOARD CAN ONLY
EXERCISE.
IF THERE IS AN EMINENT THREAT OR
EVENT THAT ENDANGERS.
OUR RESIDENTS.
WE NEED TO DISCOURAGE BUSINESSES
FROM OPERATING WITHOUT PERMITS.
BUT ALSO ENSURE THAT PUBLIC
HEALTH IS OUR NUMBER ONE
PRIORITY.
IT'S NOT WAIT. FOR A REGULATORY
AGENCY TO ALLOW US TO TAKE THE
NECESSARY ACTION WHEN THE SAFETY.
OF OUR COMMUNITY IS AT STAKE.
THAT SAID OUR EXPERT SHOULD BE
CONSULTED IN PROTECTING OUR
CALIFORNIA RESIDENTS WITH THIS
IN MIND.
I WILL BE ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS TODAY THAT
WILL REQUIRE CONSULTATION
BETWEEN THE HEALTH OFFICER IN
THE PRIMARY PERMITTING AGENCIES.
I WOULD LIKE TO SINCERELY THANK
THE COMMITTEE STAFF. FOR WORKING
WITH OUR OFFICE AND STRAINING
THE TECHNICAL FRAMEWORK OF THIS
VERY IMPORTANT BILL.
I LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING MY
WORK WITH THE KNOWLEDGE WITH
KNOWLEDGEABLE STAKEHOLDERS. TO
CLARIFY IMMINENT THREAT.
AN EMINENT ENDANGERMENT.
THAT ARE REFERRED TO IN OUR
ASSEMBLY BILL. TO ENSURE THE
SCOPE OF THIS LEGISLATION IS
NARROWLY TAILORED TO MEET OUR
GOALS OF WORKING WITH THE
INDUSTRY TO PROTECT OUR
COMMUNITIES.
TODAY WE HAVE DOCTOR DOCTOR
CYRUS RANKIN DIRECTOR OF THE
BUREAU TOXICOLOGY AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ASSESSMENT -- LA
COUNTY PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT
RANDY SAWYER THE CHIEF
ENVIRONMENTAL HEALTH AND
HAZARDOUS MATERIAL OFFICER
CONTRA COSTA COUNTY.
AND I JUST DIDN'T MILAN WHO WILL
OFFER MORE -- TESTIMONY.
THANK YOU.
A PLEASE.
BOB FOUR MINUTES TOTAL.
MY NAME IS DOCTOR SIRES RANKING
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF THE BUREAU
OF TOXICOLOGY ENVIRONMENTAL
ASSESSMENT AND DEPUTY HEALTH
OFFICER THE LOS ANGELES COUNTY
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENT.
AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED IS ABOUT
STRENGTHENING THE ABILITY OF
LOCAL AUTHORITIES TO TAKE
IMMEDIATE ACTION AGAINST LOCAL
THREATS THE PUBLIC'S HEALTH AND
SAFETY WHICH IS CURRENTLY
LACKING. TO PROTECT THE PUBLIC'S
HEALTH AND SAFETY LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICERS HAVE LONGSTANDING
AUTHORITY TO IMMEDIATELY ORDER
TEMPORARY CLOSURE OF A
CONTAMINATED BEACH OR WATER
SUPPLY WITH THE CLOSURE OF A
RESTAURANT FOR INSANITARY
CONDITIONS OR TAKE ACTION
NECESSARY IN RESPONSE TO FOOD
BORNE ILLNESS OR OTHER
COMMUNICABLE DISEASE.
WILL HELP OFFICER AUTHORITY OVER
THESE ENTITIES IS TIED TO AN
ESTABLISHED UNDERSTANDING THAT
PUBLIC HEALTH DEPARTMENTS MUST
PREVENT THE SPREAD OF INFECTIOUS
DISEASES OR BIOLOGICAL THREATS
WHENEVER POSSIBLE.
HOWEVER WHEN THERE'S A CHEMICAL
THREAT TO THE THREAT OF THE
PUBLIC'S HEALTH AND SAFETY LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS LACK STATUTORY
AUTHORITY TO TAKE IMMEDIATE
ACTION AGAINST THE RESPONSIBLE
PARTIES.
IN THE ABSENCE OF A CLEAR
EMERGENCY.
AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED SEEKS TO
ALIGN HEALTH OFFICER AUTHORITY
OVER CHEMICAL THREATS WITH ITS
ESTABLISHED AUTHORITY TO STOP
BIOLOGICAL THREATS.
LA COUNTY HAS FACE NUMEROUS
CRISES IN IN WHICH RESPONSIBLE
PARTIES RELEASE CHEMICALS INTO
THE ENVIRONMENT PRESENTING A
SUBSTANTIAL ENDANGERMENT TO
LOCAL COMMUNITIES THE ABSENCE OF
A CLEAR EMERGENCY. FOR EXAMPLE
IN AUGUST TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
THE SOUTH COAST AIR QUALITY
MANAGEMENT DISTRICT'S AIR
MONITORING STATIONS REGISTERED
ELEVATED LEVELS OF CHROMIUM SIX
A KNOWN HUMAN CARCINOGEN.
IN THE CITY OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY NOW THE AGENCY DETERMINED
THAT THE ELEVATED LEVELS WERE
HIGH ENOUGH TO CAUSE LONG TERM
HEALTH RISKS BUT SINCE IT DID
NOT POSE AN IMMEDIATE RISK TO
LIFE AND HEALTH.
IT WAS NOT DECLARED AN EMERGENCY
AND DUSTED NOT DIRECTED
BUSINESSES TO CEASE THEIR
OPERATIONS.
NOW BECAUSE CHROMIUM SIX IS ONE
OF A HANDFUL OF CHEMICALS THAT
IS SCIENTIFICALLY PROVEN TO
CAUSE HUMAN CANCER.
AT THAT TIME OUR LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICER ISSUED SEVERAL PUBLIC
HEALTH DIRECTIVES TO MIDDLE
WORKING FACILITIES IN THE AREA
THAT WE'RE RESPONSIBLE FOR
ELEVATED LEVELS.
OF IF YOU COULD YOU'VE USED TO
MINUTES COULD YOU JUST SUMMARIZE
VERY QUICKLY ALL WRAPPED UP YES.
SO THIS BILL ESSENTIALLY WOULD
ALLOW LOCAL AUTHORITIES
INCLUDING THE CERTIFIED UNIFIED
PLANNING AGENCIES.
THE PROGRAM AGENCIES AND LOCAL
HEALTH OFFICERS TO TAKE
IMMEDIATE ACTION DIRECTOR OF
FACILITIES THAT POSE AN IMMINENT
AND SUBSTANTIAL ENDANGERMENT TO
PUBLIC HEALTH AND SAFETY AND TO
TEMPORARILY CEASE OPERATIONS
OTHER FACILITY OR PORTIONS OF
THEIR FACILITIES UNTIL THE ISSUE
IS CORRECT.
THANK YOU.
OKAY YOU HAVE A MAN AND A HALF
LEFT THE CHURCH JUST MULLIN FOR
THE LOCAL IN BRAMBLE HEALTH
DIRECTORS BECAUSE SPONSORING A
BILL WITH LA COUNTY AND I YIELD
MY TIME TO THE EXPECT NEXT TO ME.
THANK YOU GREAT MY NAME IS RANDY
SO HERE AS MENTIONED EARLIER AND
CHIEF ENVIRONMENTAL.
HEALTH AND HAS JUST MATERIALS
OFFICER FOR CONTRA COSTA CANYON --
AS DOCTOR AGAIN BUT SHARED AB
FIFTEEN HUNDRED WE'RE NOT GOING
STRENGTHENED LOCAL HEALTH
OFFICERS ABILITY TO MEET TAKE
IMMEDIATE ACTION AGAINST THREAT.
BUT IT ALSO STRENGTHENED ABILITY
OF THE CERTIFIED YOU KNOW BY
FIVE PROGRAMS KNOWN AS COOPER'S.
TO DIRECT THIS SILLY SAILING OR
GENERATING HAS AS WE MATURE AS A
CEASE OPERATIONS THAT FACILITY
POSES FINANCIAL OR MAKE
IMMEDIATE.
THREAT TO THE PUBLIC HEALTH AND
SAFETY.
COOPER'S REGULATE THOUSANDS OF
BUSINESS AT HAND OR GENERATE THE
HUNT -- HAZARDOUS MATERIALS
THESE BUSINESS RANGE IN SIZE
FROM A SMALL BUSINESS SUCH AS A
MACHINE SHOP.
AUTO REPAIR AND DRY CLEANERS TO
LARGER BUSINESSES INVOLVED WITH
METAL PLATING AND PROCESS AND
CHEMICAL FORMULATION -- THOMAS
GET DOWN HERE WE HAD A IN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY THERE WAS AN
INCIDENT.
WHERE -- WE OFFICIALLY
REGENERATED SUPPER GAS IT HAD A
RELEASE FROM RAIL CAR CONTAINING
OLD HIM.
AS A RESULT SUFFER TRACKSIDE
REACTED WITH WATER IN THE AIR
THE PRODUCES OPERATE CAST A
CLOUD.
OVER TWENTY THOUSAND PEOPLE
SOUGHT MEDICAL ATTENTION FROM
THIS RELEASE AFTER THE RELEASE
OCCURRED THERE WERE A SERIES OF
OTHER SMALLER RELEASES FROM THE
SAME FACILITY THEY IMPACTED
COMMUNITY.
HI RES EXAMPLE BECAUSE DURING
THESE ADVANCE WE LACK THE
ABILITY TO ACQUIRE THE SILLY TO
STOP OPERATIONS AND IS AND TO US.
CITY VALUATION COULD BE FORMER
BE PERFORMED.
SO AB FIFTEEN HUNTER WILL GRANT
US THAT THEY'RE READY TO DIRECT
SUCH A FACILITY FROM OPERATING
THEIR FACILITY.
OR PORTIONS OF THEIR FACILITY TO
CEASE OPERATIONS INTO SAFETY
EVALUATION FORM.
ADDITIONALLY AB FIFTEEN HUNDRED
HAS COMMONSENSE PROVISIONS
IMPOSE FINES AND BUSINESSES THEY
ARE SUBJECT TO COOPER LAWS BUT
OPERATE WITHOUT PERMITS.
THEIR BUSINESS IS THE HANDOVER
GENERATE HAZARDOUS MATERIALS TO
REMAIN ON REGULATED.
THEY NOT ONLY OPERATE OUTSIDE OF
THE REGULATORY FRAMEWORK BUT THE
ALSO MEETING AN UNFAIR ADVANTAGE
OVER BUSINESSES THAT ARE
COMPLIANT. TO STATE LAWS AND
REGULATIONS.
MAYBE FIFTEEN HUNDRED ENSURE
LOCAL AUTHORITIES HAVE -- THAT
THEIR THIRTY DAY ACT IN THE
INTERESTS OF BURKE CONSTANTS AND
SUCH FACILITIES THREATEN HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF OUR COMMUNITIES.
THEREFORE I URGE YOU TO PASS A
BE.
FIFTEEN HUNDRED THANK YOU ARE
GAVE AN EXTRA MINUTE.
ALL RIGHT -- LET'S SEE OTHERS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY CALMLY WITH THE
LA COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS
FOR THE ONE OF THE PROUD
SPONSORS OF THIS BILL AND I
THINK THE COMMITTEE AND THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING A SPORT
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
MICHELLE GIVEN THAT THE COUNTY
HEALTH EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA WE REPRESENT LOCAL
HEALTH DEPARTMENTS THROUGHOUT
THE STATE AND PLEASED TO BE
HEARD SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS MARIO
TRAY SERWIS I'M CURRENTLY THE
ACTING DIVISION CHIEF OF THE
HEALTH HAZARDS MATERIALS
DIVISION A LOS ANGELES COUNTY
FIRE DEPARTMENT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT -- SO I'M GLAD WE HAD
A THOROUGH DISCUSSION.
UP CAN WE HEAR FROM THE
OPPOSITION.
NO OPPOSITION OKAY GOOD A MISTER
MURATSUCHI THANK YOU -- THANK
YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRING IT IS
IMPORTANT BILL FOR IT I SEE A
NUMBER MY CITIES THAT ALREADY
SIGNED ON IN SUPPORT OF OF YOUR
BILL -- I I JUST WANT -- TO MMHM --
WELL FIRST ASK -- SO THIS THIS --
AUTHORITY DOESN'T ALREADY EXIST
IN AND CURRENT LAW.
I CAN HELP ANSWER THAT -- SO.
WHEN IT COMES TO A CHEMICAL
FACILITY RELEASING LEVELS OF A
CHEMICAL THAT ARE IMMEDIATELY
DANGEROUS TO LIFE AND HEALTH
THEN CERTAINLY OUR FIRE
DEPARTMENT CAN STEP IN ORDER
EVACUATIONS ETCETERA TO PROTECT
PUBLIC HEALTH?
HOWEVER WHEN IT COMES TO
SOMETHING LIKE THIS WHEN LEVELS
OF A CERTAIN CHEMICAL ARE BEING
RELEASED INTO COMMUNITY OVER THE
COURSE OF SEVERAL WEEKS TO
MONTHS TO YEARS -- CAUSING
CHRONIC LONG TERM HEALTH RISKS
THIS IS WHERE THERE'S A GAP
BETWEEN WITH THE FIRE
DEPARTMENTS CAN DO IN THE COOPER
S. CAN DO AND WHAT HEALTH
OFFICERS CAN DO SO THIS WOULD
GRANT THE AUTHORITY TO LOCAL
HEALTH.
HELP OFFICER TO SEIZE THOSE
OPERATIONS THAT THE OTHER
AGENCIES CANNOT TIRADES.
I JUST -- SEE ELABORATE THAT
FOUR LONG STANDING LOW IS THAT
THE PUT THE HEALTH OFFICER HAS A
POLICE POWER.
BUT THEY HAVE TO EVOKE EIGHT
LOCALS STATE OF EMERGENCY SO
THIS WHAT HE SAID THIS WOULD
CIRCUMVENT THAT PRICES IN IN A
PLACES LARGEST LA YOU DON'T.
HAD THE WHOLE COUNTY BEING IN A
STATE OF EMERGENCY BECAUSE A ONE
FACILITY A ONE LOCATION SO THIS
THIS STILL KEEPS THE STANDARD OF
IMMINENT PUBLIC HEALTH IT
DOESN'T REQUIRE THAT --
DETERMINATION OF THE STATE OF
EMERGENCY OKAY SO.
AS AS SAYS SOME MEMBERS OF THIS
COMMITTEE NO I I HAVE AN ISSUE
IN IN IN MY DISTRICT OF THE
TORTURE FINERY.
WHERE THEY USE A HIGHLY TOXIC
CHEMICAL HYDROCHLORIC ACID?
I AND MANY PEOPLE IN THE
COMMUNITY ARE ARE CONCERNED
ABOUT.
YOU KNOW AT IF THAT CHEMICAL
WERE -- TO TO TO BE RELEASED
ACCIDENTALLY RELEASED -- IT
WOULD.
TO POTENTIALLY BECAUSE DEATH AND
AND AND SERIOUS HARM TO TO
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE LIVING
WITHIN THE PERCENT OF THE
REFINERY BUT ACCORDING TO THE LA
COUNTY THE TESTIMONY YOU'RE
YOU'RE SAYING THAT.
IF FOR FOR THAT KIND OF
IMMEDIATE.
LIFE THREATENING -- THAT THAT
AUTHORITY I READ EXISTS BUT THIS
WOULD BE -- ALSO EXTEND THAT
AUTHORITY ALSO TO TO THE EXACT
TYPE SITUATIONS WHERE THERE
WOULD BE.
PERHAPS NOT IMMEDIATE HARM BUT
BUT HARM OVER A PERIOD OF TIME
THAT'S CORRECT.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ALL RIGHT -- ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA.
THANK YOU AND I THINK JUST TO
PAY YOU BACK A LITTLE BIT ON ON
YOUR QUESTION -- WE PASSED THE
A. B.. ELEVEN THIRTY TWO COUPLE
YEARS AGO THEY GAVE AIR
DISTRICTS A SIMILAR IT ALREADY
AND IT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE THAT
WE'RE EXPANDING SOMETHING LIKE
THAT FOR OUR HEALTH AGENCIES AND
WE SAW IT WITH EXCEPT THAT THEY
WERE VERY DIFFERENT AGENCIES
THAT COULD TAKE ACTION ENDED IN
BUT WE SAW.
THE WHOLE THEIR WITH CONNIE AND
SIX A AND SOME OF THE
SURROUNDING COMMUNITY SO WHEN I
THINK YOU FOR THE EXPANSION OF
THAT APPLICATION TO ANOTHER
AGENCY -- MAKES A LOT OF SENSE.
VERY GOOD OTHER QUESTIONS.
THERE BEING NO OTHER QUESTIONS --
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARILLO YOU MAY
CLOSE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AB
FIFTEEN HUNDRED IS COMMONSENSE
LEGISLATION.
THAT WILL ENABLE OUR LOCAL
AUTHORITIES TO ACT IN THE
INTEREST OF OUR CONSTITUENTS AND
BETTER PROTECT OUR COMMUNITIES
HEALTH.
AND SAFETY THIS BILL ENJOYS
BROAD SUPPORT FROM LOCAL HEALTH
EXECUTIVES LOCAL AGENCIES AND
ENVIRONMENTAL ADVOCATES AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
ALL RIGHT WE NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
MOVED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA
SECONDED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI.
NOTHING MORE NEEDED WHAT IS THE
MOTION MANAGE TO PASS. TWO
PASSES AMENDED TO APPROPRIATIONS
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM ELEVEN AB FIFTEEN
HUNDRED CARILLO THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED AND RE REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
QUIRK AYE QUIRK AYE MELENDEZ.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I'D.
BAUER-KAHAN BAUER-KAHAN HI DALY.
CRISTINA GARCIA CRISTINA GARCIA
I AM HOLDEN.
MATHIS.
MATHIS NOT VOTING WITH A TO
CHANGE THAT TO CHEAT I WE HAVE
MISTER HOLDEN WALKING IN.
THIS IS A MISS CARILLO SPELL --
GIVING FLORIDA THE WELL.
I OKAY HOLDEN AYE.
VERY GOOD.
YOU'RE OUT SICK CONGRATULATIONS
THAT'S OUT.
ALL RIGHT -- IS THIS OUR LAST.
THIS IS OUR LAST BILL.
I AM [inaudible]
FIVE THE BILL.
OKAY NOW WE'RE COOKING.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU AND I WILL
BE SHORT AND WILL ALLOW THE
EXPERTS TO ANSWER QUESTIONS IF
YOU INDULGE MAKE SOME A LITTLE
FUSSY.
THANK -- GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEMBERS IN HERE 2% AB.
SEVEN FIVE SIX WHICH YOU REQUIRE
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS IN
CALIFORNIA TOMORROW MONITOR FOR
FLORA CALL LIKE AND THE FOR THE
FOR ALL LOOK COLE WAS UP THE
SAYS THE CLASS OF CHEMICALS
KNOWN AS P. FIVE IT ALSO
REQUIRES THE PUBLIC WATER SYSTEM
TO PUBLISH.
AND KEEP CURRENT ON THE INTERNET
WATER QUALITY INFORMATION
RELATING TO REGULATED
CONTAMINANTS IN THE WATER
SYSTEMS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE I WILL.
FEED MY TEND TO THE EXPERTS
TODAY.
ALL RIGHT.
EXPERTS YOU HAVE FOUR MINUTES
TOTAL MY NAME IS SUSAN LITTLE
AND WITH THE ENVIRONMENTAL
WORKING GROUP BUT I'M HERE. TO
EXPRESS THEIR ARMOR EWG IS
SUPPORT AND CONCEPT FOR THIS
BILL AS WELL AS CLEAN WATER
ACTIONS AND JUST LET YOU KNOW
THAT WE ARE.
WORKING WITH THE AUTHOR -- TO
FURTHER PROMOTE FURTHER PURSUE
THIS PERSON PROPOSAL AND I'M
STOPPING THERE AND SEATING IF
POSSIBLE MY IT'S TIME.
TO ANNA RATE -- GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIR AND MEMBERS THANK YOU --
MY NAME IS ANNA READ I'M A
SCIENTIST WITH THE NATURAL
RESOURCES DEFENSE COUNCIL.
SCIENTISTS AND HEALTH OFFICIALS
AROUND THE WORLD -- HAVE
EXPRESSED CONCERN ABOUT THIS
CRYING CLASS OF SYNTHETIC
CHEMICALS FOR SEVERAL REASONS
THEY'RE VERY PERSISTENT WHICH
MEANS THEY DON'T BREAK DOWN THE
HIGHLY MOBILE WHICH MEANS THAT
THEY SPREAD THROUGHOUT OUR
ENVIRONMENT VERY QUICKLY.
AND THE ONES THAT WOULD HAVE
BEEN STUDIES HAVE SHOWN A WIDE
VARIETY OF HEALTH -- ADVERSE
HEALTH EFFECTS INCLUDING CANCER
HARM TO DEVELOPING FETUSES
INFANTS AND CHILDREN -- AND HARM
TO THE IMMUNE SYSTEM -- ALTHOUGH
WE DON'T HAVE HEALTH INFORMATION
ALL FORTY FIVE THOUSAND
CHEMICALS WITHIN THIS CLASS WE
DO KNOW IS THAT -- MORE COMPLEX
CHEMICALS WITHIN THIS CLASS
BREAK DOWN INTO -- OR OR INTO A
SMALL SUBGROUP OF THESE
CHEMICALS THAT WE HAVE A LOT OF
INFORMATION ON AND IN TERMS OF
THEIR TOXICITY -- AND THAT'S WHY
THE ACTING DIRECTOR OF DTS THE
EXPLAINED IN A STATE HEARING
SEVERAL WEEKS AGO THAT ALL ROADS
LEAD TO P. FAA'S WHICH IS THE
SMALL SUBGROUP.
OF P. FAST THAT WE NOW ARE
ASSOCIATED WITH -- ADVERSE
HEALTH EFFECTS -- AND WHY THE
SAFER CONSUMER PRODUCTS PROGRAM
IN CALIFORNIA IS LOOKING AT THE
ENTIRE CLASS OF THESE CHEMICALS
IN CARPET -- UNDERSTANDING THE
EXTENT OF PEANUTS CONTAMINATION
IN CALIFORNIA DRINKING WATER.
IS AN AND ENTERING THE IMPORTANT
STEP IN OUR PROTECT IN
CALIFORNIANS FROM EXPOSURE TO
THESE TOXIC CHEMICALS.
ARE BASED ON NATIONAL MONITORING
FOUR YEARS AGO -- THEIR
APPROXIMATE THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION CALIFORNIANS ABOUT 10%
OF OUR POPULATION THAT ARE
DRINKING P. FAST CONTAMINATED
WATER.
HOWEVER THIS IS ACTUALLY --
LIKELY A UNDERESTIMATE -- OF THE
THE EXTENT OF CONTAMINATION OF
OUR DRINKING WATER THIS IS
BECAUSE NATIONAL TESTING -- HAS
SEVERAL LIMITATIONS THEIR
REPORTING LIMITS WERE VERY HIGH
HIGHER THAN LEVELS THAT ARE OF
HEALTH CONCERN.
ARE THERE WERE ONLY A FEW P.
FAST TESTED.
FOR TOM AND IT FOCUSED ON LARGER
SYSTEMS OVER TEN THOUSAND PEOPLE
START.
WHICH MEANS THAT THERE COULD BE
SIGNIFICANTLY MORE I
CALIFORNIANS DRINKING PEOPLE'S
CONTAMINATED WATER THAN WE KNOW
NOW. FOR REFERENCE -- WHEN
MICHIGAN EXPANDED -- IT'S
TESTING FOR BEFORE US IN ITS OWN
WATER.
THEY FOUND ESTIMATES FOR
AFFECTED POPULATION WENT FROM
UNDER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
PEOPLE TO OVER ONE POINT FIVE
MILLION PEOPLE.
THERE'S A HANDOUT THAT -- WAS
SENT OUT -- IF THERE'S TIME I
CAN GO THROUGH A QUICK OR CAN
SKIP YOU HAVE ANOTHER.
MINUTE AND FIFTEEN SECONDS.
BASICALLY IT SHOWS IN THE AND
THE THE FIRST MAP SHOWS THE
RESULTS FROM THE NATIONAL
TESTING.
THE SECOND MAP SHOWS FROM WHEN
CAP A MICHIGAN DID THEIR OWN
TESTING WHERE THEY TESTED ALL OF
THE PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS.
AND THEY ALSO DID SITE
INVESTIGATIONS BASED OFF OF
SITES WHERE -- THEY THOUGHT THEY
WOULD BE RISK OF CONTAMINATION
THEY FOUND OVER -- FIVE FORTY
CONTAMINATION SITES NUMBER
HUNDRED THEIR PUBLIC WATER
SYSTEMS WERE AFFECTED -- THIS
COMPARISON REALLY HIGHLIGHTS HOW
IMPORTANT COMPREHENSIVE TESTING
IS FOR UNDERSTANDING -- THE
CONTAMINATION EXISTS IN OUR
WATER -- THAT WE AND OUR
FAMILIES DRINK EVERY DAY -- AND
TO WRAP UP AS THE THIS BILL
MOVES FORWARD WE SUPPORT THE
CONCEPT OF EXPANDED MONITORING
AND WE WOULD LIKE TO SEE THAT
THE FOCUSES ON THE ENTIRE CLASS
NOT JUST ONE CHEMICAL AT THE
TIME -- THAT THERE IS A ANNUAL
TESTING OF ALL CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
WATER SYSTEMS AT TO COMPLEMENT
THE SITE INVESTIGATIONS THAT ARE
GOING ON WITH THAT BY THE STATE
WATER RESOURCES CONTROL BOARD.
AND THAT THE MOST CURRENT
TESTING METHODS ARE USED.
TO CAPTURE THE GREATEST NUMBER
OF PEOPLE US -- AT HEALTH
RELEVANT LEVELS ON THANK YOU AND
WE LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WITH
THE AUTHOR AND WITH THE
COMMITTEE AS THIS BILL MOVES
TOWARD.
ALL RIGHT -- OTHERS IN SUPPORT.
NGUYEN COMMISSAIRE CLUB
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT.
ANY IN OPPOSITION.
ALL RIGHT WELL -- THE NEXT ITEM.
WILL BE QUESTIONS FROM MEMBERS
[inaudible]
BEAR.
I WAS GONNA MAKE SIMPLY MEMBER
BAUER CA HAGEN LEON -- YOU MADE
A MOTION AS THEIR SECOND
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT WE HAVE A MOTION AND A
SECOND -- QUESTIONS.
SO WERE WERE RAT DEALING WITH
THE P. FAST [inaudible]
SO.
OUR FIRST OF ALL THEIR NUMBER OF
SORT OF DRAFTING SORTS OF ISSUES
THAT WE HAVE HERE IN THE LIST
AND I KNOW YOU WORK WITH US AND
THOSE -- AND THIS IS A QUESTION
FOR THE TECHNICAL EXPERT.
SO WHAT THE WATER BOARD DO IS
DOING RIGHT NOW IT'S TESTING FOR
TO CHEMICALS.
THERE IS A METHOD. TO TEST FOR
SIXTEEN OTHERS.
IT IS NOT CLEAR TO ME WHY WHEN
THERE WAS ACTUALLY WITH THE TIME
IT WAS DONE IT WAS ONLY TWELVE
OTHERS BUT THERE'S COMING UP A
NEW.
A NEW TEST WHICH SHOULD LAST
SIXTY NOW THERE'S BUT WE DON'T
KNOW WHEN THAT'LL BE CERTIFIED
SO THE POINT IS THERE ARE
THERE'S NOW [inaudible]
ON YOU THINK WHY IS IT IMPORTANT
TO LOOK AT THE CLASS IS A WHOLE
WHEN WE DON'T HAVE A METHOD OF
DOING THAT.
SO WHAT WE MEAN BY LOOKING AT
THE CLASS AS A WHOLE IS TO TAKE
A CLASS BASED APPROACH SO TO
THINK ABOUT THE CLASS AS A WHOLE.
CLASS CONCERN OBVIOUSLY WORKING
WITH IN THE TECHNICAL
FEASIBILITY IS THAT WE HAVE NOW
SO -- ACTUALLY THE WATER BOARD
IN ITS SITE INVESTIGATION SO
IT'S DURING A PHASE FRIGHTENED
OF MASTICATION ONE THAT MEANS IS
THAT THEY'RE GONNA LOOK AT SITES
WHERE WE THINK WE KNOW THERE'S
KIND CONTAMINATION.
BASED OFF OF PREVIOUS USE SO FOR
INSTANCE NEAR.
DOT SITES -- AND WHAT THEY'RE
GOING TO BE DOING IS ACTUALLY
TESTING.
FOR THAT THE WHAT WITH THE EPA
METHOD WHICH WOULD BE FOURTEEN
P. FASTER NOT JUST LOOKING AT
THE FILE MP FAST -- FOR PUBLIC
WATER SYSTEMS THEY HAVE
NOTIFICATION LEVELS ARE IN TERM
NOTIFICATION LEVELS FOR JUST
THOSE TWO AND THAT'S BECAUSE
THEY WERE ASKED -- TO THAT
THAT'S THE FIRST STEP THAT THEY
COULD TAKE RATES OF THE WATER
BOARD ASK THEM WHAT WOULD BE ARE.
ASKED WE HOW WHAT WOULD BE IN
TERM LEVELS FOR THESE TWO BASED
OFF OF WHAT THE OTHER
INFORMATION OUT THERE AND THEY
BASED IT OFF NEW JERSEY'S.
RISK ASSESSMENTS THAT THAT
THEY'VE ALREADY DONE -- WE HAS
NOW DOING ITS OWN ASSESSMENT OF
THOSE TWO CHEMICALS BUT THE
WATER BOARD -- CAN ASK THEM TO
DO THAT AT SET IN TERM LEVELS --
A NOTIFICATION NOVELS FOR THE
OTHERS AS WELL SO BUT THE
QUESTION IS -- WHAT IS THE
ADVANTAGE OF REQUIRING THE --
WATER UTILITIES TO TO ALSO TEST
FOR THE OTHER CHEMICALS CAN BE
DETECTED RAINY OTHER.
TWELVE THE SITE INVESTIGATIONS --
WILL LOOK AT WHAT WE THINK WILL
BE USED AREAS OF CONTAMINATION
BUT FROM LOOKING OUR MICHIGAN
DID -- BECAUSE THEY'VE DONE THE
MOST COMPREHENSIVE TESTING IN
THE NATION -- WHAT THEY FOUND
WAS THERE THE TWO DON'T ALWAYS
MATCH UP SO BASED OFF OF
HISTORICAL INFORMATION THEY WENT
INSIDE INVESTIGATION FROM THE
FOUND OVER FORTY PLUS
CONTAMINATION SITES WITHIN STATE?
WHEREVER THERE ARE SOME -- AND
THEN BUT THEY ALSO SURVEYS ALL
OF THE PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS AND
WHAT YOU SEE IS THERE ARE SOME
PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS THAT DON'T
HAVE CONTAMINATION -- BUT THERE
ARE SITES WITHIN THAT AREA THAT
ARE CONTAMINATED NOTS PROBABLY
BECAUSE THAT PUBLIC WATER SYSTEM
HAS A SOURCE THAT ISN'T
NECESSARILY AFFECTED BY A YET
BUT THAT AREAS SERVED BY -- WELL
WATER.
AND THEN VICE VERSA -- THERE ARE
WORDS PUBLIC WATER CONTAMINATION
UP PUBLIC WATER SYSTEM
CONTAMINATION THAT WASN'T
PROTECTED BY AT A SITE SO FOR
INSTANCE IF YOU LOOK AT THE MAP
YEAH BUT THE QUESTION IS.
I THAT'S ALL FINE BUT YOU'RE NOT
ANSWERING THE QUESTION OF WHY.
WE WOULD ASK THE PUBLIC WATER
COMPANIES. TO TEST.
FOR FOURTEEN RATHER THAN TO AND
REPORT ON TO RATHER THAN
FOURTEEN RIGHT WHAT IS THE
ADVANTAGE OF GOING IT WILL THIS
SHOW SOMETHING DIFFERENT THAT IS
REALLY THE QUESTION.
RIGHT SO WHAT WE SEE AS BAD AND
PEOPLE'S BLOOD THERE ARE THAT
WE'VE SEEN -- AT LEAST FOUR
DIFFERENT BE FAST THAT ARE
COMMON THROUGHOUT -- PEOPLE'S
BLOOD IN IN NATIONALLY SO THAT
MEANS WERE BEING EXPLORED
EXPOSED TO MORE THAN JUST THOSE --
TWO ALSO WHAT WE SEE IS THAT A
LOT OF THESE CHEMICALS AYE OCCUR --
TOGETHER AND WATER THEY DON'T
IT'S NOT THAT IT'S RARE THAT
THERE'S ONLY P. PHí
FOSS AND WATER.
AND ALSO -- THE CDC HAS -- COME
UP WITH NUMBERS FOR MORE THAN
JUST BE PHONE BEFORE US IN TERMS
OF HOW OKAY SO I STILL HAVEN'T
HEARD FOR A REASON AND I WHY WE
NEED TO TEST.
AND GET REPORTS ON THE OTHER
DOESN'T I I STILL HAVEN'T HEARD
THAT FROM YOU BECAUSE YOU'RE
SAYING THAT.
THE THING IS HER.
IN ARE THE SAME.
THE SAME THINGS OCCUR.
THAT P. FOSS BE FAST.
THESE OTHER CHEMICALS ARE LIKELY
TO BE THERE TOO SO WHY DO WE
NEED TO TEST THE OTHER.
FOURTEEN THAT'S THAT'S THE
QUESTION I'M TRYING TO GET AN
ANSWER TO BECAUSE THE RATIOS ARE
ALWAYS THE SAME SO THE LEVELS OF
CONTAMINATION BETWEEN SO THERE
ARE SITES WHERE THERE WILL BE
MORE LIKELY TO HAVE SHORT CHAINS
THEN LONG CHAINS THAT WILL
CHANGE THE TYPE OF TREATMENT
THAT NEEDS. TO BE USED.
ALSO IT GIVES US A BETTER IDEA
OF THE TYPE OF CONTAMINATION
THAT WE'RE WORKING WITH AND WHAT
CHEMICALS WOULD NECESSARILY BE
MORE IMPORTANT TO ADDRESS BASED
OFF OF THE EXPOSURES THAT WAY
OKAY AND YOU WOULD GET THIS BY
LOOKING AT THESE OTHER TWELVE
CHEMICALS.
OKAY.
THANK YOU.
MR MATHIS THANK YOU ITS
DISSOLUTION THE DISCUSSION WHEN
IT MAKES SENSE TO TEST THE TO
WIN AND IF IT DOES COME UP THEN
DO FURTHER TESTING.
VERSUS SPENDING THE MONEY.
IN ENFORCING THE LOCALS A SPEND
THE MONEY TO TO TEST.
SEVERAL WHEN WE KNOW OKAY IF WE
JUST USED TO IS AS YOU SAID IN
YOUR STATEMENT.
THAT OFTEN THE OTHERS ARE THERE
STILL.
LIKE I SAID BEFORE -- THERE ARE.
ALL CONTAMINATION SITUATIONS ARE
NOT THE SAME SO WHEN YOU LOOK AT
IT INTO THE DETAILED DATA ON IN
MICHIGAN THERE ARE SOME SITES
WHERE THEY HAVE A LOT OF OTHER
TYPES OF THE FAUCET NOT P. FILL
MP FOSTER'S.
TO AND THEN THERE'S OTHER SITES
WORK FOR DOMINATED BY PEOPLE ON%
THE FAUCET NOT THE OTHERS AND
THE REASON WHY IT'S IMPORTANT IS
BECAUSE THE TREATMENT IS
DIFFERENT. FOR THE DIFFERENT
TYPES OF P. FIVE NINE WE'VE DONE
WE ALL UNDERSTAND THE THE
TREATMENTS ARE DIFFERENT IT'S
GONNA HAVE CONTAMINATION AND
WE'RE TESTING FOR TWO TYPES.
THAT WE KNOW OKAY NOW IT'S
CONTAMINATED WE HAVE TESTS TO
SEE WHAT ELSE IS IN THERE.
IN A ONE TRIGGERS THE OTHER.
BUT YOU YOU'RE SAYING TO GO
AHEAD AND JUST.
THERE WOULD LIKELY THERE WOULD
BE SITES WHERE YOU CAN YOU CAN
YOU BETTER SPEAK INTO THE
MICROPHONE BECAUSE WE'RE
RECORDING THIS AND I KNOW.
YOU WANT TO TALK TO THE PERSON
IS AND I HAVE A QUESTION.
HE CAN HEAR YOU AND THE AUDIENCE
AND THE PEOPLE WHO IN THE
AUDIENCE AND THE GROUP THAT'S
LISTENING TO THE BROADCAST
CANCER JUST TALK INTO THE
MICROPHONE.
RIGHT SO THERE ARE WITH THEIR
WILL THERE ARE SITUATIONS WHERE
WE'VE SEEN THAT THERE ARE OTHER
TYPES OF P..
COSTS WITHIN THE FOURTEEN ARMED
THAT HAVE SHOWN UP BUT NOT WOULD
NOT BEEN PROTECTED BY -- HE FELL
AND THE FAST THE TO OKAY
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
WHAT WAS THAT AND SHE SAID WHAT
I WAS GONNA SAY [inaudible]
OKAY -- ALL RIGHT.
OTHER QUESTIONS.
MADAM VICE CHAIR DO WANNA
ANYTHING -- WHITE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I'M
JUST I HAVE SOME CONCERNS WITH
THE FACT THAT THERE IS -- A
CUSTOMER WARNING IF YOU WILL
IT'S REQUIRED UNDER THIS BILL
EVEN THOUGH THE LEVEL MAY NOT.
RISE TO THE LEVEL OF IN A
WARNING. FOR FOR HEALTH REASONS
AND I'M JUST
TRYING TO IT.
I DO HAVE SOME CONCERNS THAT YOU
KNOW YOU'RE GONNA HAVE BECAUSE
SOME PARENTS TO PANIC.
OUT THERE THANK YOU AS SO IT'S
ONLY IF IT TRIGGERS THE
NOTIFICATION LEVEL SO WE HAVE IN
OUR NO THEY GET NOTIFICATION A
LIST RIGHT NOW UNTIL WE HIT
THOSE LEVELS.
THAT'S WHEN WE DO BE DISCLOSED
IN THE SAME WE HAVE OTHER
CHEMICALS THAT ONCE A YEAR YOU
GET IN YOUR BILL AT DISCLOSURE
OF WHAT WAS TRIGGERED TO WHAT
EXCEEDED A CERTAIN LEVEL IF WE
ARE GETTING.
SO THAT'S WILL BE TRIGGERED IN
THIS CASE TO SAID THE ENRON
LEVEL WOULD HAVE TO BE TRIGGERED
FOR YOU TO GET THE NOTIFICATION.
OKAY THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT UP IF THERE KNOW WHAT
THE QUESTIONS ARE I'D LIKE TO
ASK YOU TO CLOSE YES -- I WANT
TO THANK THE COMMITTEE FOR
WORKING WITH AS OF THE CHAIR AND
I HAVE A COMMITMENT TO CONTINUE
TO WORK ON THIS CLOSELY AND MAKE
SURE THAT HIS CONCERNS ARE
ADDRESSED BEFORE WE GO ANY
FURTHER -- AND I APOLOGIZE FOR
MY LACK OF ENTHUSIASM BUT THIS
IS A REALLY IMPORTANT BILL -- I
STARTED TO LOOK AT EXCITED WHICH
LED TO AN ARTICLE ABOUT PLANT
WHICH LED TO AN ARTICLE ABOUT
MICHIGAN WHICH LEFT LED TO A
STUDY.
AT THE FEDERAL LEVEL AND AN
ENGAGING MATH OR ALL OF THE
PEOPLE THAT WE HAVE DETECTED IN
LA COUNTY IS IN MY DISTRICT.
ARE AND SO WANT TO MAKE SURE
WE'RE NOT WAITING THIRTY YEARS
LIKE WITH EXCITE OR TEN YEARS
LIKE WITH COME IN SIX AND WE'RE
BEING PRACTICE WHERE WE CAN BE.
IN TRYING TO FIND THAT SPACE WE
HAVE SOME WORK TO DO BUT
COMMITTED TO CONTINUE TO DO THAT
WORK.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
OKAY SO -- THERE'S A LIST OF
THINGS WILL BE WORKING ON IN
ADDITION.
I WILL BE CHECKING WITH THE
WATER BOARD ON THESE OTHER ITEMS
AND ASSUMING THAT YOUR EXPERTISE
CORRECT AND WILL DEFINITELY I'LL
BE SUPPORTING THAT SO -- LET'S
SEE WE HAD THEIR MOTION.
WE HAVE A MOTION AND A SECOND SO
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
THIS IS ITEM FIVE AB SEVEN FIFTY
SIX CRISTINA GARCIA THE MOTION
IS DO PASS AND RE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS
QUIRK.
HI QUIRK I MELENDEZ MULLIN DOES
NOT VOTING BLOOM.
BLOOM I BAUER-KAHAN BAUER-KAHAN
HI DALY.
CRISTINA GARCIA HI I CRISTINA
GARCIA I HOLDEN.
HOLDEN AYE [inaudible]
MATHIS.
WHAT A TO G. READ SWITCHING HI?
SIX WE HAVE SIX VOTES WINS OUT
OKAY VERY GOOD BILL IS -- ALL
RIGHT NOW WE'RE GOING -- TO
WE'RE GOING -- TO HAVE THE ADD
ONS.
AND I THINK ALL THE BILLS ARE
OUT NOW.
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT WE'LL START WITH OUR
AND WE KNOW THAT MISTER DALI
WILL NOT RETURN NOR WILL MISTER
BLOOM.
AND MATHIS OKAY.
THIS STILL CALL THEM BUT WE
WON'T WAIT FOR THEM.
I THINK EVERYONE ELSE IS HERE.
SEVEN A START WITH THE CONSENT
CALENDAR -- THAT'S AT SEVEN ZERO
RIGHT NOW -- BAUER-KAHAN HI
BAUER-KAHAN I DALY ELISE NOT
VOTING SO THAT'S EIGHT ZERO ALL
RIGHT.
THIS IS ITEM ONE AB TWO
SEVENTEEN EDUARDO GARCIA THE
VOTE IS AT FIVE TWO BAUER-KAHAN.
BAUER-KAHAN I ONLY WENT MISSING
[inaudible]
SIX TWO GOOD.
THIS IS ITEM TO A. B. ONE THIRTY
FOUR BLOOM.
THE VOTE IS AT FIVE ZERO
BAUER-KAHAN.
BAUER-KAHAN I DALY DOES NOT
VOTING.
SET [inaudible]
SIX ZERO RIGHT.
THESE ARE ADULTS.
THIS IS ITEM THREE AB TWO
SEVENTY FOUR MATHIS.
THE VOTE IS AT SIX ZERO MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ AYE DALY TELL IS NOT
VERY [inaudible]
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN HI SELECT BRINGS THE VOTE.
TO EIGHT ZERO THIS IS ITEM FIVE
AB SEVEN FIFTY SIX CRISTINA
GARCIA.
THE VOTE IS AT SIX ZERO DELI
IT'S NOT VOTING AND MATHIS IS
OFFERING SO HE'S GOING TO SET
STAYS AT SIX HERE.
ITEM SIX AB.
EIGHT FORTY ONE TEN VOTES AT SIX
ZERO MELENDEZ MELINDA'S HI
DAWALY DELIS NOT VOTING HOLDEN.
HOLDEN IS HI SO THAT'S EIGHT
ZERO VERY GOOD.
ITEM EIGHT AB.
ELEVEN TWENTY THREE ITEM SEVEN I
BELIEVE IS A CONSENT -- I DON'T
YES ITEM SEVEN WITH A PULLED IT
WAS AB NINE TWELVE MURATSUCHI
YEAH.
ITEM.
EIGHT IS AB ELEVEN TWENTY THREE
RAY S. -- THE VOTE IS AT FIVE
ONE RIGHT NOW MELENDEZ.
MULLIN IS NO.
DALY IS NOT VOTING.
HOLDEN HOLDEN HI.
THAT BRINGS THE VOTE
[inaudible]
TO SIX TO VERY GOOD.
ITEM NINE AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
FRIEDMAN.
THE VOTE IS AT SIX ZERO MELENDEZ
MELENDEZ HI DAWALY NOT VOTING
HOLDEN.
HOLDEN HI THAT BRINGS IT.
TO EIGHT ZERO ITEM ELEVEN IS AB
FIFTEEN HUNDRED GOT REAL.
THE VOTE IS AT SIX ZERO MELENDEZ.
MULIN DOES NOT VOTING DALLY NOT
VOTE SO IT STAYS AT SIX ITEM
THIRTEEN IS AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
EIGHT BLOOM.
VOTES AT FIVE TWO DELHI DELHI
VOTING HOLDEN.
HOLDEN HI AT SIX TWO KNOTS
[inaudible]
ALL RIGHT.
OKAY BAG MOTION TO ADJOURN
[inaudible]
SECOND.
ALL RIGHT.
RIGHT STOP.
WHAT'S A MAN.
OKAY -- VOTE CHANGE ALL RIGHT
THAT'S FINE.
YEAH WE WANNA JOURNEY
[inaudible]
YEAH [inaudible]
PLEASE.
WE'RE CHANGE CHANGING A VOTE ON
ITEM NUMBER ONE AB TWO SEVENTEEN
EDUARDO GARCIA.
MELENDEZ FROM NOT VOTING TO KNOW.
ITEM.
THIRTEEN SHE AB SEVENTEEN EIGHTY
A BLOOM.
FROM NOT VOTING TO KNOW THIS IS
MELINDA SNOT VOTING TO NOW ON
SEVENTEEN EIGHTY EIGHT ALL RIGHT
I THINK WE'RE DONE.
OKAY GREAT WE'RE DONE -- I MOVE
WE ADJOURN.
ALL RIGHT SHE SECONDS.
ALL RIGHT WE'RE DONE